WELCOME MISTER FRAZIER UP TO
THAT DíAS WE ARE NOW.
TRANSITIONING FROM A AT BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE SIX HEARING TO AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
ALONG WITH.
ASSEMBLY TRANSPORTATION ALONG
WITH THE ASSEMBLY ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMITTEE -- AND WE'RE GOING TO
ASK FOR THE FIRST PANEL FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES.
TO COME ON UP
[inaudible]
AT THE THANK YOU SO NOW WE ARE
GOING TO BE BEGINNING THE
OVERSIGHT HEARING ON DEPARTMENT
OF MOTOR VEHICLES SO I WAS GONNA
ASK MY TO FELLOW CULTURES AS
WELL AS OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
IF THEY HAD ANY.
OPENING COMMENTS SO.
MR PETROU NORSE.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
I THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE WITH
US I'D THIS AFTERNOON AND I
THINK THANK YOU FOR STOPPING IN
TO THIS VERY IMPORTANT ROLE. FOR
AT THE DMV AND AND FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA LOOK FOR TO AN
UPDATE ON NINE ON THE PROGRESS
THAT'S BEEN MADE SO FAR AND
PLANS FOR HOW WE CONTINUE TO TO
MOVE THE DEPARTMENT FORWARD.
IN THE FUTURE -- AND I DO
APPRECIATE ALL THE HARD WORK
THAT TO ADD THAT YOU AND YOUR
TEAM HAVE PUT INTO.
I TRYING TO TRANSFORM THIS
DEPARTMENT FOR CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU.
THANK MISS FRAZIER.
MR TING THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
FOR INVITING ME TO JOIN YOUR
COMMITTEE TODAY -- AT THIS
HEARING.
AS I SAID LAST YEAR'S JOINT
HEARING IN MANY WAYS THE DMV IS
THE FACE OF CALIFORNIA'S
GOVERNMENT.
IT IS THE AGENCY THAT
CALIFORNIA'S MOST OFTEN INTERACT
IN SOME WITH IN SOME WAY.
WHETHER IT'S FOR VEHICLE
REGISTRATION OBTAINING A
DRIVER'S LICENSE OR RENEWING A
DRIVER'S LICENSE.
GOING FORWARD.
SINCE OUR HEARING LAST AUGUST
WE'VE SEEN A MODEST.
IMPROVEMENT AT THE DMV WAIT
TIMES ARE DOWN ABOUT AN AVERAGE
OF AN HOUR.
THIS IS LARGELY DUE TO THE FACT
THAT OVER ONE THOUSAND NEW
EMPLOYEES HAVE BEEN HIRED AT
FIELD OFFICES.
DMV IS ALSO EXPAND THE USE OF
CHAOS TO GIVE CONSUMERS MORE
OPTIONS FOR COMPLETING THEIR
VEHICLE REGISTRATIONS.
DMV IN THE ADMINISTRATION HAVE
BEEN MORE RESPONSIVE TO THE
LEGISLATURE THAN THEY EVER HAVE
BEEN.
IN FACT THE ENVY IS PROVIDING
MONTHLY WAIT TIME REPORTS TO US.
RECENTLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS COMPLETED AN
EXTENSIVE REVIEW OF THE
CHALLENGES DMV IS FACING.
MORE IMPORTANTLY THE NEW
ADMINISTRATION IS MADE DMV A
PRIORITY WHICH I APPRECIATE IS
THE CHAIR.
SO FAR I'VE BEEN IMPRESSED BY
GOVERNOR NEWSOME AND THE DMV
STRIKE TEAMS EFFORTS TO MAKE
MUCH NEEDED REFORMS.
THAT BEING SAID I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT THE AMOUNT OF RESOURCES
DMV IS CURRENTLY REQUESTING. FOR
THE COMING YEAR.
SIMPLY ADDING MORE EMPLOYEES IS
NOT ENOUGH AS THE DEPARTMENT --
FINANCE ON IT HIGHLIGHTS.
DMV IS HAS TO TAKE MORE STEPS TO
MAKE SURE THE USER EXISTING
WORKFORCE IN A MORE EFFECTIVE
MANNER.
FURTHER WELL WAIT TIMES ARE DOWN
WHAT FROM LAST SUMMER THEY HAVE
YET TO MEET THE THE FORTY FIVE
MINUTE GOAL THAT THEY HAD SAT.
I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
THE STRIKE TEAM.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
ACTING DIRECTOR KATHLEEN WEB
WHOSE I'VE HAD MANY MEETINGS
WITH AND I APPRECIATE HER TAKING
THIS ON AND HOW WE GET AS THE
LEGISLATURE CAN.
BECOME A PARTNER.
WITH THE NEW ADMINISTRATION
FIXING THE AGENCY SO MANY OF US
CAN INTERACT ON A REGULAR BASIS
INSTEAD OF WHEN IT'S CONSIDERED.
EMERGENCY.
THANK YOU MISTER TAKE.
THANK MISTER ANY OTHER COMMENTS
OPENING COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
MR BLOOM.
THANK YOU MISTER AT AND MISTER
CHAIR AND I APOLOGIZE FOR BEING
A LITTLE BIT LATE BUT THIS IS
ONE OF THOSE DAYS IS IN THAT --
THE DMV HAS BEEN HAVING ONE OF
THOSE DAYS FOR COUPLE HERE SO
NOW AND AND I WANT TO BE
PROACTIVE AND HELPFUL IN.
FIGURING OUT HOW WE CAN MOVE THE
DEPARTMENT FORWARD WILL BE
SPENDING CUT CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT
OF TIME PROVIDING OVERSIGHT IN
REVIEWING THE OF THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL -- I IN MY
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE CONVERSATION HERE
TODAY AND AND OF THE HOURS THAT
WILL SPEND TOGETHER IN COMMITTEE.
I THINK THIS BILL MISS SMITH.
THANK YOU TO OUR CHAIRS TODAY
AND I I ACKNOWLEDGE THE COMMENTS --
FROM MY COLLEAGUE UNFORTUNATELY
I THINK MINE IS ONE OF THE
DISTRICTS PERHAPS WHERE WE
HAVEN'T SEEN SIGNIFICANT
IMPROVEMENT -- FROM THE DAY THAT
I WAS FIRST WORN IN A NUMBER OF
OUR CONSTITUENT CALL THE DOCTOR
VERY SIGNIFICANT NUMBER HAVE
BEEN DIEM BE RELATED AND HAS
BEEN POINTED OUT BY MY
COLLEAGUES HERE. FOR MANY THAT
IS THEIR FIRST AND SOMETIMES
ONLY INTERACTION WITH OUR
STATE'S GOVERNMENT AND SO -- I
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
BE HERE TODAY MY COLLEAGUES IN
ON PUTTING THIS PANEL TOGETHER.
AND AND ESSENTIALLY YOU KNOW
WHAT I'M HERE TO SAY IS HELP ME
HELP YOU.
BECAUSE I'VE EVEN ASK MYSELF I
HAVE BEEN RECENT VISIT TO THE
DMV TO GET MY REAL ID I SAID
WHAT ARE THE BARRIERS WHAT ARE
THE SILOS WHAT ARE THE THINGS
THAT WE NEED TO HELP WITH.
THAT ALLOWS YOU TO SERVE OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR
CONSTITUENCIES BETTER SO I THINK
YOU -- FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE TODAY TO MY COLLEAGUES AND
I APPRECIATE THAT YOU'RE HERE
WILLING TO TESTIFY.
THANK YOU MISTER.
NEITHER OPENING COMMENTS.
LET ME TO START VERY QUICKLY
THIS IS A FOLLOW UP HEARING FROM
OUR HEARING.
IN AUGUST SOME OF YOU ARE HERE
AGAINST MOVE YOUR NEW TO THAT
HEARING BUT JUST TO REFRESH
EVERYONE'S MEMORY -- THAT
HEARING WAS HELD BECAUSE OF THE
ATROCIOUS WAIT TIMES THAT WERE
OCCURRING ALL AROUND THE STATE.
NOT JUST IN MY DISTRICT OF SAN
FRANCISCO BUT REALLY IN EVERY
PART OF THE STATE AND
UNFORTUNATELY -- THE DEPARTMENT --
WAS LATE TO THE GAME AND REALLY
REACTING HAVING A PLAN -- I DO
WANT TO COMMEND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ON THEIR VERY GOOD AUDIT
THAT THEY JUST FINISHED.
ABOUT UNFORTUNATE WHEN WE HEAR
LAST IN AUGUST THERE WERE
APPROPRIATION REQUEST.
WE DID OUR PART IN MAKING SURE
THAT THE BUDGET THAT WAS PASSED
IN JUNE HAD APPROPRIATE.
APPROPRIATION WE ALSO DID OUR
PART TO DO AUGMENTATION LATER ON
IN THE FALL.
UNFORTUNATELY SOME OF THAT
AUGMENTATION WENT TO STAFF THE
STAFF WERE HIRED WITH THE AUDIT
DEMONSTRATED WAS.
THE STAFF PORTRAIT.
SO IT JUST IN MY EYES SMALL
OBSERVATION STOP THAT WERE
DEPLOYED AT DIFFERENT OFFICES
WERE EITHER STANDING AROUND
REALLY NOT ABLE TO DO -- THE
MOST BASIC DUTIES THEY WERE JUST
STANDING AROUND HANDING OUT
FORMS RATHER THAN ACTUALLY BEING
BEHIND THE COUNTER -- TRAINED ON
THE COMPUTERS ABLE TO SERVE IN
PROCESS CUSTOMERS -- WE WERE
TOLD BY BY THEN -- BY THE DâN
DIRECTOR THAT ONE OF THE
SOLUTIONS AROUND WAIT TIMES WAS
EVERY.
EVERY -- FIELD OFFICE WAS GONNA
GET WAS GONNA GET TABLETS OF THE
TABLETS GOING TO BE USE REAL
TIME TO REALLY HELP MANAGE WAIT
TIMES WHAT WE FIND.
WE FOUND THAT YES THE TABLETS
WERE PURCHASED.
BUT THEN NOT USED.
SO AGAIN IF WE APPROVE NEW
COMPUTERS AND YOU BY THE NEW
COMPUTERS IS GREAT BUT THE JUST
SIT IN THE BOX IN YOUR DMV FIELD
OFFICES I DON'T KNOW HOW THAT
MEETS -- OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT.
WHAT THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE?
SPENT ON IN ADDITION WE TALKED
ABOUT SHE SHE VERY PROBABLY
TALKED ABOUT THE TEXTING
SOFTWARE THAT WAS TO BE USED AT
THE FIELD OFFICES.
SO AGAIN SOFTWARE WAS USED.
SOFTWARE WAS I PURCHASED SO SO
THE LICENSES I ASSUME WERE THERE.
WE GUESS WHAT.
THEY WERE USED.
SO THE QUESTION COMING BEFORE
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE IS.
YOU HAVE.
A 10220% -- REQUEST. TO TO
INCREASE YOUR BUDGET BY 10220%
YOUR BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET. TO
BE INCREASED BY TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS.
COM.
HOW HOW CAN YOU GIVE US THE
CONFIDENCE THAT THEY WILL BE
SPENT CORRECTLY?
AND IT WILL BE SPENT EFFICIENTLY --
WALL ARE -- TRANSPORTATION
CHURCH CORRECT -- THE WAIT TIMES
ARE DOWN SO THAT'S GOOD -- WE
ALSO KNOW THAT MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE COULD BE COMING
IN FOR REAL ID'S.
SO WHAT'S THE PLAN FOR THE NEXT
TWO FIVE YEARS TO REALLY --
DEPLOY RESOURCES WE WE SAW --
WHAT'S PLAN TO IMPLEMENT THE
FINANCE ON ITS RECOMMENDATION
AND I GUESS WHO ARE WE GIVING
THE MONEY.
TO SO THE PREVIOUS DIRECTOR.
WHO IS NO LONGER HERE DECIDE TO
RETIRE WHICH I THINK WAS A SMART
MOVE BEFORE COMING BACK TO THIS
COMMITTEE -- SWORE TO US THAT
THEY WERE IMPLEMENTING ALL THESE
THINGS.
AND THEN HIGH TAILED IT OUT OF
TOWN.
AND DIDN'T DIDN'T DO IT.
SO WHY SHOULD WE GIVE YOU AN
ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS OF RESOURCES TO SPEND ON
TO SPEND ON TABLETS THAT'S IN
THE CLOSET AND TO SPEND ON
SOFTWARE THAT'S NOT USED IN TO
SPEND ON PEOPLE THAT ARE TRAINED.
SO IF YOU COULD ANSWER THOSE
QUESTIONS -- WOULD WELCOME NOT
TO THE IN THIS COMMITTEE --
AGAIN WE HAVE A NUMBER OF PANELS
AND SEGMENTS SO WE'RE WE'RE
GONNA BE A FIRST JUST GETTING
SOME BACKGROUND -- AND THEN
TALKING ABOUT THE WAIT TIMES
UPDATE THE WE HAVE.
A DISCUSSION ON THE EVALUATION
OF THE DMV OPERATIONS WITH THE
STRIKE TEAM COME BEFORE THEN ARE
GOING FORWARD WE HAVE THE
DISCUSSION AROUND CURRENT YEAR
AND A YEAR AND BUDGET YOUR
FUNDING REQUESTS BUT LET'S --
LET'S BEGIN -- ACTING DIRECTOR
ACTING DIRECTOR WITH.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN TING AND
FRAZIER INSURE ONE PATRON NORRIS
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AM
KATHLEEN WEB.
I AM THE ACTING DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES AND
WITH ME TODAY IS ROBBIE CROCKETT
OR DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES.
AND COLLEAGUES SOLOMON OUR
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF FIELD
OPERATIONS DIVISION AND WE HOPE
TO ANSWER ALL THE QUESTIONS --
THE THAT YOU HAVE RAISED HERE --
AMONG ALL OF YOU -- THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME BEFORE YOU
AND ADDRESS OUR PROGRESS IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO ALL OF US AND I
WANT TO BE ABLE TO SHARE WITH
YOU WHAT WE'RE DOING AND
REDUCING WAITING TIMES
IMPLEMENTING REAL ID.
AND THE PROGRESS THAT IS BEING
MADE TO REINVENT THE DMV.
NOT ONLY AT THE CUSTOMER SERVICE
LEVEL.
BUT ALSO AT THE TOP OF THE
ORGANIZATION.
AS THE NEW ACTING DIRECTOR I AM
EXCITED ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITIES
TO MODERNIZE THE DMV OPERATIONS.
AND THE DECISION MAKING PROCESS
TO NOLLIE BETTER SERVE OUR
CUSTOMERS.
BUT TO RESTORE CONFIDENCE AND
TRUST BACK INTO THE DEPARTMENT.
THAT HAS SEEN STRUGGLES LEAD TO
PUBLIC FRUSTRATION.
AND GOVERNMENT EMBARRASSMENT.
LATER ON YOU'LL HEAR FROM
SECRETARY VOUCHER AND WE BOTH
SHARE A PERSPECTIVE.
IT IS THE BEGINNING OF A PROCESS.
FOCUSED UPON DELIVERING SERVICES.
TO CUSTOMERS IN THE WAY THEY
WANT US TO DELIVER IT.
THE DMV IS TAKEN SIGNIFICANT
ACTION TO IMPROVE CUSTOMER
SERVICE AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
DO SO IN THE MONTHS AHEAD.
AS FURTHER IMPROVEMENTS ARE
CERTAINLY NEEDED.
ADDITIONALLY WE ALSO NEED TO
THINK OF CREATING THE DMV IN THE
FUTURE.
THIS REQUIRE A COMMITMENT FROM
THE WHOLE TEAM AT DMV AND I CAN
TELL YOU THAT THEY ARE COMMITTED
TO DOING THIS.
I'M ALSO VERY APPRECIATIVE THE
SUPPORT AND PARTNERSHIP PROVIDED
BY THE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS
AGENCY STRIKE TEAM WITH THIS
EFFORT AND THE PROGRESS THAT WE
HAVE BEEN MAKING TO ENSURE THAT
WE ARE DELIVERING EASILY AND
EFFECTIVE CUSTOMER SERVICE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
PERFORMANCE AUDIT REVEALED THAT
THERE ARE MANY MANY CHALLENGES
FACING DMV.
MUCH IMPROVEMENT IS NEEDED AT
ALL LEVELS OF DMV'S OPERATION
AND SERVICES TO OUR CUSTOMERS.
INDEED NEW LEADERSHIP
[inaudible]
NEW INSPIRATION.
NEW IDEAS ARE ALL NEEDED IN THIS
PROCESS OF REINVENTING.
THE MOST PUBLICLY ACCESS
DEPARTMENT IN THE STATE.
SO I'M HERE TO ASSURE YOU THAT
WE ARE PAYING ATTENTION.
I AM PAYING ATTENTION.
AND I TAKE THIS AUDIT VERY
SERIOUSLY KNOWING WE NEED TO
INSTILL.
MORE THAN EVER.
GOOD FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITIES
AND PRACTICES.
AND GREAT WORK PERFORMANCE
BENCHMARKS TO ACHIEVE MEASURABLE
OUTCOMES.
THIS WILL HELP THE LEGISLATURE
IN KNOWING THAT THE DMV IS
MANAGING ITS RESOURCES AND
DELIVERING ON ITS COMMITMENTS.
DAVIES FUTURE DEPENDS ON IT AND
EVERY RECOMMENDATION THE
PERFORMANCE ON IT WILL BE
THOROUGHLY EVALUATED RESPONDED
TO IN OUR CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN
WITHIN THE NEXT SIXTY DAYS.
AS I MENTIONED THIS IS THE
BEGINNING OF A PROCESS TOWARD
SOMETHING BETTER.
THE DMV THE FUTURE.
IS AN ACHIEVABLE DESTINATION WE
CAN GET THERE TOGETHER WITH MANY
ADDITIONAL PREVENTS IN THE SHORT
TERM AND OTHERS COMING OVER TIME.
THE DMV IS COMMITTED TO REDUCING
WAIT TIMES FOR CUSTOMERS
OFFERING MORE EXTERNAL SERVICE
CHANNELS TO REDUCE THE NEED FOR
FIELD OFFICE VISITS.
AND WITH THE HELP OF OUR
PARTNERS RE IMAGINING DELIVERING
SERVICES IN WAYS THAT CUSTOMERS
WANT THEM. TO BE LIVER NOW AND
INTO THE FUTURE.
THIS MEANS IMPROVING REAL ID
TRANSACTIONS.
IMPROVING REAL ID OUTREACH
IMPROVING REAL ID TRAINING.
DEVELOPING BETTER FIELD OFFICE
CUSTOMER FLOWS STRATEGIES.
DEPLOY MORE SELF SERVICE
TERMINALS PROVIDING MORE
CUSTOMER SERVICES ONLINE AND
THROUGH OUR BUSINESS PARTNERS
[inaudible]
AND RESHAPING THE DMV DECISION
MAKING PROCESS AT AN
ORGANIZATIONAL LEVEL.
AND WHAT I MEAN BY RESHAPING IS
THAT FOR FAR TOO LONG.
DMV'S DECISION MAKING HAS BEEN A
TOP DOWN HIERARCHY.
THAT RESULTED IN REACTIVE
DECISION MAKING MADE AT THE VERY
TOP OF THE ORGANIZATION.
BUT WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING THE
DOWNSTREAM IMPACTS.
THERE ARE MANY EMPLOYEES AT ALL
LEVELS OF THE ORGANIZATION WHO
POSSESS KNOWLEDGE AND
UNDERSTANDING.
THE HOW TO MAKE MEANINGFUL
IMPROVEMENTS TO DMV.
A MORE ROBUST ENGAGE ENTERPRISE
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE THAT
EMPHASIZES AND EXAMINES THE BEST
SOLUTIONS AS A TEAM.
WE'LL HAVE MORE ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND TAKE MORE RESPONSIBILITY
ASSURING THOSE SOLUTIONS ARE THE
MOST SUCCESSFUL.
LAST SUMMER.
WAIT TIMES WERE EXTREME AN
UNACCEPTABLE.
I WISH TO APOLOGIZE TO EACH OF
YOU AND ALL OF OUR VALUED
CUSTOMERS WHO HAD TO EXPERIENCE
A LONG WAIT TIMES.
I WISH TO SHARE WITH YOU TODAY.
THAT'S SINCE LAST AUGUST THE
DEPARTMENT OF SUCCESSFULLY
REDUCE THE AVERAGE STATEWIDE
WAIT TIME BY NINETY ONE MINUTES.
AS MAINTAIN AN AVERAGE STATEWIDE
WAIT TIME OF ONE HOUR OR LESS
SINCE OCTOBER.
DMV IS ACHIEVED ITS OVERALL WAIT
TIME GOALS IN THE PAST
CONSECUTIVE MONTHS SINCE OCTOBER.
IN ALL THE DMV IS ACHIEVED ITS
GOALS THIS DOES NOT MEAN THAT
OUR WORK IS DONE.
DMV WILL CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
EFFECTIVE EFFICIENT CUSTOMER
SERVICE REDUCE WAIT TIMES
ENHANCE THE CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE
A DMV FIELD OFFICES.
AND PROVIDE INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS
FOR ADDED CUSTOMER CONVENIENCE
OUTSIDE OF THE TRADITIONAL FIELD
OFFICE.
OUR SUCCESS REDUCING WAIT TIMES
IS DIRECTLY ATTRIBUTABLE TO
SOLUTIONS FUNDED THROUGH PRIOR
BUDGET ALLOCATIONS.
AND WE DO SINCERELY APPRECIATE
THE LEGISLATOR SUPPORT AND
FUNDING.
HIRING NINE HUNDRED TEMPORARY
NEW EMPLOYEES BY OCTOBER.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TRIAGE IN
CUSTOMERS WAITING TO APPROVE AN
EX BUT I HANDLING OF
TRANSACTIONS.
USING SMART TABLETS TO CHECK
CUSTOMERS INTO THE QUEUE FASTER
AND TO ALSO ASSIST CUSTOMERS
WITH ASSESSING.
ACCESSING ONLINE SERVICES AND TO
SCHEDULE APPOINTMENT.
PROVIDING AN EXPEDITE LINE FOR
EASIER TRANSACTIONS LIKE
OBTAINING A DRIVING RECORD OR
PICKING UP LICENSE PLATES AND
THE SABBATH DISABLE PLACARDS.
PROVIDING TEXT MESSAGE
NOTIFICATIONS TO CUSTOMERS SO
THEY CAN HAVE FLEXIBILITY TO
LEAVE THE DMV FIELD OFFICES.
AND RETURN WHEN THEIR QUEUE
NUMBER IS TO BE CALLED.
IMPROVED INTEGRATION OF OUR
DRIVERS LICENSE APPLICATION
PROCESS SO THAT TECHNICIAN
KEYSTROKES ARE REDUCED AND
CUSTOMERS SPEND LESS TIME AND A
TECHNICIAN WINDOW.
ADDITIONAL SERVICE HOURS SEVEN
AM START TIME IN SIXTEEN OFFICES.
AND SATURDAY SERVICES AT SIXTY
TWO OFFICES FROM EIGHT AM TO
FIVE PM.
ENHANCING OFFICE PERFORMERS
EFFICIENCIES AS SOME FIELD
OFFICES FOR CUSTOMERS WAITING BY
PRE SCREENING THEIR DOCUMENTS SO
WHEN THEY ARRIVE IN A TECHNICIAN
WINDOW.
THE DOCUMENT REVIEW IS ALREADY
COMPLETE REDUCES THE TRANSACTION
PROCESSING TIME.
MONITORING FIELD OFFICE WAIT
TIMES A REAL TIME THROUGH THE
DMV COMMAND CENTER.
AND OFFERING SERVICES THAT DO
NOT REQUIRE VISITING A FIELD
OFFICE.
WE ACKNOWLEDGE WE SUBMITTED
SIGNIFICANT BUDGET REQUEST FOR
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY TO
THE LEGISLATURE.
WHICH WILL BE DISCUSSED FURTHER
IN PANEL.
THREE WE DO NOT TAKE THIS
LIGHTLY.
AND WE MUST BE GOOD STEWARDS OF
RESOURCES AND FUNDING GRANTED.
AND TO BE TRANSPARENT ABOUT OUR
EFFORTS WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
AND THE PUBLIC TO RESTORE
CONFIDENCE AND TRUST.
BUT ON THE ISSUE OF WAIT TIMES I
WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU THAT THIS
IS NOT JUST A FIELD OFFICE
CONCERN.
IT IS ALSO A CONCERN DMV'S CALL
CENTERS.
THE AVERAGE CUSTOMER CALL WAIT
TIME IS FIFTEEN MINUTES.
AND THE MAXIMUM WAIT TIME IS
BEEN AS HIGH AS TWO HOURS TO
ALMOST FIVE HOURS DURING PEAK
PERIODS.
THIS IS SIMPLY NOT ACCEPTABLE
AND EVEN WITH FEATURES THAT
INCLUDE VIRTUAL HOLD.
PROVIDING A CALLBACK TO CUSTER
WHEN A CALL CENTER
REPRESENTATIVES AVAILABLE.
THIS VIRTUAL HOLD ALSO GETS OVER
PRESCRIBED IS NOT AVAILABLE TO
ALL CUSTOMERS.
DO YOU MAY WANT TO ENSURE THAT
ALL CUSTOMERS CONTACTING DMV BY
PHONE OR ONLINE OUR TIMELY
SERVED IN DO NOT ENCOUNTER A
LONG FRUSTRATING WAIT TIMES.
THAT'S WHY DMV IS PROPOSING NEW
SERVICES THAT ARE WIDELY USED BY
ALMOST EVERY MAJOR RETAILER.
SERVICES LIKE LIVE CHAT IN
CUSTOMER SERVICE EMAIL.
ALLOWING CUSTOMERS TO CONTACT
VIA THE INTERNET TO A REAL DMV
REPRESENT OF WHO CAN LAND
CUSTOMER SYSTEMS.
AND CHAT BOT VIRTUAL
REPRESENTATIVE PROVIDING
ASSISTANCE ON SOME OF THE MOST
FREQUENTLY ASKED QUESTIONS AND
TOPICS OF DMV.
THESE ARE JUST TWO SERVICES THAT
WILL ENHANCE THE CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE REDUCE WAIT TIMES.
FOR ASSISTANCE AND DELIVER
SERVICES IN THE WAYS CUSTOMER
ONE THING IF YOU COULD.
YES [inaudible]
I'M SO.
WE WE HAD KNOWLEDGE THAT THERE
ARE MULTIPLE WAYS THAT WE NEED
TO GO AND DRESS THESE CHALLENGES
ARE ONLINE APPOINTMENT SYSTEM IS
ANOTHER AREA THAT WE'RE
ADDRESSING THOSE AND WORKING
WITH OUR VENDOR. TO EXPAND
SERVICES AND ALSO MANAGE THE
BLOCKING OF APPOINTMENTS -- THE
REAL ID IS THE MAJOR PRIORITY OF
WHAT WE NEED TO ACHIEVE IN ORDER
TO ACCOMPLISH THAT AND OUR
COMPLIANCE RESPONSIBILITY TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
WE FEEL THAT WE HAVE TO REALLY
AGGRESSIVELY MARKET AND RAISE
AWARENESS AND EDUCATION.
WITH OUR CUSTOMERS SO THEY COME
IN THE MOST PREPARED IT
EVERYTHING INDICATES THAT WHEN A
CUSTOMER COMES IN MOST PREPARED.
THE PROCESSING TIME IS SO MUCH
SHORTER THAN WHEN THEY DON'T WE
HAVE HEARD THAT CUSTOMERS
ACTUALLY THAT COMING PREPARE CAN
GET IN AND OUT OF THAT
TRANSACTION IN TEN MINUTES.
SO THAT IS A GOAL WE ARE
AGGRESSIVELY ADDRESSING BECAUSE
THAT WE THAT MEANS WE CAN SEE
MORE PEOPLE -- WE'VE ACTUALLY --
SELF PAY THANK YOU.
AGAIN LET ME JUST REITERATE.
WHY WERE HERE APPRECIATE YOUR
YOUR YOUR SPEECH -- ACTING
DIRECTOR WEB.
BUT IT SOUNDS ALMOST IDENTICAL
TO THE SPEECH THAT WAS GIVEN TO
US IN AUGUST -- IN TERMS OF MANY
PROMISES THAT WERE MADE AND NOT
FOR FILLED SO THE QUESTION IS IS.
HOW DO WE ENSURE?
THAT WHAT YOU SAID ACTUALLY GETS
DONE SO I'M GONNA GIVE -- MISS
CROCKETT A MINUTE AND MISS
MARTIN AND MINUTE NOR MISTER
CROCKETT.
AND MINUTE EXCUSE ME -- AND
LET'S GET TO MEMBER QUESTIONS.
IF YOU HAVE ANYTHING THAT YOU
CAN YOU DON'T YOU YOU COULD BE
THE MOST POPULAR GUY IN THE ROOM
NOT [inaudible]
FINANCE.
THANK YOU I'M IN MARIN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE VERY
BRIEFLY BY WAY OF BACKGROUND
YOUR AGENDA ON PAGE SIX LAYS OUT
THE FUNDING.
REQUESTS HIS FOR THE FUNDING
REQUEST THE FIRST VOTE FOR ROSE
INCLUDING THE AUGUST TWENTY
EIGHTEEN REQUEST PRESENT
PURSUANT TO PROVISION TO HAVE
ALREADY BEEN APPROVED BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
I WOULD NOTE THAT THE SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN PROPOSAL WAS ORIGINALLY
A FIVE YEAR PROPOSAL BUT THE
LEGISLATURE UNDERSTANDING THAT
IMPLEMENTATION WAS JUST GETTING
STARTED.
THE ONLY APPROVED THE FIRST TWO
YEARS OF FUNDING INTO SPRING
THAT WE WOULD BE BACK IN
NINETEEN TWENTY WHICH IS WHERE
WE ARE NOW.
THE ADMINISTRATION ALSO
SUBMITTED THEIR SONORA QUEST ON
JANUARY THIRD THROUGH JAIL BC
PROCESS AND BASED ON DISCUSSIONS
WITH LEGISLATIVE STAFF WE
COMMITTED TO EXTENDING THAT
REVIEW PERIOD.
UNTIL WE COULD HAVE UNTIL YOU
COULD HAVE A HEARING WHICH IS
WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY -- IN
KEEPING WITH THAT COMMITMENT WE
HAVE RELEASED THE AUDIT.
THE FIRST FEW MONTHS OF THE
STRIKE TEAMS WORK AND OUR SPRING
PROPOSAL TO BE DISCUSSED LATER.
AT LAST THAT WOULD JUST NOTE AS
HAS BEEN MENTIONED THE BUDGET
ACTOR TWENTY EIGHTEEN REQUIRES
DMV TO SUBMIT MONTHLY WAIT TIME
REPORTS.
THROUGH AT LEAST DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY WHICH IS ACT
FOR THE OCTOBER ONE TWENTY
TWENTY DEADLINE AND WE WILL
CONTINUE. TO SUBMIT THOSE TO
KEEP THE LEGISLATURE APPRISED OF
OUR PROGRESS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
THIS PETRIE-NORRIS.
SEC I THINK.
AT THE CHAIR RAISED I THINK SOME
CONCERNS IN TERMS OF PROMISES
THAT HAD BEEN MADE PREVIOUSLY
AND AND NOT MET AND I THINK
THERE'S A RESISTANCE AND IT JUST
SORT OF POOR GOOD MONEY AFTER
BAD AS THE CASE MIGHT BE.
I'M I THINK YOU AS WELL LIKE
KNOWLEDGE YOU NEED TO REBUILD
KIND OF CONFIDENCE AND TRUST IN
THE DMV AND IN.
THE DMV'S LEADERSHIP'S ABILITY
TO ACTUALLY GET THINGS DONE
ACTUALLY DELIVER ONE SUGGESTION
I I WOULD HAVE IS I THINK A WAY
TO REBUILD CONFIDENCE AND TRUST
IS.
BY SETTING YOU KNOW NEAR TERM
CONCRETE DELIVERABLES AND
MILESTONES AND I DO APPRECIATE.
YOU SEEM TO HAVE A MORE
EXPANSIVE AND AMBITIOUS AGENDA
BUT I DO WHICH I DO APPRECIATE
BUT I THINK WOULD BE REALLY
HELPFUL CERTAINLY FOR ME AND FOR
THIS COMMITTEE TO SAY OKAY.
HERE'S WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
DELIVER IN THE NEXT YOU KNOW TWO
MONTHS FOUR MONTHS SIX MONTHS.
AND THEN AS WE HIT THOSE
MILESTONES WE CAN ALLOCATE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING I'M IS A IS
IS THAT.
APPROACH SHOULD BE COMFORTABLE
WITH AND BE WHAT ARE THOSE
CONCRETE DELIVERABLES AND
MILESTONES THAT THAT WE COULD
LOOK FORWARD TO OVER THE COURSE
OF THE NEXT. EIGHT TWO FOUR AND
SIX MONTHS.
I'M SO WE'RE GONNA ADDRESS A LOT
OF THAT I THINK SECRETARY OF
ACTUAL ADDRESS SOME OF THAT WITH
OF OURS FOR WORK WITH THE GOV UP
STRIKE TEAM.
HEY THERE THE WAY I WOULD --
PROBABLY APPROACH THIS IS. ONE
ALTERNATIVE SERVICE -- WE REALLY
NEED TO MOVE FOR WITH OFFERING
ALTERS SERVICES AND GET PEOPLE
OUT OF THE FIELD OFFICE.
SO THE EXPANSION OF CHAOS WOULD
BE SOMETHING THAT WE CAN MEASURE --
I BELIEVE ALSO THE EXPANSION OF
ONLINE SERVICES AND IMPROVING
OUR WEBSITE SOMETHING WE CAN
MEASURE.
I THINK THOSE ARE ARE TERRIBLE
AND THEY OBVIOUSLY HAVEN'T
ILLUSTRATED CAPABILITY AND THEN
THE OTHER THING IS TO MEASURE
THE TAKE UP RIGHT.
I THINK YOU KNOW ARE THESE
HITTING THE MARK FOR OUR
CUSTOMERS DO WE SEE A TAKE
OPERATE GOING ON WELL I THINK --
CHAIRMAN YOU BROUGHT UP
SOMETHING THAT'S ALWAYS IMPORT
TO ME IS WHAT ARE THOSE KEY
PERFORMANCE INDICATORS THAT WE
NEED TO PUT IN PLACE AT THE DMV.
THAT MEASURE WERE ACHIEVING THE
CUSTOMER GOALS THAT WE ARE
SEEKING -- WE KNOW THAT IN ORDER
TO PROCESS REAL ID WHICH
REQUIRES IN PERSON HANDLING
THERE IS NO ALTERNATIVE. FOR US
TO ISSUE A REAL ID -- I NEED TO
MOVE TRANSACTION THAT
TRANSACTION SO THE FIELD OFFICE
SO THAT WE CAN ACCOMMODATE THE
VOLUME OF PEOPLE THEY'RE GONNA
BE COMING AND WE'LL TALK ABOUT
THOSE NUMBERS -- IN FURTHER
DETAIL BUT EARLY PROJECTIONS I
WOULD SAY ARE WE SHOULD
ANTICIPATE ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE COMING IN ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS -- BONO ON A
MONTHLY BASIS ON A MONTHLY BASIS
I WISH IT WAS ANNUAL.
ON A MONTHLY BASIS THEY SHOULD
BE COMING IN SO THE MORE THAT I
CAN MOVE OUT -- AND ALLOW THE
FIELD OFFICE TO HANDLE COMPLEX
TRANSACTIONS OR REAL ID
TRANSACTIONS.
THE MORE TIME WILL HAVE FOR
THOSE APPOINTMENTS SO LET'S
MEASURE THAT I THINK THE OTHER
THING IS CALL CENTERS I THINK WE
NEED A MEASURE HOW QUICKLY WERE
ABLE TO GO AHEAD AND SERVICE
PEOPLE IN THE CALL CENTER.
WERE LOOKING AT THE ABILITY TO
HANDLE TRANSACTIONS IN THE CALL
CENTER ENVIRONMENT -- IN OUR NEW
CONTRACT WITH OUR VENDOR BUT I
ALSO DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO BE
WAITING AND IN IN A CALL CENTER
ENVIRONMENT WHEN THEY NEED SOME
IMMEDIATE ANSWERS -- SO AGAIN
PROVIDING THOSE ALTERS COULD BE
MEASURABLE AREAS AGAIN WHAT TO
TAKE A BREAK.
OUR CUSTOMERS ACTUALLY USING
THESE TOOLS DOES THIS MEET THE
NEEDS OF ITS NOT MEETING THEIR
NEEDS THAT I SAY WE STOP USING
IT.
BUT PERMITS MARKETING THOSE
TOOLS MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE
KNOW THEY'RE AVAILABLE I THINK
AS I POINTED OUT.
THESE ARE TOOLS ARE CUSTOMARILY
AVAILABLE IN ANY KIND OF RETAIL
ENVIRONMENT OR IF YOU GO ONLINE
AND DO ANY KIND OF WORK WITH AN
ONLINE.
ENTITIES SO WHY NOT MAKE THESE
AVAILABLE FOR DMV CUSTOMERS AS
WELL -- FROM THE FIELD OFFICE
STANDPOINT -- WE AGREE WITH YOU
WERE LOOKING AT WAYS TO GO AHEAD
AND DO BUSINESS PROCESS
IMPROVEMENT AND ALL OF OUR
OFFICES.
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
CAME UP IN MY MEETINGS WITH ALL
OF YOU IS THOSE THAT ARE OFFICES
THAT ARE HIGH PERFORMING -- WHAT
ARE THE BEST PRACTICES IN THOSE
HIGH PERFORMING OFFICES THAT
ACTUALLY COULD BE APPLIED
ANOTHER OFFICES?
THERE ARE SOME NUANCES THAT WE
HAVE TO BE -- MINDFUL OF NOT
EVERY OFFICE IS DESIGNED THE
SAME WAY THEREFORE FLOW IS NOT
EXACTLY THE SAME -- THE OTHER
THING THAT WE'RE AWARE OF IS IN
CERTAIN OFFICES -- THERE ARE
CERTAIN PRODUCTS THAT ARE --
CUSTOMERS WANT VERSUS OTHER
PRODUCTS AND WE LOOK AT PRODUCT
LINE BEING SERVICE BASED ON
THOSE OFFICES IN THOSE CUSTOMERS --
BUT WE'RE LOOKING AT THOSE SOME
SHOULD SEIZE I THINK THE THING
I'M VERY EXCITED ABOUT -- AND I
THINK CAN GIVE US SOME
MEASURABLE -- KEEP PERFORMANCE
INDICATORS IS THE WORK WE'RE
CURRENTLY DOING WITH MACKENZIE.
AND THEIR ASSESSMENT OF THE
CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE THAT'S GOING
ON RIGHT NOW -- WE ANTICIPATE
GETTING A REPORT FROM THEM -- BY
MADE JUNE I THINK WE'RE GONNA
HAVE SOME OUTSTANDING
RECOMMENDATIONS COMING FROM THEM --
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
IMPLEMENTING THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE THE
CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE THE OTHER
THING WE'RE ASKING -- FROM ALL
OF YOU.
IS -- THE ABILITY TO EDUCATE OUR
CUSTOMERS.
AND AGAIN AS I SAID EARLIER
PREPARE CUSTOMER MEANS IT'S A
SHORTER EXPERIENCE AT THE DMV IF
THEY COME IN FULLY PREPARED WITH
ALL THEIR DOCUMENTS.
IN HAND WE CAN PROCESS THEM VERY
VERY QUICKLY WHICH MEANS I CAN
ACTUALLY HAVE MORE PEOPLE COME
INTO THE OFFICE FROM AN
APPOINTMENT STANDPOINT.
IF IT'S NOT A THIRTY MINUTE
EXPERIENCE JUST IN FRONT OF A
COUNTER IT'S A TEN MINUTE
EXPERIENCE THE THINK ABOUT IN
THAT SAME PERIOD TIME I CAN
ACTUALLY TAKEN THREE MORE PEOPLE.
MULTIPLY THAT BY ALL THE
CUSTOMER COUNTERS THAT MEANS WE
CAN START TAKING IN MORE PEOPLE
SO.
WE SAY ONE OF THOSE KEY
PERFORMANCE INDICATORS WE CAN
PUT THOSE THINGS IN PLACE.
WE NEED THE RESOURCES TO DO THAT --
THAT'S THE REQUEST FOR MAKING
ALL OF YOU AND A LOT OF IT HAS
TO DO WE'VE GOT A SHORT TERM
NEED THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS.
IN ISSUING READ REAL ID WHAT I'M
ALSO -- THOUGHTFUL ABOUT AS A
GOOD STEWARD.
IS THAT AS WE GET THROUGH THIS
IMMEDIATE NEED TO ISSUE A REAL
ID WHAT ARE THE EFFICIENCIES
THAT WERE GAINING AS WE GO
FORWARD.
AND HOW DO WE NEED TO STAFF THE
DMB ON A GO FORWARD BASIS.
AND THOSE OR SOMETHING I THINK
WE OWE TO YOU AS WELL.
GREAT THANK YOU FOR THAT AND
I'VE GOT SOME FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS BUT I MIGHT SAVE THEM
FOR THE SECRETARY'S FIVE
PRESENTATION TO ON A STEEL.
SEWER THUNDER.
THIS IS A JUST A JUST A FALL
PROGRAM MR FONG ON WHAT IS THE
TAKE OPERATE FOR KIOSKS IN
ONLINE AS OF NOW.
I DON'THAVE THOSE NUMBERS ARE
FROM MALE SEE IF MY COLLEAGUES
DO BUT I CAN'T TELL YOU -- AT
THE CHAOS AT THE DMV OFFICES
HAVE STAYED ABOUT THE SAME.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I AM
VERY THOUGHTFUL ABOUT IS.
PUTTING KEY AWESOME DMV OFFICES
MEANS I'M TAKING MORE PEOPLE
INTO THE DMV OFFICE -- WHAT WE
ARE FINDING AS WE PUT THEM OUT
TO RETAIL OUTLETS OR TRIPLE A
OFFICES THE TAKE UP RATE -- IN
THOSE OFFICES ACTUALLY --
INCREASED DRAMATICALLY AND SO WE
BELIEVE WITH GOOD MARKETING AND
EDUCATION OF PEOPLE ABLE TO
GOOGLE AND FIND WERE A KIOSK AS
THEY CAN ACTUALLY PROBABLY SEE A
HIGHER TAKE UP RIGHT.
THE OTHER THING IS OUR VENDORS
VERY GOOD AT LOOKING BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT TO BE IN A KIOSK IF
IT'S NOT GONNA GET TRAFFIC -- IS
WORKING WITH THEM TO IDENTIFY
GOOD RETAIL OUTLETS IN OUR TRIP
WAY PARTNERS WHERE WE CAN
BENEFICIALLY PUTTING KIOSK. TO
TAKE UP THAT -- ACTIVITY SO WE
HAVE A MARKETING PLAN FROM THE
VENDOR -- TO LOOK AT THAT AND
YOU GUYS [inaudible]
YEAH.
SO I'M SORRY GO IN A DIFFERENT
YOUR PREFERENCE ON FEBRUARY
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND THE SST
THEIR SELF SERVICE TERMINALS WE
PROCESS ABOUT.
A HUNDRED SIXTY TWO THOUSAND
TRANSACTIONS.
AND INTERPRET WHAT A LOT OF OUT
OF HIM WHAT KIND OF HAMMY KIOSK --
THAT WAS WHICH SHOULD HAVE BEEN
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND HE WAS ABOUT
A HUNDRED AND NO TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY TWO NOW IF I THINK ABOUT A
HUNDRED TWENTY MONEY COME. TO
TWENTY FIVE SMALL.
ANDTHEN AND THEN -- FEBRUARY
TWENTY NINETEEN IT WAS A HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY EIGHT THOUSAND AND I
WAS AT A HUNDRED FIFTY TWO
KIOSKS.
AND AGAIN THOSE ARE WITH LIMITED
SERVICES AND I'M RIGHT NOW
CORRECT WITH EXPANDED SERVICES
WE COULD SEE A TAKE OPERATE THAT
WE WOULD WANT TO MONITOR.
OKAY.
AND THEN WHAT ABOUT ONLINE.
ONLINE WE PROCESS ABOUT
SEVENTEEN MILLION TRANSACTIONS A
YEAR.
AND HAS A CUT ON THE DOWN.
OR DOWN CONTINUOUS TOOK TO CLIMB
INTO THE CALL -- MAYBE CLIMBS
ABOUT A MILLION A YEAR.
BUT AGAIN WITH EXPANDED SERVICES
WE CAN SEE THAT ACTUALLY GROW.
CUT -- AND THEN JUST JUST A
FINANCE -- DECIDE JUST WANNA
HAVE THE STATED FOR THE RECORD
THE THE BUDGET -- THE
APPROXIMATE.
BUDGET FOR THE AGENCY DMV'S
ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS WITH --
ABOUT -- EIGHT THOUSAND FULL
TIME FULL TIME EMPLOYEES ROUGHLY
OR FOR THE THOUSAND PLEASE
[inaudible]
WITHOUT. ONE IF.
PRIOR TO DISCUSS ABOUT ONE POINT
ONE BILLION AND A THOUSAND
SOUNDS ABOUT RIGHT. EIGHTY THREE
SO THE REQUESTED. FOR TWO
THOUSAND NEW POSITIONS IN -- FOR
TWO HUNDRED FORTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS SO JUST ROUGHLY YOU'RE
ASKING FOR A 25% INCREASE ON
MONEY AND BODY.
TWENTY AND ALSO A AND ALSO A 25%
INCREASE ON STAFFING IS THAT
ROUGHLY CORRECT [inaudible]
SO.
IN TERMS OF TOTAL TEMPORARY
POSITIONS. TWO THOUSAND IS IS
CORRECT WE ONLY A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY EIGHT OF THOSE ARE
PERMANENT POSITIONS BECAUSE WE
ARE ANTICIPATING.
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN TRAFFIC
SO TWO THOUSAND TEMPORARY
POSITIONS IS WHAT WE ESTIMATE
BASED ON OUR ASSUMPTIONS.
RELATED -- TO THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WILL BE COMING IN FOR A
REAL ID AND THE DOLLARS THAT GO
WITH THEM.
SELECT THE TIME TO BE SAID TO BE
ASKING FOR THREE YEARS -- HOW
HOW MANY YEARS AGO ASKING FOR
THE TEMPORARY POSITIONS?
THE TWO THOUSAND IS THE HIGHEST
OF ONE YEAR IS THE HIGHEST
NUMBER IN AND THEN IT IT DROPS
DOWN AS WE WOULD EXPECT THE
WORKLOAD TO DROP DOWN THIS
PROPOSAL -- FLUSHES OUT OUR
SANCTIONS ALL THE WAY THROUGH.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE OKAY
THANK YOU MISS.
FOR THANKS VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE -- I ECHO -- THE
THE SENTIMENTS -- OF OF THE
CHAIRMAN -- AND AND OF A SERVER.
APACHE NORRIS.
MY MY PATIENCE I DON'T I'D I
GUESS I CAN SAY I DON'T HAVE THE
PATIENCE ANYMORE WHEN IT COMES
TO WHAT'S HAPPENING.
IT'S IRONIC TO ME AND I WAS
TALKING TO MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
REPAIRS TODAY THAT WE'RE HAVING
THIS HEARING.
AT THE VERY DAY THAT.
ACCORDING TO YOUR TWITTER
ACCOUNT.
DMV OFFICES WERE IMPACTED BY A
CONNECTIVE ITTY ISSUE THIS
MORNING FROM A HARDWARE FAILURE
AT THE STATE DATA CENTER
OPERATED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY.
SO YOU HAD A STATEWIDE FAILURE
TODAY.
SEKARANG.
WE HAVE AN OUTAGE KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED YOU SHOULD SHARE SOME
SPECIFICS OF WHAT HAPPENED -- I
WAS SHARING WITH YOU FROM A LAY
PERSON'S PERSPECTIVE BUT I WILL
TELL YOU THAT THERE WAS -- A
SYSTEM -- AT CVG WHICH SUPPORTS --
THE DMV SYSTEMS BUT ALSO
SUPPORTS OTHER DEPARTMENTS AS
WELL -- AND IT HAD A FAILURE
WHICH THEN AFFECTED ALL OF OUR
OFFICES BUT WE WERE ABLE TO GO
AHEAD AND RESTORE FULLY TO OUR
ALL OUR OFFICES I BELIEVE WAS
GOING ABOUT. TEN O'CLOCK TEN
THIRTY AND THEN WE HAD A FULL
TRANSPARENCY AYE BECAUSE OUR
OFFICE AT NOON AND IT WAS SOLD
OUT.
WHY CALL THE ONE EIGHT HUNDRED
NUMBER I JUST OUT OF CURIOSITY
TO SEE IF IT WAS A FUNCTION YES
SO THEN WHAT I WAS GOING TO FALL
OFF AND SAY IS THAT WE HAD A
SUBSEQUENT -- FAILURE WITH ABOUT
FIFTY OF OUR OFFICES AND AT THIS
POINT TIME IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THEY ARE RESTORING THOSE
OFFICES WE HAD TO GO THROUGH A
REBOOT.
OF ARE AT A DMV A SYSTEM AND MY
UNDERSTANDING OF YOUR CALL NOW.
HAVE A LOOK AT MY EMAILS YEP
MAYOR STANDING AS THEY WOULD BE
FUNCTIONAL AT THIS POINT IN TIME
SO JUST SO THAT EVERYONE HERE
UNDERSTANDS IN THE PUBLIC THEY
WERE TOO OUTRAGEOUS TODAY
[inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
OKAY -- IN A NOW I WANT TO DELVE
INTO THIS THAT THIS SPECIFIC
RELATIONSHIP THAT YOU THAT THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
HAS WITH -- THE THE CALIFORNIA
BERMAN TECHNOLOGY ON PAGE FOUR
OF OF THE END OF THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS OF IT OUTLINES --
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGIES IMPACT
ON THE FIELD OFFICES CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCING YOU OUTLINED A
NUMBER THERE'S OF COURSE
OUTLINED IS IS A NUMBER OF
PROBLEMS WITH INSUFFICIENT
NETWORK SYSTEM INFRASTRUCTURE --
WEAKNESSES IN EXISTING PRO DMB
PROJECT PRIVATIZATION -- WHAT IS
YOUR RELATIONSHIP WITH THE?
CALIFORNIA PART OF TECHNOLOGY
WHO IS WHO ENDS UP BEING
ACCOUNTABLE.
IN THE END IN BETWEEN THAT
RELATIONSHIP IS THAT IS.
IS THE DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY
ACCOUNTABLE WHEN SOMETHING GOES
WHEN SOMETHING FAILS OR IS IT
THE DMV -- WILL NOT SPEAK FOR
CDT BUT WE ARE A CUSTOMER OF CD
TEAM AND THEY HANDLE -- SOME OF
OUR HARDWARE AND OUR TECHNOLOGY
SUPPORT MECHANISMS -- SO WE DO
HAVE A WHAT I CALL SERVICE LEVEL
AGREEMENT WITH A CONTRACTUAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH A FOR THOSE
SERVICES -- AND SO THERE ARE
PROGRAMMING THINGS THAT WE ARE
RESPONSIBLE -- FOR AND THEN IT'S
KIND OF OUR BACK UP SYSTEMS AND
OUR IBM SYSTEMS AND EVERYTHING
ELSE.
THAT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THAT WE
HAVE A GREAT NEED TO ADDRESS --
THEY ARE I THINK OUR OUTAGES
POINT OUT -- WE HAVE A VERY
FRAGILE SYSTEM AT THE DMV -- AND
IT AND IT'S AN OLD SYSTEM.
SO WHEN THERE IS A WHEN THERE IS
AN OUTAGE OR WHEN SOMETHING
HAPPENS LIKE TODAY -- WHO DOES
THE CITY COMING FIX IT OR DO YOU
HAVE PEOPLE THAT GO AND FIX IT
WALK ME THROUGH THE RELATIONSHIP
ON WHAT HAPPENS?
SO IT FOR THIS PARTICULAR
SITUATION BECAUSE IT THE FAILURE
OCCURRED WITH THE CVT SYSTEM.
CITY WAS ACTUALLY STAFF WAS
WORKING WITH REPAIRING THE
SYSTEM WITH PROBABLY THE VENDOR
I DON'T KNOW SPECIFICALLY BUT
PRESUME IT WAS WITH A VENDOR. TO
GO AHEAD AND REPAIR OR REBUILD
THAT SYSTEM THEY WERE THEN IN
COMMUNICATION WITH OUR IT FOLKS
WITH OF OURS WHAT WE NEEDED TO
DO ON OUR SIDE.
AND ALSO BE ABLE TO DRESS WHAT
WE COULD FROM OUR SIDE BUT WHEN
WE ISOLATED AND DID SOME ROOT
CAUSE ANALYSIS.
IT WAS DETERMINED THAT THAT WAS
THE FAILURE WAS ACTUALLY WITHIN
A SYSTEM AT THE END AT C. D. T. --
ALL WE CAN DO THEN IS AND FORMER
STAFF AND TRY TO GO AND HANDLE
OUR CUSTOMER SERVICE TO THE BEST
WE CAN OUR OFFICES -- AND THEN
WORK WITH THEM WITH REGARDS TO
ANY KIND OF REVIEW WE HAVE TO DO
OF OUR OWN SYSTEM.
ON OUR SIDE SO THERE IS A
SEQUENTIAL ACTIVITY THAT NEEDS
TO TAKE PLACE AS WELL AND THEN
TESTING TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN
IT DOES COME UP WE HAVEN'T LOST
ANYTHING AS WELL.
SO THAT JUST SIMPLE QUESTIONS
AND THEN WHO DO WE HOLD
ACCOUNTABLE.
AND IN THIS CIRCUMSTANCE.
WHO IS OUR ULTIMATE RESPONSE WAS
A CITY?
YOU KNOW THAT'S A COMPLEX
QUESTION I HAVE TO BE HONEST
WITH YOU -- IT WILL ONLY TWO
ENTITIES YEAH I DISEASE THE IDEA
OF THE AND THERE'S DIEM.
AND THEN THERE IS INCREDIBLY OLD
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT JUST CAN'T
BE SUPPORTED ANYMORE -- WE HAVE
A SYSTEM THAT IS AN IBM SYSTEM
THE IBM CAN'T SUPPORT ANYMORE.
WE HAVE TO MIGRATE OVER TO AN
UPDATED IBM SYSTEM AND I WILL
TELL YOU IT'S NOT EVEN WHERE IT
NEEDS TO BE BUT IT GETS US IN A
MORE STABLE ENVIRONMENT THAT WE
NEED TO BE.
SO I CAN ALSO TELL YOU IT'S
AGING INFRASTRUCTURE AND WE HAVE.
PRACTICE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE ON
THIS AGING INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
HAS TO BE ADDRESSED SO THEN WHEN
YOU ROLL THESE KIOSKS AND
EVERYTHING THAT YOU'RE SUPPOSED
AT THESE TABLETS THAT -- AT THE
GERMAN TING TALKED ABOUT.
THEY OBVIOUSLY HAVE TO BE
SUPPORTED BY THIS INFRASTRUCTURE.
CORRECT THEY RECEIVE INFORMATION
FED FROM OUR SYSTEMS THE THE KEY
ALSO BASICALLY STALE SYSTEMS BUT
THEY DO RECEIVE INTERFACE WITH
OUR SYSTEM SO WE CAN PROCESS THE
APPLICATION SO WHEN THE SYSTEMS
GO DOWN. TO THESE KIOSKS TO WORK.
THE CHAOS MINERS THEY ARE ALSO
IMPACTED I THINK TRIPLE A WAS
IMPACTED THE KIOSKS WERE
IMPACTED.
SO SO IT'S IT SEEMS TO ME THAN
THAT.
THAT'S THAT WHEN THE SYSTEM GOES
DOWN EVERYTHING STOPS.
AT THAT LEVEL YES.
OKAY AND THEN SO WHO IS AN OLDER
RESPONSIBLE DENT IT SO.
AS A CUSTOMER CDT MARIJUANA
PECAN CT BUT IT'S IT'S ON IT'S
THAT NO CHOICE RIGHT.
IS THAT WHEN YOU WHEN YOU WANT
TO IMPROVE THESE THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE IBM
MAINFRAMES AND WHAT AND WHAT NOT.
DO YOU GO TO SEE THE TùAND
SAY WE WANT YOU TO PURCHASE AN
UPGRADE AND AND AND AND AND
EMPLOYMENT WHAT WE WANT OR DOES
HE NEED TO COME TO YOU AND SAY
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO FOR
YOU.
AND THEN YOU SAY YEA OR NAY.
SO THAT'S A JOINT EFFORT BECAUSE
THERE IS OVERSIGHT THE CITY HAD
CITY HAS FOR THE DMV -- BUT I
ALSO WILL TELL YOU THE APPROACH
THAT WE WANT TO TAKE THIS YEAR --
IS PUT IT OUT BECAUSE I THINK
TECHNOLOGY -- TECHNOLOGY IS
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY RICH IN
CALIFORNIA.
I THINK WE HAVE A LOT OF
PARTNERS HERE IN CALIFORNIA THAT
I THINK CAN ACTUALLY HELP US
SOLVE OUR PROBLEMS DMV AND SO
OUR GOAL IS TO REACH OUT. TO OUR
TECHNOLOGY PRIVATE SECTOR
PARTNER TO LOOK AT SOLVING THE
TECHNOLOGY PROBLEM WITH DMV.
AND SO OUR APPROACH -- IN THE
FIRST THE FRONT AND
SUSTAINABILITY IS TO TAKE THAT
STRATEGIC APPROACH AND NOT TRY
TO SOLVE IT OURSELVES.
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK THAT'S THE
RIGHT APPROACH I THINK IS TO
REACH OUT.
TO OUR AGAIN ARE ARE RICH RICH
TECHNOLOGY KNOWLEDGE IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR TO SEE IF WE CAN
FIGURE OUT.
HOW TO TRANSFORM THE DMV
TECHNOLOGIES BECAUSE THIS IS A
TRANSFORMATION IT IS A FULL ON
TRANSFORMATION?
HOW DO WE TRANSFORM THE DMV
SYSTEMS WHILE ALSO ENSURING THE
PROTECTION OF REALLY CRITICAL
DATA AND THE SECURITY OF THAT
DATA AS WE TRANSFORM SURE?
ARE YOU SAY THIS AND I I I DO
WANT TO SPRING THIS ON YOU SO I
APOLOGIZE BUT IT'S SOMETHING
THEY THEY COMES UP BECAUSE
THERE'S A CLEAR PATTERN.
OF FAILURES HERE WHEN IT COMES
TO AND IT MAY BE.
MORE CITY THAN TO DMB SO I JUST
WANT WILL THROW IT OUT THERE BUT
SO YOU'VE GOT THE SMART TABLETS
THAT ARE BEING ABLE MAY BE AT
THE OUTAGES. TO OUTAGES THAT
HAPPENED TODAY AND THEN THERE
WAS A VERY CONCERNING
INVESTIGATIVE STORY IN LA TIMES
TODAY ABOUT THE MISMANAGEMENT OF
THE MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM AND THE
CONFUSION AND CHAOS THAT WAS
EVIDENT AS IS ROLLING OUT.
AND OF COURSE THE DMV AND AND C.
T. WERE INVOLVED WITH THAT ALONG
WITH THE SECTORS STATE.
AND SO -- I GUESS THE CONCERN
FOR ME IS THAT -- AS WE ROLL OUT
THESE AYE IF THE I'VE AYE IF
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY AND THE
I. T. SYSTEM IS THE CORE PROBLEM.
THEN AND YOU'RE ASKING. FOR TWO
OR FORTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS
ABOVE THE EXISTING BUDGET HOW
MUCH OF THE TWO ONE FOUR TWO
MILLION IS GOING TO NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE AND AND I. T. PRO.
OR ARE PROVING THIS THIS -- IN
FROM IT INFRASTRUCTURE.
CHALLENGES THAT TURNED A ROBBIE
TO THOSE NUMBERS FOR YOU.
BUT TWO THINGS THAT I HOPE WILL
GIVE YOU SOME ASSURANCE WAYS
PULLING UP THE NUMBERS IS.
I AGREE THAT WE NEED TO GIVE YOU
INSURANCE THAT'S GOING TO SPEND
APPROPRIATE PART OF ITS
ESTABLISHING A VERY STRONG
GOVERNANCE ¡UCTURE
THAT LOOKS AT THE ENTERPRISE A
MEASURES RISK.
MEASURE STRATEGIC GOALS AND
MEASURES PERFORMANCE THE OTHER
PIECE THAT THEY MIGHT WANT TO
BRING IT CONSULTANT -- TO HELP
WITH THAT IN PLACE IN A BET THAT
INTO THE DMV ORGANIZATION.
THE OTHER PIECE THAT I WANT TO
BRING IN BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
OUR STRENGTH IS IN THIS AREA AT
DMV.
IS PROJECT MANAGEMENT.
BECAUSE OF THE MULTIPLE OF
PROJECTS THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE
GOING ON I WANT TO HAVE STRONG
PROJECT MANAGEMENT THAT'S
ACTUALLY REPORTING TO ME.
AND THEN THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
PART BUT IF THE PROJECT
MANAGEMENT IS AT C. T. AND C. T.
IS THE ACTUAL.
PROBLEM THEN WE'VE GOT A WE'VE
GOT WE'VE WE'VE ACTUALLY CREATE
A PROBABLY MADE THE PROBLEM
WORSE CORRECT CORRECT AND I'M
NOT GOING THAT ROUTE I'M
ACTUALLY GOING OUT WITH A
CONTRACT TO BRING IN SOMEBODY
OUTSIDE TO BE A PROJECT
MANAGEMENT OFFICE FOR ME A
PARTING DIRECTLY TO THE WHY.
DO WE HAVE THE CITY T..
WELL AND SUFFER I'M NOT SURE OF
THAT THEIR STAFF TO ACTUALLY
HANDLE THE VOLUME THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE DMV AND I AGAIN I
WOULD HAVE IS AND THIS IS A
HEARING AS EASY AS I APOLOGIZE
I'M JUST I'M JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND AND IF IF.
IF YOU COULD THE NUMBER THAT THE
NUMBERS SO YES SO WITHIN THE THE
PROPOSAL WE ACTUALLY HAVE TWO
ITEMS THAT ARE SO SHOULD WITH
LIFE IMPROVEMENT ONE IS.
A PER I COULD REDUNDANCY WHICH
IS WORKING THROUGH SPEAKING
ABOUT FOUR POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS.
AND SO THAT'S AN ANNUAL COST
WHAT THAT IS IS FOR OUR LARGER
OFFICES GRADE THREE FOURS AND
FIVES.
SMALLER OPPOSITE R. GRADES ONE
AND TWO SO THE GREAT BEFORE THE
FIVE OFF THE TO ALLOW ADDITIONAL
LINE COMING IN THE OFFICE SELECT
ONE OF THE LINES COMING FROM C.
T.. FOR WHAT EVERYTHING GOES
DOWN THERE'S ANOTHER LINE THAT
GOES INTO THAT OFFICE.
THE FACT THAT OKAY TONS OF FOUR
POINT SIX MILLION FOR THAT AND
THEN THERE'S ANOTHER THREE POINT
ONE MILLION - FOR I KEY
COMPONENTS AND IT'S REALLY AN
ANNUAL REPLACEMENT -- AND THAT'S
FOR SERVERS ROUTERS SWITCHES
THINGS ALONG THOSE LINES AS THEY
RELATE TO JUST FROM AT AN
OUTDATED A REFRESH PROCESS. TO
DO THAT SO THIS IS IMPORTANT
PART POINT WHICH I THINK IT
DOVETAILS INTO -- A WHAT IS A
NUMBER THAT PETRIE-NORRIS SAYS
THAT IF WE WANTED.
MILESTONES AND METRICS SO WHAT
HOW MUCH WOULD IT TAKE TO FIX.
THE I. T. PROBLEMS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE.
NOTTHE PEACE MIL FOUR POINT SIX
AND THREE POINT ONE MILLION WHAT
WOULD IT TAKE TO FIX THE PROBLEM.
MAY YOU YOU SAID AND RIGHTFULLY
SO IN YOUR OPENING STATEMENT
THAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR THE DMV
OF THE FUTURE.
RIGHT.
I HAVE NO INTEREST IN APPROVING
A BUDGET AUGMENTATION THAT
DOESN'T FIX THE PROBLEM.
SO WHAT FIXES THE PROBLEM.
NOT MORE STAFF.
BUT HOW IF INFRASTRUCTURE IS
THAT THE KEY COMPONENT AND OF
YOUR TWO THOUSAND STAFF MEMBERS
CAN EVEN DO THE WORK BECAUSE THE
I. T. SYSTEM FAILED.
AND THEY'RE SITTING THERE DOING
NOTHING AND THE GETTING YELLED
AT BY CUSTOMERS RIGHTFULLY SO.
HOW MUCH FIXES THE PROBLEM AND
WHAT DO WE NEED TO DO TO FIX THE
PROBLEM?
SO ALL THAT ROBBIE SPEAK TO BUT
I KNOW WE PUT TOGETHER A A FIVE
YEAR PLAN -- ON ADDRESSING OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH IS ENTITLED
FRONT AND SUSTAINABILITY WE'VE
ACTUALLY HAD SOME FURTHER
STRATEGIC CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THE MANNER WHICH WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE FORWARD -- MY PERSPECTIVE
ON THIS INTO YOUR POINT AND
YOU'RE ASKING FOR IS THE FIRST
THING I WANT TO SEE PUT IN
PLACES ENTERPRISE ARCHITECTURAL
PLAN.
THAT MOVES US INTO THE FUTURE.
AND WE DON'T HAVE THAT PLAN
RIGHT NOW BUT WE HAVE TO CREATE
THE ENTERPRISE ARCHITECTURAL
PLAN THAT KNOWLEDGE IS ALL THE
PRODUCT LINES THAT ARE SERVICE
BY DMV.
AND THEN THE AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND HOW DO WE
TRANSITION FROM OUR AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE TO A NEW --
SYSTEM THAT'S MUCH MORE FLEXIBLE
NIMBLE AND AND ROBUST FOR OUR
NEEDS -- THAT'S A FIVE YEAR
PROJECT AND I THINK THE GOAL IS
TO TAKE AN AGILE APPROACH THAT
FOR THE FIRST THING IS TO COME
UP WITH A PLAN. TO ENSURE THE
SAFETY AND SECURITY OF OUR
SYSTEM BUT I WHENI SAID I WANT
TO GO OUT WITH A PROBLEM
STATEMENT.
IS THAT HOW DO WE GO AHEAD AND
SOLVE THE CURRENT STATE OF THE
DMV TECHNOLOGY TO MAKE SURE.
THAT IT ACTUALLY MEETS OUR NEEDS
ON A REGULAR BASIS TWENTY FOUR
BY.
SEVEN I APPRECIATE THE ANSWER I
THINK I COULDN'T AGREE MORE THAT
WE NEED A PLAN WE'VE BEEN
WAITING FOR THIS PLAN FOR VERY
LONG TIME I'M ONLY IN MY SECOND
TERM AND I BELIEVE THAT MY
PREDECESSORS HAVE BEEN WAITING
FOR THAT PLAN AS WELL.
SO.
FROM I I'M NOT PICKING ON THE
DMB I'M I'M FIVE MORE PICKING ON
THAT FORMER TECHNOLOGY RIGHT NOW
BUT I THINK FOR US AS
LEGISLATORS.
AS LEGISLATOR WARS AS STEWARDS
OF THE TAX DOLLAR WE HAVE TO SEE
THE PLAN FIRST.
AND SO I CAN'T WE MAKE DECISIONS
I'VE SAID THIS BEFORE THE LAST
HEARING I'M I'M REPEATING MYSELF
BUT WE MAKE DECISIONS ON
IMPERFECT INFORMATION.
ALL OF US.
TO AND WE KNOW ONE INCH ABOUT
EVERYTHING AND SO PROVIDING US
WITH ADDITIONAL INCHES OF
INFORMATION IS CRITICAL.
AND SO YOU'RE ASKING FOR TWO
HUNDRED FORTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS ABOVE IT BILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET YOU ALREADY HAVE.
AND SO A YOU'VE AND ALL THE ALL
THE RESULT ALL THE REVIEWS THAT
OUTLINED THE SAME PROBLEM.
AND YOU EVEN ACKNOWLEDGE THE
SAME PROBLEM.
AND AND SO IF IT'S I. T. IF IT'S
CHAOS IF IT'S OUTSOURCING TO THE
TRIPLE A OR EVERYTHING THAT ARE
ALL THE THINGS WE THAT'S
INCLUDED IN THIS PLAN.
THEN JUST TELL US THE PLAN.
AND WE CAN EVALUATE WHAT THAT
PLAN IS AND THEN WE CAN
DETERMINE WHETHER WE SHOULD
FUNDED AT THAT LEVEL.
BUT IF YOU'RE PIECE MILLING IT
AND ALL WE'RE DOING IS APPROVING
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS EVERY SINGLE
YEAR ON TOP OF THE BILLION
DOLLARS AND AT THE END OF THE
DAY THAT DOESN'T FIX THE PROBLEM.
WITHIN I DON'T KNOW WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO YOU WHEN WE COME BACK
NEXT YEAR AND WE'RE HAVING THIS
EXACT SAME HEARING.
AND SO FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IF
THE PROBLEM IS TECHNOLOGY AND CD
T. ISN'T DOING THEIR JOB.
AND THEN ALL THE SUDDEN YOU'RE
GOING TO DO AN INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECT WERE NOT EVEN GOING TO
USE C. D. T. YOU'RE GONNA CREATE
YOUR OWN SYSTEM WITH YOUR OWN I
KEY PEOPLE THAT WE'VE CREATED
MULTIPLE.
AGENCIES AND MULTIPLE TECHNOLOGY
DEPARTMENTS AND THAT SEEMS
INEFFICIENT TO ME AND A WASTE OF
TAXPAYER DOLLARS SO I HOPE THAT.
OVER TIME AND I'M HAPPY TO SIT
DOWN WITH YOU AND WORK THAT OUT
IN TERMS OF WORKING OUT A LONG
TERM PLAN AND IF THE GOAL AND WE
ALL SHARE THIS GOAL IS TO
DEVELOP A DMB OF THE FUTURE THAT
WE CAN ALL BE PROUD OF THAT
CUSTOMERS WILL.
BE PROUD TO GO INTO OR NOT GO
INTO AS WE HOPE THEY PROBABLY
DON'T GO INTO NOW -- THAT WE CAN
FIGURE THAT OUT SO I I
APPRECIATE YOUR CANDOR
APPRECIATE THE INFORMATION --
ABOUT I CAN I HOPE YOU CAN --
TELL THAT MY FRUSTRATION IS VERY
HIGH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I KNOW -- MISTER
COOPER IS TO LEAVE HIM TO LET
HIM GO FIRST AND THEN TURN TO
MISTER PATTERSON.
I'LL JUST KEEP IT SHORT AND AN
AWFUL OF MR FUNDS QUESTIONS
REALLY THE BIG THING IS -- IN
THE IT AYE AYE KNOWS IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET YOU WANT -- SIX
POINT TWO MILLION FOR SIXTY FIVE
HUNDRED NEW PERSONAL COMPUTERS.
FOR MOST IT PROGRAM YOU'RE VERY
REPLACE REFRESH PROGRAM WHERE
YOU GO ALONG IT REPLACED A FEW
EVERY YEAR SO IT'S IT'S ONE BIG
BANG.
AND THAT REALLY GOES BACK TO
FUNDAMENTALLY FOR THE FOR THE
DMV THAT'S A BIG -- ONE ALL
ALONG.
YOU KNOW YOU STILL DO THE EFFORT
IT BEFORE I KNOW A LOT ABOUT IT
BUT DO NOT REFRESH REPLACE.
AND AS FAR AS YOUR YOUR PROJECT
MANAGERS GO PROJECT MANAGEMENT
IS NOT ROCKET SCIENTIST.
IT IS HOW THE PROJECT KEEPING ON
TASK AND FOLLOWING IT SO I I
KNOW YOU WANT TO GO OUT YOU
MENTIONED BY GOING OUT DOING
SME GOOD PROJECT MANAGERS.
I THINK YOU HAVE THOSE FOLKS IN
PLACE ALREADY THERE IN THE STATE
EMPLOYMENT ALREADY.
WHY ARE WE GONNA GO OUT ALREADY?
AND YOU HAVE PROJECT MANAGER
OVER SOME OF THESE PROJECTS.
I'VE BEEN TOLD WITH THE REAL ID.
AND WITH THE CUT THE OTHER I
CAN'T THINK OF WHAT IT WAS.
THE SIXTY OF THEM.
YEAH MOTOR VOTER WILL NOT MOTOR
VOTER THAT'S IT SO WAS THE SAME
[inaudible]
CHIEF.
OVER THOSE BOTH PROJECT MANAGERS
FOR THOSE PROJECTS.
THE CHECKS AND SHE FROM YOUR
AGENCY.
I'D HAVE TO LOOK AT THE DATA BUT
WHAT I WILL TELL YOU FROM A
STAFF STANDPOINT OR A TEA SHOP --
IS WE DO NEED TO MODERNIZE THAT
OPERATION -- I'M ALSO FACE WAS
SOME SUCCESSION PLANNING ISSUES
THAT WAS NOTED IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AUDIT -- SO I NEED TO
BE LOOKING AT WHO DO I NEED TO
RECRUIT IN YOUR RIGHT PROJECT
MANAGEMENT I CAN GO OUT AND
RECRUIT.
FOR BUT I ALSO KNOW THAT I HAVE
AN IMMEDIATE NEED WITH A
MULTITUDE OF PROJECTS THAT ARE
GOING ON RIGHT NOW.
WITH SOME STAFFING VACANCIES
THAT I HAVE BUT I ALSO WANT TO
GIVE SOME ASSURANCE -- TO THOSE
WHO QUESTION OUR CAPABILITY TO
DO THE JOB IS TO BRING SOMEBODY
OUTSIDE TO DO THE JOB BUT I ALSO
SEE IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO SOME
POWERFUL KNOWLEDGE TRANSFER.
I THINK OUR FOLKS NEED THAT
SKILL SO ANY CONTRACT THAT I
WOULD GO OUT WITH AND HAVE
SOMEBODY COME IN AND DO PROJECT
MANAGEMENT IS WITH THE
FUNDAMENTAL GOAL.
OF DEVELOPING MY STAFF AT THE
SAME TIME WITH THE KNOWLEDGE
TRANSFER THAT THEY NEED TO DO
THAT WORK.
AND WE NEED TO PROBABLY RE
EXAMINE HOW WE HANDLE PROJECTS
AT DMV.
THAT'S BEEN SOME OF CHALLENGES
WE HAVE BUT ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES WE HAVE FOR TV AGAIN
BECAUSE OF OUR A LEGACY SYSTEM.
WE DON'T GIVE OURSELVES ENOUGH
TESTING TIME TO TEST SOMETHING
BEFORE WE LAUNCH IT -- AND
THAT'S BEEN A CHALLENGE WHEN
WE'VE LOST SOME OF OUR PROJECTS
TO SOME OF THE UNFORESEEN --
GLITCHES AND ROLLING OUT
SOMETHING BECAUSE OF THE VOLUME
OF VERY OLD ASSEMBLER KAULBACH
COATS WE HAVE WITH THE DMV.
SO YOU HAVE SOME THE OLDEST --
NETWORKING SYSTEMS COMPUTER
SYSTEMS IN THE STATE.
IS THAT CORRECT THERE IS MY
UNDERSTANDING YES AND I KNOW YOU
THE ACTING DIRECTOR RIGHT NOW
HOW LONG HAVE YOU BEEN WITH THE
IN BEFORE.
US SINCE FEBRUARY FIRST OKAY THE
MINARET Là BUT A LOT OF FOLKS
HAVE BEEN FOLKS COME AND GO BUT
STILL YOU'RE YOU'RE MIDDLE
MANAGEMENT THE CRUX THEY RUN THE
DAY TO DAY OPERATIONS.
THOSE FOLKS HAVE BEEN THERE A
LONG TIME AND YOU KNOW WE TALK
ABOUT STRATEGIC GOALS THESE ARE
GREAT WORD PHRASES AND AND CATCH
PHRASES BUT ULTIMATELY COME DOWN
TO LEADERSHIP DOING THAT IT.
REALLY STARTS AND WITH
ACCOUNTABILITY SO THE HARD PART
IS WITH A LOT OF MONEY.
AT DMV YOU'RE ASKING FOR MORE
MONEY MORE PERSONNEL IT'S REALLY
HARD TO HAVE CONFIDENCE BECAUSE
THERE'S A TRACK RECORD HERE
GOING BACK ON THE BCP'S.
AND AFTER THAT IT HAPPEN OVER
MULTIPLE YEARS AND NOT MUCH IS
JAMES GODDING IT'S GOTTEN WORSE
I REALLY DO HAVE A LOT OF
CONFIDENCE.
IN DMV RIGHT NOW TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WITH THAT IT
EVEN JUST GOES A POINT THAT THE
COMPUTER JUST BASICS. SIXTY FIVE
HUNDRED COMPUTERS.
YOU CHANGE COMPUTERS OVER HERE
MAYBE A THOUSAND EVERY YEAR FIVE
HUNDRED EVERY EVERY OTHER BUDGET
CYCLE BUT TO CHANGE.
ALMOST SEVEN THOUSAND PETERS A
ONE TIME.
AT REALLY MAKES NO SENSE FOR
SOMEONE HAVE A GOAL TO PUT THAT
IN.
WHERE WERE YOU?
THE PAST FEW YEARS HE'S MAKING
THIS RECOMMENDATION FOR THIS.
I I T. IS NOT I MEAN FOR CERTAIN
PARTS OF IT IS NOT REALLY THAT
HARD.
BUT THAT THAT'S JUST THE
FRUSTRATING PART.
AND I SEE THIS AND IT'S JUST WAS
WASTING THE TAXPAYERS' MONEY.
THAT'S BY THE MOST TROUBLING
THING SITTING HERE -- TO TRY TO
RECONCILE THAT NOTHING THE
BROUGHT COMPLETELY HEARD ABOUT
THE IN THE MY FIELD OFFICE WHICH
IS IN SACRAMENTO ELK GROVE.
NUMBER CAN PLAY FREEZE AGENCY IS
ABOUT YOUR AGENCY.
SELESAI THE WORD ONCE BEING
IGNORED AMOUNT OF MY PURSE MIKE
STAFF TIME ON THE IN THE ISSUES.
AND YOU KNOW FOR FOLKS TO CALL
AND THEY GOT THE PRETTY.
PO.
SELECT THAT YOU KNOW -- IN A LOT
DON'T CALL AND SO TO ME THE
PROBLEM IS MUCH MORE --
SIGNIFICANT THEN ON THE SURFACE
SO.
THAT'S THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY
FOR NOW.
THANK MISS COOPER MISTER
PATTERSON.
THEY JUST UP.
I HAVE A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS
WITH RESPECT TO REAL ID AND YOUR
CUSTOMER WAIT TIMES AND WHEN I
ASK A COUPLE OF SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS THERE AND THEN LATER.
WHEN THE SECRETARY AB THE
BACHELOR IS HERE -- I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT WHAT THE THAT THE
ENVY OF THE FUTURE LOOKS LIKE.
AND THEN JUST KIND OF SETTING
THE STAGE HERE.
I REALLY THINK WE HAVE GOT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE IS A HUGE
PROBLEM NOW.
AND YET THERE I BELIEVE THERE IS
A POTENTIAL IN A POSSIBILITY TO
GET TO A D. M. V. OF THE FUTURE.
BUT THE CHALLENGE YOU HAVE IT
SEEMS TO ME IS YOU ARE IN THE
MIDDLE OF KEEPING A D. M. V.
OPERATING WHILE YOU ARE TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW YOU ENTIRELY
RE ENGINEERING.
SO UNLESS WE'RE WILLING TO SAY
WE'RE GOING TO SHUT IT DOWN
TODAY TURN IT OFF FOR AWHILE AND
THEN FIX IT.
I'M THAT'S NOT REALISTIC EITHER
SO WE'VE GOT THE PROBLEM OF
TODAY.
BUT THEN I THINK THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY OF TOMORROW AND I
WANT TO ADDRESS THAT A LITTLE
BIT WITH.
WITH THE SECRETARY AND I'M GONNA
PREFACE IT WITH THIS WE ARE THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY.
ON THE PLAN.
WITH HOME.
OF SILICON VALLEY.
UP WE ARE -- THE STATE THAT HAS
REALLY DEMONSTRATED WHAT.
TECHNOLOGICAL AND AIDED CUSTOMER
SERVICE REALLY LOOKS LIKE. FOR
EXAMPLE AMAZON OR ANY OF THE
OTHER LARGE TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES.
ARE.
AND SO I WANT TO FIRST OF ALL
TALK ABOUT RIGHT HERE AND NOW.
WITH A COUPLE OF ISSUES OF
CONCERN.
AND THEN LATER I WANNA EXT I
WANT TO REALLY EXPLORE WHAT THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY DMV.
CAN LOOK LIKE.
I WANT TO SAY ALSO FROM THE
OUTSET THAT I APPRECIATED YOUR
VISIT WITH ME YESTERDAY.
AND WE HAD SOME VERY YOU GOT
DIRECT CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS.
AND I HAVE TO SAY THAT I AM MORE
ENCOURAGED NOW -- THAN I WAS
WHEN THE GOVERNOR INITIATE THAT
THE PREVIOUS GOVERNOR INITIATED
WHAT I THOUGHT WAS A RATHER LATE
AND SORT OF LACKLUSTER APPROACH
TO THIS.
WHAT WE DO HAVE NOW IS A
GOVERNOR WHO IN MY ESTIMATION
JUMPED OUT VERY EARLY ON THIS IN
HIS STATE OF THE STATE?
AND HE ARE FRANKLY A APPOINTED
SOMEONE -- THAT I HAVE KNOWN --
AND HAVE WATCHED AND UP FOR
SOMETIME.
AND I AND I THINK THAT SECRETARY
BATCH OR WAS IT WAS A GREAT
CHOICE ON THIS.
AND I THINK THE STRIKE FORCE
REALLY DOES HAVE SOME REAL
OPPORTUNITIES HERE.
BUT THERE IS A BIG BIG CHASM
BETWEEN WHERE WE ARE NOW AND
WHERE WE HAVE GOT TO GET.
TO AND SO I WANT TO JUST REMIND
US THAT THIS IS THE THIS IS THE
STATE THAT HAS LED.
THE WORLD IN TECHNOLOGY AND YET
WE HAVE A DMV THAT THE
INSTITUTION THAT FACES MORE
PEOPLE WITHOUT A ESSENTIALLY
ALMOST A MONOPOLY ON THEIR
SERVICE AND THEIR TIME.
AND IT IS IN FACT.
JUST IN.
IT IS SPECIAL NOT WORKING -- AND
WE ALL KNOW THAT WE WE WE WE'VE
GOTTEN TO THE POINT THAT.
YOU KNOW OUR BUT WHAT WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE PAST THE THE
PATIENT'S SIDE.
AND YEAH I REALLY THINK THERE
NEEDS TO BE A BIT OF A WAR A
WORD OF WARNING HERE.
THIS IS GOING TO BE SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING TO TAKE SOME TIME.
M. YOU CAN'T JUST CLOSE THE DMV
DOWN.
YOU THINK YOU'VE GOT PROBLEMS
NOW WANT YOU YOU KNOW
DECONSTRUCTED IN SUCH A WAY THAT
YOU CAN'T EVEN DO.
LIMITED FEW FUNDAMENTALS BUT
THEN THERE IS THE NEXT QUESTION
WHAT DOES THAT TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY.
D. M. V. LOOKS LIKE I THINK IF
YOU CAN DO AMAZON LIKE
TECHNOLOGY AND YOU CAN DEVELOP A
A DMV THAT DOESN'T JUST HAVE.
A YOU KNOW A REALLY UNDERSTANDS
THAT THE DMV SERVE THE CUSTOMER
NOT THE OTHER WAY AROUND.
AND I'VE HEARD ALSO SOME
SUGGESTIONS THAT DECENTRALIZING
IT.
ASKING YOUR PARTNERS TO DO MORE --
THE TRIPLE A IS A PER PERFECT
EXAMPLE THERE LOTS OF OTHER WAYS
THAT YOU CAN REDUCE THE WAIT
TIMES.
MOVE FOLKS -- TO TO OUTSIDE --
PLACES THAT'S MUCH MUCH MORE
CONVENIENT AND ACTUALLY HELPS TO
CUT THOSE WAIT TIMES DOWN BUT
THE TWO THINGS I WANT TO JUST
ASK DIRECTLY HERE.
FROM -- SUCH A FROM MY
RECOLLECTION THIS IS ABOUT REAL
ID.
THE DMV HAD A PLAN TO CORRECT
ITS COMPLIANCE ISSUE BY APRIL
FIRST.
BUT APPARENTLY FAILED TO MEET
ITS OWN DEADLINE.
NOW.
I GUESS THE THE DMV IS SAYING
IT'S THE END OF THE MONTH.
I'M MY CONCERN IS ARE YOU.
COMPLIANCE WITH THE FEDERAL.
REQUIREMENTS OR NOT IT SEEMS
LIKE THE FEDERAL.
THE AGENCY.
IS SAYING OUR WHERE TESTING TO
SEE THAT YOU'RE COMPLIANT WILL
MAKE A DECISION AND IT SEEMS
LIKE THE DMV IS SAYING WELL
WE'RE COMPLIANT WE'RE WAITING
FOR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT -- TO
APPROVE OUR COMPLIANCE MY
QUESTION IS ARE YOU IN FACT REAL
ID COMPLIANCE NOW OR ARE YOU IN
DEFAULT OF COMPLIANCE AND ARE
STILL WORKING ON A DEADLINE IN
WHICH YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
COME INTO COMPLIANCE.
SO IN THE COMPLIANCE BASE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY WE RECEIVED OUR LETTER
YESTERDAY FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY -- THEY'VE
EXTENDED OUR COMPLAINTS PERIOD
TILL MAY TWENTY FOURTH -- TWENTY
NINETEEN THEY WANT TO ACTUALLY
SEE US IMPLEMENTS.
THE CHANGE THAT WE'RE GOING TO
BE MAKING BOTH FOR WHAT I CALL
KIND OF GO THE SECOND GENERATION
OF GOING FORWARD WHICH IS
REQUIRING TO RESIDENCY DOCUMENTS.
WHERE THERE WAS A QUESTION THAT
WE WAITED TO HEAR FROM HOMELESS
CREE SO WE KNEW HOW TO IMPLEMENT --
THE APPROPRIATE SOLUTION.
WAS OUR FOLKS AND I REFER TO
THEM AS OUR EARLY ADOPTERS WE
ROLLED OUT -- THE REAL ID BACK
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE WERE ONLY
REQUIRING ONE RESIDENCY DOCUMENT.
WE ACTUALLY FOLLOWED WHAT OTHER
ANOTHER STATE HAD ACTUALLY DONE
AND PUT THAT FORWARD AS OUR PLAN
GOING FORWARD.
WE LATER LEARNED FROM HOMELAND
SECURITY THAT WAS NOT ACCEPTABLE
THAT YOU HAVE TO ACTUALLY
REQUIRED TO RESIDENCY DOCUMENTS.
SO WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS ADDRESS
ALL THOSE INDIVIDUALS AND
THERE'S ABOUT THREE POINT FOUR
MILLION AT THIS POINT.
THAT -- HAVE
THEIR REAL ID BUT SUBMITTED ONE
RESIDENCY DOCUMENT -- WE PUT
FORWARD A PLAN HOW TO GET THE
SECOND RENTS THE DOCUMENT
BECAUSE MY KEY GOAL WAS.
NOT HAVING THOSE THREE POINT
FOUR MILLION PEOPLE COME BACK TO
THE OFFICE.
I WANT TO BE ABLE TO HANDLE IT
EITHER ONLINE OR BY MAIL.
THE OFFICE OF HOMELAND THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
APPROVE THAT PLAN.
WE ALSO WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE UNDERSTOOD THE TIMELINE IN
WHICH TO GO AHEAD AND CLICK THE
SECOND RUNS A DOCUMENT -- IN
THEIR LETTER BACK TO US --
BASICALLY WE HAVE TO PASS THEY
CAN COME IN ANY TIME NOW IF THEY
WANT TO GO AHEAD AND ADD THEIR
SECOND RAZZIE DOCUMENT. TO THE
REAL IDEA WILL REFLECT OUR
RECORDS OR AT THEIR SUBSEQUENT
RENEWAL.
THEY CAN COME IN WITH THEIR
SECOND RESIDENCY DOCUMENT.
SO OUR CONCERN WAS THAT WE
DIDN'T KNOW IF THEY ARE IN
REQUIRES TO DO THAT ALSO BY
OCTOBER ONE TWENTY TWENTY TO
COLLECT ALL THE SECOND RESIDENCY
DOCUMENTS THEIR LETTER TO A SAYS.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO BE
REQUIREMENTS SO CAN HAPPEN OVER
THE COURSE OF TIME UNTIL THEY
RENEW THEIR ON THEIR CURRENT
LICENSE -- AND THEN WE BASICALLY
HAVE BEEN GOING FOR WITH THE
SECOND RESIDENT DOCU WE
BASICALLY DID A SOFT LAUNCH MANY
OF OUR FOLKS OF APPLIED FOR REAL
ID HAVE COME IN.
WITH TO RESIDENCY DOCUMENTS -- I
THINK ARE I BELIEVE OUR WEBSITE
ALSO REFERS THEM TO BRING TO
RESIDENCY DOCUMENTS SO WE HAVE
ONLY A HANDFUL OF PEOPLE
PROBABLY SINCE JANUARY THAT HAVE
NOT BROUGHT INTO RESIDENCY
DOCUMENTS.
BUT OFFICIALLY GOING APRIL GOING
FOR APRIL TWENTY NINTH THEY MUST
ACTUALLY PROVIDE AND PROVIDE TO
RESIDENCY DOCUMENTS TO GO HEAD
SECURE THEIR REAL ID THAT'S THE
CHANGE THAT'S THE COMPLIANCE
PIECE THAT WERE BEING HELD.
TO BY THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY [inaudible]
SO THE MY UNDERSTANDING IS THEN
THAT THE ANSWER IS YOU ARE
PRESENTLY NON COMPLIANT.
AS OF AS OF APRIL TWENTY NINTH
WE WILL BE COMPLYING WITH
HOMELAND SECURITY THEY WANT TO
SEE IS IMPLEMENTED BECAUSE THAT
WILL BE THAT THE DATE WE'VE SAID
WE WILL START OFFICIALLY.
NO BUTS WILL OFFICIALLY BE
ASKING FOR TOO RESIDENCIA
DOCUMENTS [inaudible]
AND WHEN YOU OFFICIALLY ASK FOR
TO YOU ARE IN COMPLIANCE.
THAT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING FROM
THAT PART OF HOMELAND SECURITY
THEY WILL ACTUALLY THEN.
GET BACK WITH US BY HERE'S A
BEFORE MAY TWENTY FOURTH OF
TWENTY NINETEEN TO LET US KNOW
FOR COMPLIANCE AT MY MY STANDING
AS THE MAY TWENTY FOURTH IS THE
EXTENDED PERIOD CORRECT -- IN --
EMAIL INFORMATION.
YOU WE'VE HAD DISCUSSIONS AND
YOU KNOW THAT THERE ARE.
SIGNIFICANT INDIVIDUALS -- WHAT --
THAT ARE ESSENTIALLY.
SORT OF WHISTLE BLOWERS INSIDE
OPERATIONS AND WE ARE.
WE HAVE INFORMATION AT THAT THE
WE WE PAY SOME ATTENTION.
TO ADD IN SOME EXCHANGES WITH
THE SENIOR LEGISLATIVE ASSISTANT --
SIX SUGGESTS THIS AND AND IN AN
EMAIL THAT THIS REVIEW PERIOD
WILL AND NO LATER THAN MAY
TWENTY FOURTH OF TWENTY NINETEEN
ONCE CALIFORNIA MEETS ALL REAL
ID REQUIREMENTS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY WILL APPROVE THE STATE
AS FULLY COMPLIANT SO AS OF NOW
WE ARE NOT IN COMPLIANCE.
COMPLIANCE AND THE ACTIVITIES
THAT YOU ARE UNDERTAKING BETWEEN
NOW AND MAY. TWENTY FOURTH.
WE'LL BRING YOU INTO COMPLIANCE.
AND SO CAN YOU SAY THAT WHAT YOU
HAVE LAUNCHED.
AND THAT WILL MEET THE TIMELINE.
WILL RESULT BY OR EARLIER THAN
MAY TWENTY FOURTH [inaudible]
HOMELAND SECURITY'S --
CERTIFICATION THAT YOU ARE IN
FULL COMPLIANCE.
OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
INDICATE THAT THEY WILL GIVE US
COMPLIANCE ONCE I SEE IS ROLLING
OUT AS OF APRIL TWENTY NINTH --
THAT'S ALL I CAN TELL YOU IS
THAT'S WHAT THEY'VE CONVEY TO US
AND THAT -- WHAT WE'RE GONNA BE
DOING WILL ACTUALLY PUT US INTO
COMPLIANCE YOU YOU REFERENCE THE
THREE POINT SOME ODD MILLION --
I'M I'M SURE YOU HAVE SEEN THE
SACRAMENTO BEE STORY ON THIS
TODAY -- HI.
AGAIN I WOULD I I REALLY HOPE
THAT.
THE PRESENTATIONS THAT WE'RE
HEARING TODAY THAT SOUND VERY
MUCH LIKE TO PRESENTATIONS.
WE WERE HEARING THAT
[inaudible]
BACK FORMALLY [inaudible]
SOUNDS SIMILAR.
AND THE CLOCK IS TICKING WITH
RESPECT. TO THREE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS AND YOU SAY SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE THROUGH THE DOOR.
WHAT HE SAID A DAY?
MONTH A MONTH MONTH A MONTH
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THERE ARE.
MY POINT IS THIS THAT ARE I
REALLY THINK THE REAL ID IS IS
IS.
THE TOP OF THE PYRAMID HERE TO
GET THIS RIGHT -- AND AND YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE SOME DEADLINES
HERE TO MEET.
AND IF WE GET TO A PLACE WHERE
IT IS INSUFFICIENT TO GET TO THE
COMPLIANCE.
WETHOUGHT OUR WEIGHT LINES AND
OUR DIFFICULTIES ARE PROBLEMS IN
THE DISTANCE APPOINTMENT WITHOUT --
CUSTOMERS AND AND CONSTITUENTS
IN CALIFORNIA WAS BAD BACK THEN.
WAIT UNTIL WE HIT A HARD LINE
WHERE THEY HAVE BY.
TWENTY TWENTY AND WE'VE GOT.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS IF NOT
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS SAYING
ALL MY GOODNESS I GOT TO GET IN
AND GET.
SO IT DOESN'T IT BEHOOVE YOU TO
GET COMPLIANCE.
AS SOON AS YOU POSSIBLY CAN AND
CAN YOU ASSURE US THAT
COMPLIANCE WILL BE MET BY THIS
DEADLINE.
SO FROM A COMPLIANCE STANDPOINT
AS FAR AS REQUIRING TO RESIDENCY
DOCUMENTS YES ABSOLUTELY WE'RE
GOING TO BE DOING THAT.
THE CHALLENGE WE HAVE WITH REAL
ID IS THE FACT THAT IT'S ALSO
NOT MANDATORY IT'S VOLUNTARY
COMPLIANCE.
AND WHILE WE CAN FORECAST THE
ONGOING ANNUAL RENEWAL OF
DRIVERS LICENSE AND IDEAS THAT
COME UP WE CAN FORECAST THAT A
CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF THOSE
PEOPLE I THINK ARE FORECAST IS
ABOUT 75% OF THOSE PEOPLE WILL
OPT. FOR HAVE A REAL ID --
WHETHER AS A DRIVER'S LICENSE OR
AN ID CARD BECAUSE IF YOU HAVE A
PASSPORT OR SOME OTHER APPROVED
DOCUMENT PASSPORT WITH A
DRIVER'S LICENSE WILL ALLOW YOU
TO BOARD A PLANE -- THE
UNCERTAIN TODAY IS REALLY HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE GOING TO NEED
REAL ID AND WANT REALITY AND
THAT'S THE UNKNOWN PIECES HOW
MANY PEOPLE IN ADVANCE OF THEIR
REGULAR RENEWAL CYCLE.
WILL WANT TO COME INTO THE
OFFICE BECAUSE THEY WANT TO OPT
IN TO GET REAL ID BEFORE THEIR
RENEWAL IS DUE.
THAT'S A BIT OF A GUESSING GAME
WE'RE LOOKING AT OTHER STATES
AND LOOKING AT THE TAKE OPERATE.
THAT THEY'RE SEEING AGAIN HOW
CAN WE SHARE BEST PRACTICES WHAT
ARE WE LEARNING DO WE NEED TO
ACTUALLY FORECAST AT A LITTLE
BIT HIGHER. TO YOUR POINT I WISH
I HAD A CRYSTAL BALL HAD MORE
CERTAINTY WITH EXACTLY THE
VOLUME WE ARE.
GIVING OUR BEST ESTIMATE ON WHAT
WE THINK IS GOING TO BE THE TAKE
OPERATE NOT ONLY FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAVE RENEWALS BUT PEOPLE WHO
MAYBE WILL COME IN ADVANCE OF
THEIR RENEWAL.
BUT COMPLIANCE IS REALLY FROM AN
INDIVIDUAL STANDPOINT WE WILL BE
A COMPLIANCE BECAUSE WE FIND WE
HAVE A PROCESS FOR PEOPLE TO
COME AND GET REAL ID IF THEY
WANT A REAL ID.
THEY CAN COME IN AND GET IT THE
QUESTION IS WHEN THEY SHOW UP IN
AN AIRPORT AND THEY WANT TO FLY.
DO THEY HAVE ALL THE REQUIRED
DOCUMENTATION AS A CALIFORNIA TO
DO THAT. ONE FINAL QUESTION IN
THIS AREA.
HAD HAVE YOU HAD ASSURANCES THAT
THE THAT THE REAL ID FORMAT WHAT
IT LOOKS LIKE AND IT PHYSICAL
WHEN YOU HAVE IT.
IS THAT IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE
EXPECTATIONS OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT YES THAT IS -- ONE
OTHER POINT HERE WITH RESPECT TO
CUSTOMER WAIT TIMES AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT.
TROUBLED ME ABOUT THE WHAT IT.
WAS THE AT THE APPARENT -- LACK
OF CANDOR AND FRANKLY I'M I'M
NOT.
I'M NOT I DON'T WANNA SAY
[inaudible]
THE THE WASN'T TELLING THE TRUTH
BUT IT SURE FELT LIKE IT WHEN IT
COMES TO TRACKING THE TIME A
CUSTOMER WAITS IN LINE BEFORE
THEY ARE CHECKED IN.
AND SO IF YOU GO ON THE WEBSITE
THE WEBSITE REPRESENTS A CERTAIN
WEIGHT TIME.
AND THE AUDIT DETERMINED.
I THINK THAT THAT WAS NOT
ACCURATE -- I ASKED FORMER
DIRECTOR SHE MOTOR ABOUT THIS
THE LAST TIME SHE WAS HERE.
AND SHE WAS SHE INSISTED THAT
THE DMV WAS WORKING ON WAYS TO
TRACK THE COMPLETE DIRECTION.
THE DURATION OF WAIT TIMES.
AND AS OF THE AUDIT THE
CONCLUSION WAS THAT THE AUDIT
MENTIONS THAT THIS AS WELL.
OF THAT THIS THIS.
PRE Q. ISSUE -- SO BASICALLY --
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE TO WAIT OR NOT
IN A LINE TO GET TO TAKE YOUR
ICKET.
SEEMS LIKE THE WHAT THE DMV IS
DONNA SAID THAT'S THE WAIT TIME
WHEN YOU TAKE THE TICKET.
NOBODY SEEMS TO UNDERSTAND OR
WANT TO REPORT.
THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE GONNA END UP
SITTING IN IN IN A WAIT TIME IN
IN A LINE THAT IS MUCH LONGER
THAN THE TIME IT TAKES YOU TO
GET THE TICKET.
AND TO GET TO THE WINDOW -- CAN
YOU ASSURE US THAT.
THE WAIT TIME INFORMATION WILL
BE PRECISE AND ACCURATE AND
REPRESENT THE REAL WAIT TIME --
THAT PEOPLE HAVE TO INDOOR.
I MUST TELL YOU THAT.
MOST PEOPLE WHO CONTACT US ABOUT
THE DMB AND IT'S BEEN A LOT OVER
THIS.
THESE LAST THREE YEARS -- THEY
TAKE IT THE TRUST FACTOR IN THE
BELIEVABILITY OF THE DMB IS IS
JUST THAT SHREDDED.
AND PART OF IT IS THAT.
YOU CAN'T TRUST.
WHAT SHOWS UP ON THE DMV WEBSITE
TO BE ACTUAL PEOPLE SAY WELL YOU
GOT AN HOUR WAIT?
AND THERE AND THEY GO IN AND
THEY WAIT AN HOUR AND A HALF OR
TWO OR YOU HAVE A HALF HOUR WAIT
TIME AND IT'S ACTUALLY AN HOUR
AN HOUR AND A HALF -- SO CAN'T
IT WILL THE DATA AND THE
INFORMATION THAT YOU PUT ON THE
WEBSITE THAT SAYS TO PEOPLE.
YOU'RE GONNA EXPECT THIS AT
FRESNO WE'RE GONNA EXPECTED SHIP
SACRAMENTO AND THAT IT WILL BE
AN APPROPRIATE CALCULATION FROM
THE TIME THAT THEY GET IN THE
FRONT DOOR.
WAIT THROUGH THE LINE TO GET THE
TICKET.
PULL THE TICKET AND THEN GET TO
THE WINDOW.
SO I'M GONNA TURN THIS OVER TO
COLLEEN BUT I WANT -- TO CLARIFY
THAT WE HAVE A METHODOLOGY AND
ALL HAVE CALLING SPEAK TO THAT
METHODOLOGY.
BUT WE ALSO CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
WAYS TO IMPROVE THAT METHODOLOGY
TO ENSURE ACCURACY I THINK YOUR
POINT WE NEED TO PROVIDE OUR
CUSTOMERS WITH A REASONABLE
EXPECTATION THAT WHEN THEY GO TO
ONE OFFICE WHAT IS THAT WAIT
GOING TO BE.
AND SO WITH THAT CALLING YOU
WANT TO TALK ABOUT HOW WE'RE
CURRENTLY MEASURING NOT SURE SO
I'M A CURRENTLY YOU CAN HEAR ME
I'M CURRENTLY AND AS YOU STATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON IT IS
IT'S A MANUAL TRACKING SYSTEM.
SO THE TOPIC EACH OUR VERY A CAN
SHE WENT.
IT IS THE LATTER PART TYPE --
AVENUE TAKE THAT CARD AT THE TOP
OF THE HOUR WE GIVE IT WE
RECORDED AND IT SAN MANUEL
TRACKING.
AND I SHARE YOUR CONCERN AS WELL
THAT WHAT YOU SEE ON THE WEBSITE
TRULY IS THE ONLY REFLECTIVE OF
THE TIME A TICKET IS ISSUED AND
TELL THE CUSTOMER SERVICE.
AND OVER THESE LAST COUPLE
MONTHS WE'VE REALLY BEEN
EXPLORING WAYS THAT WE CAN TRACK
THE TOTAL CUSTOMER JOURNEY.
EVERYTHING CANNOT MEET AGAIN HI
MEDI WE HAVE AN OFFICE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA -- ARE
CARMICHAEL OFFICE THAT HAS
MOBILE WORKSTATIONS BOTH MOBILE
WORKSTATIONS HAVE THE TABLET ON
THE ARBITRON FOR LACK OF A
BETTER WORD.
AND AS THE CUSTOMER COMES IN
THERE IMMEDIATELY AND TURNED
INTO THE QUEUE AND THEN THEY HAD
ONTO THEIR DL NEXT STEPS AND
THEN BE OUR NEXT STEP.
THAT MOBILE WORKSTATION HAS THE
ABILITY IT CHARGES OVERNIGHT HAS
THE ABILITY TO GO OUT FIGHT AS
WELL.
MIKE WAS UNIQUE OFFICES HAVE
REPEATERS AND IT IS SIGNAL GOES
OUT WE HAVE OTHER OFFICES IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
ALSO KILEY MISSED.
AND REALLY IT IS ON AND IT'S
CONTINGENT UPON THE ABILITY TO
HAVE A SINGLE REACH OUTSIDE OF
THE BUILDING SO WOULD YOU
RECOGNIZE IT SO WHAT YOU SEE FOR
CARMICHAEL IS TRULY REFLECTIVE
YOUR ENTIRE CUSTOMER DIRTY.
IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT YEAH
[inaudible]
WITH THE A SUGGESTION YEAH.
YOU HAVE A METHODOLOGY THAT IS --
AT THE BEST ON CLEAR AND
POSSIBLY EVEN A BIT.
DECEIVING.
IT'S NOT ACCURATE.
WHY DON'T YOU SAY SOMETHING ON
THE WEBSITE PAGE THAT SAYS THIS
IS AN ESTIMATE YOU MAY?
END UP WAITING -- YOU KNOW A LOT
LONGER DO YOU DO THAT.
PRESENTLY DO YOU WARN THEM.
THAT THIS IS A GAS.
IT COULD BE WORSE.
IT OUT OF IF YOU IF YOU SHOW UP
SOMETHING THAT BASICALLY TELLS
FOLKS WE UNDERSTAND AND WE'RE
TRYING TO DO OUR BEST.
BUT WHEN YOU TELL THEM ONE THING
AND THEN THEIR EXPERIENCE IS
SOMETHING ELSE AND YOU DON'T
GIVE THEM THE KIND OF WARNING
THAT EVERY RETAILER EVERY.
TECHNOLOGY OPERATION.
YOU SEE IT ON ADVERTISEMENTS
RIGHT THE THE THE AT THE BOTTOM
OF THE ADVERTISEMENT I RESULTS
MAY VERY.
THIS IS A REAL WORLD OF REAL
COMMUNICATIONS WITH REAL PEOPLE
I'M HOPING THAT.
YOUR COMMUNICATIONS.
WILL WILL NOT TRUST ITSELF IN A
IN A IN A FORMULA.
THAT IS MISLEADING AND THAT YOU
CLEARLY LET PEOPLE KNOW WHAT
THEY CAN EXPECT THAT'S WHY
THEY'RE COMING TO THE WEBSITE.
NOW I APPRECIATE THAT SUGGESTION
IT DOES INDICATE ON OUR WEBSITE
IT PROBABLY COULD BE A LOT MORE
PREDOMINANT A LOT MORE.
OUT THERE IN VISIBLE THAT DAY.
THE TIME IT'S REFLECT ON THE
INTERNET IS REFLECTIVE OF THE
TICKET.
ENTIRE TRANSACTION IT DOES NOT
INDICATE THE FREAKY TIME BUT
AGREED WE CAN DO A FAR BETTER
TIME.
YES AND IN THAT WAY WHAT DO YOU
SAY THAT WAIT TIMES COULD
POSSIBLY BE LONGER WE DO NOT.
IN.
NINETEEN THANK YOU FOR THE
SUGGESTION.
MR FRAZIER HAD ONE QUICK FOLLOW
UP QUESTION TO MISTER BROWN WHEN
I'M GONNA.
ASK.
QUESTION BETWEEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- I
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THIS THIS
ON AND AND AGAIN YOU KNOW PLEASE
TAKE THIS IS CONSTRUCTIVE --
DIALOGUE -- WE TALKED IN THE
PAST IN THE LEGISLATURE'S AND I
AND I BEG YOUR PARDON IF THIS IS
BEEN ASKED AND ANSWERED I DO
OVER TO HUMAN Và.
HOA SERVICES TO TESTIFY BUT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE QUITE A
WORKLOAD FOR THE DMV OVER A
PERIOD OF TIME.
CAN YOU.
SHARE HAS IT ADEQUATELY BEEN
FUNDED.
WITH WHAT THE LIKE AB.
SIXTY A MOTOR VOTER AB NINETY
THREE ALL OF THESE THINGS ARE
CONTINUALLY PILE UP.
AND THEN.
US GOING WELL.
WE TOLD YOU.
HELLO CAN YOU SHARE WITH ME
[inaudible]
THE ADDITIONAL.
THINGS THAT WE'VE ASKED YOU TO
DO HAS IT BEEN -- FUNDED IN THE
APPROPRIATE WAY.
NOT ONLY FUNNY BUT THE MANPOWER
THAT IT WAS REQUIRING.
AN WHERE YOU JUST TAKEN IT ALL
ON IN JUST.
AS AN ORGANIZATION IN SAINT
LEGISLATURE WANTS US TO DO THIS
WE'RE GONNA DO THE BEST WE CAN.
SO I'M GONNA -- HAVE ROBBIE
PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT MORE
SUFFICIENT KNOWLEDGE BUT LET ME
SHARE WITH YOU MY OBSERVATION
AND THE TWO AND A HALF MONTHS
I'VE BEEN A TEAM MADE.
I THINK THERE IS A BIT OF A GOOD
SOLDIER -- ATTITUDE THAT THEY
THEY JUST PRESUME THERE IS WHEN
THEY'RE ASKED TO DO THINGS THEY
DO IT BUT WHAT IT DOES ALSO IS --
BECAUSE A RE PRIVATIZATION OF
THINGS THAT NEED TO BE DONE -- I
KNOW THAT SOMEONE MEMBER COOPER
BROUGHT UP -- THE REFRESH AND
YOU'RE RIGHT IN ANY OTHER
DEPARTMENT I WOULD SEE REFRESHES
A NORMAL ACTIVITY.
BUT NOT WHEN YOU'RE ABSORBING
COSTS THAT ARE ACTUALLY.
NOT FACTORED INTO YOUR BUDGET
THEN IN ORDER TO PAY FOR THOSE
COSTS THAN SOMETHING ELSE HAS TO
GO IN THE DMV IS BEEN FACED.
WITH THOSE CHALLENGES WITH THE
CARS THERE BUDGET -- WITH
REGARDS -- TO PROBABLY THE
HISTORY WE RAN -- KIND OF A
TALLY OF THE NUMBER OF BILLS
HAVE BEEN PASSED IN THE LATE
LAST EIGHT YEARS THAT --
REQUIRED DMV TO ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT PROGRAMS AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY -- ADDRESS PRO RING
PROGRAMMING CHANGES WITHIN ARE
VERY FRAGILE TECHNOLOGY
ENVIRONMENT.
AND THERE ARE A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY BILLS.
THAT HAVE BEEN PASSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRING THE DMV TO
DO SOMETHING WITH REGARDS TO ITS
PROGRAMS AND PRODUCTS THAT IT'S
SERVICES.
NOW MOTOR VOTER WHICH I'VE
BECOME VERY ACQUAINTED WITH IN
THE LAST TWO MONTHS -- ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I AM INSTITUTING
RIGHT NOW AT DMV BECAUSE IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO GET
MOTOR VOTER RIGHT.
AND I HAVE TO STAFF IT CORRECTLY --
IT'S BEEN TREATED BASICALLY AS A
PROJECT.
AND WHAT I MOVING FOR THIS
ESTABLISHING A GOVERNANCE
STRUCTURE AND THEN I'M INSURING
THAT I GET THE DATA.
THE DOCUMENTS THE F. T. E.'S
REQUIRED TO RUN A MOTOR VOTER
PROGRAM AND IN THE MANNER WHICH
WERE DELIVERING IT RIGHT NOW.
AT DMV WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT
OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE
PROCESSES BECAUSE WHEN I COME
BEFORE YOU IF THERE'S A A
RESOURCE REQUEST WE HAVE TO
PRESENT TO YOU.
MAYBE NEXT YEAR WE'LL SEE BUT I
WANT TO COME IN WITH FULL
JUSTIFICATION OF WHAT THE
PROCESS REQUIREMENTS ARE FOR DMV.
TO HANDLE MOTOR VOTER AND I
DON'T KNOW THAT'S ALWAYS BEEN
DONE AT DMV I'M NOT SENSING THAT
HERE IS THAT LEVEL OF
ASSESSMENT. TO REALLY TAKE A
LOOK AT IF WE'RE GOING TO DO
THAT WHAT DOES THAT REQUIRE.
SOMETIMES IT'S JUST A
PROGRAMMING CHANGE BUT OUR
PROGRAMMING PROGRAMMING CHANGE
OF DMV ON ITS IT SYSTEM IS
ANYTHING BUT EASY -- AND AGAIN I
THINK WE NEED TO GO BACK AND RE
EXAMINE.
AND WHAT I WOULD ASK IS YOUR
CONSIDERATION IN ANYTHING YOU
TASK AS WITH FURTHER.
IT REALLY IS AN EMERGENCY GIVE
US THE OPPORTUNITY TO TRANSFORM
THE ORGANIZATION BEFORE YOU ASK
US TO DO MORE PROGRAM CHANGES TO
A SYSTEM THAT'S JUST.
NOT EQUIPPED TO DO IT.
BUT I ASKED THAT BECAUSE THERE
ARE SEVERAL BILLS IN MY
COMMITTEE THAT AIM.
OF CONTEMPLATING HOLDING BECAUSE
THEY ARE IMPACTFUL ON THE DMV
AND TRYING TO ALLOW THE STRIKE
FORCE TO BE PROACTIVE AND FIND
OUT WHAT'S GOING ON BEFORE WE
PASSED MORE BILLS.
AND CREATE MORE OWNERS -- TEST
FOR YOU.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU SOME OF
THESE TASKS THAT YOU'VE TAKEN ON
MAY HAVE.
IN A BURDEN IN SOME WAYS A FORM
BUT LIKE A. B. NINETY THREE THE
VETERANS DESIGNATION.
RIGHT A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
INTO VETERANS BENEFITS -- WITH
THE SP ONE IN THE PROGRAM
CHANGES THAT YOU HAD TO DO WITH
THE REGISTRATION.
YOU KNOW THE TOTAL PROCESSES OF
FIVE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
OUT AND TRANSPORTATION SO.
THERE IS A MULTIPLIER SOMETIMES
YOU BEAR THE BRUNT.
BUT SOMETIMES THERE'S OTHERS THE
BENEFIT.
AND I NEED EVERYBODY TO RICK
RECOGNIZE THAT GOING FOR IT'S A
BIRD THAT BUSINESS PERSPECTIVE
SOMETIMES YOU.
LOSE A LITTLE HERE BEGIN A LOT
HERE THANK YOU. ONE QUICK
QUESTION -- YOU MENTIONED THE
PILOTING THE CARMICHAEL
REGARDING.
THE TRACKING THE WAY TIME SO SO
I GUESS THE QUESTION IS IS.
WE WERE HERE IN AUGUST -- WE
TALKED ABOUT THIS ISSUE IN
AUGUST IT IS NOW. SEVEN MONTHS
LATER AND IN SEVEN MONTHS THE
RESPONSE HAS BEEN THE PILOT THIS
IN ONE OFFICE.
SO WHAT'S GOING TO TAKE TO DO
THIS AND EVERY SINGLE OFFICE.
AND HOW LONG WILL IT TAKE.
THANK YOU SO PART OF THE NEED
FOR THAT WITH PART OF THE JAIL
BC ASK AS EARLY FOR FOR FUNDING.
IN SEOUL AND REGARDS TO WHAT
CALLING WAS MENTIONED IN REGARDS
THE REPEATERS IS A LOT OF THE
OFFICES DON'T HAVE THE THE WIFI
JUST LIKE AT YOUR HOME.
AS LIKE TO EXTEND THE OUTSIDE
THE OFFICES IN ORDER TO TO DO
THAT.
AND WE EITHER WE NEED TO
PURCHASE THE REPEATERS HOW WHICH
TO THE WALL FROM THAT THE
CONTRACT IN PERSPECTIVE.
AM AND THEN WE'VE GOT TO WORK
WITH THE OFFICES IF THEY ARE
LEAST OFFICES WE'VE GOT TO WORK
WITH THE LESSORS.
AND SO AT THIS POINT IT'S
WORKING VERY SUCCESSFUL AT THE
RELEASED THE CARMICHAEL WE PLAN
TO THERE'S ABOUT NINETY OFFICES
THAT WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
INSTALL THOSE REPEATERS THAT --
AND THEN WILL CONTINUE TO ROLL
IT OUT FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE THE
THE TIME LINE I'LL HAVE -- TO TO
FORGET TO CALLING AS ARE LIKE
THAT BUT THAT'S WHEN THE REASON
THAT THEY RELATE TO WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT IT BEFORE IT WAS A CONCEPT
AND THEN IT BECAME PART OF THE
JAIL BC ASK.
AND THEN WE DID THE THE
CONTRACTING PROCESS FOR THE
REPEATERS THEM ABOUT INSTALL
THEM AND IN THE PLAN TO MOVE
FORWARD.
BUDGET BUT ALSO THE CHARACTER SO
IN SEVEN MONTHS.
THE DEPARTMENT COULD ONLY
INSTALL ONE YOU CALL THAT A
REPEATER.
IT IS A REPAIR HELPS TO AMPLIFY
THE SIGNAL SENATE CAN GO OUTSIDE
OF THE BUILDING RIGHT THREE FIVE
MUCH OF IT ONLY STOLE.
ONE YES THAT'S WHAT WE'VE DONE
THUS FAR AND WORKING VERY VALUE
IN YOUR CURRENT INFRASTRUCTURE
IS ROBBIE INDICATED WE HAVE A
PLAN BE FOCUSED ON THOSE THAT
HAVE.
THE HIGHEST PEAK HE WAIT TIMES.
YOU KNOW AS WE ALL WHEN THE
NOMINEE.
YES A QUESTION SO WHAT WHY IS
THAT YOU COULD ONLY INSTALL ONE
IN SEVEN MONTHS.
AT AT THIS PACE THEN YOU KNOW TO
BE LIKE THIRTY YEARS BEFORE YOU
CAN INSTALL.
INSTALL THE REST EVERY
DEPARTMENT HAVE THE REST OF
THESE. ONE OF THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF OR WAS IT FOR OR WAS IT
JUST NOT A PRIORITY BECAUSE IT
WAS A PRIORITY FOR US NO IT WITH
THE PARTY BUT IT ONE OF THINGS
IS THE POWER TO MAKE SURE IT
WORKS WITH I WANT TO GO AHEAD
AND AND DO.
SOME INSTALLED ON ALL THE
OFFICES AND FIND OUT THAT IT'S
NOT OKAY FOR DR YOU KNOW WORKS
HOW IS IT TO TO DO THE REST
OFFICE.
AND SO DO WE HAVE THE SCHEDULE.
YEAH WE'RE STILL WORKING ON THE
FINAL SCHEDULE.
OKAY SO THEN WHEN WHEN.
YOU COME BACK FOR APPROPRIATION
WE'RE GONNA THE SAME ANSWER.
THAT WASN'T WHAT WE NEED TO
SCHEDULE I KNOW A LOT OF IN
REGARDS TO OUR LEAST OFFICES IT
TAKES ANYWHERE FROM ONE TO THREE
MONTHS OF THEIR LIVES TO WORKING
WITH THE LESSOR.
BECAUSE THEY'VE GOT A CONTRACTED
OUT IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT THE
STATE DOES IN THE STATE OWNED
FACILITY THAT SOMETHING THAT WE
CAN DO OURSELVES THAT'S ABOUT
THE BEST A COLUMN AYE AYE I
APOLOGIZE TO MR BROKE THAT YOU
KNOW -- IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE
SAME LEVEL OF URGENCY TO THE
THINGS THAT ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND AGAIN.
IT THIS IS NOT A PARTISAN SHE'S
COMPLETELY BIPARTISAN BECAUSE
WE'RE GETTING HAMMERED BY ALL
OUR CONSTITUENTS OUR PHONES ARE
LIGHTEN UP AT HOME.
IF THIS IS NOT IMPORTANT
[inaudible] TO YOU.
AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE A VERY
DIFFICULT TIME BETWEEN NOW.
IN THE MIDDLE JIM.
SO MISTER BROWN.
THE APOLOGIZE ALMOST JAPANESE
ARE VERY VALUABLE QUESTIONS.
I JUST WANNA MAKE COMMENT OFF
THE LINE OF QUESTIONING FROM OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO.
I WOULD SUGGEST THAT YOU'RE A
REAL ID PROBLEM IS GOING TO BE
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE WHEN PEOPLE
CAN'T GET ON PLANES THEY REALIZE
THE TO COME TO YOU IN YOUR
OFFICE IS GOING TO BE FLOODED.
I WANT TO DELVE DOWN INTO THE
SELF SERVICE KIOSK -- PROGRAM.
IN THE LAST BUDGET WE ALLOCATED
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS FOR YOU
CAN YOU -- GIVE US AN OVERVIEW
OF WHAT'S BEEN GOING ON HOW MANY
WERE BOUGHT WHAT SITE SELECTION
PROCESSES.
SO WHAT THE F. AS THE PROGRAM --
WE DON'T PAY FOR THE ACTUAL AT
THIS PLEASE WELL I'M AT THE PER
TRANSACTION COST.
AND SO WE WORK WITH THE VENDOR
AS IT RELATES TO PUSHING THEM
OUT INTO IN THE RETAIL SO NOW WE
HAVE THE HUNDRED AND FIFTY TWO
PRIOR TO THAT WE WERE I'M RIGHT
AROUND A HUNDRED SO WE EXPANDED
OUT THE NUMBER OF ETHNICITIES.
SO WE WORK WITH THE VENDOR AND
ACTUALLY FOR THE EXTERNAL ONES
THE BIG PUSH FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
IS -- TO INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
EXTERNAL AT FIFTY THAT WE HAVE
SO THAT WE WE DON'T HAVE
INDIVIDUALS ACTUALLY GOING INTO
THE OFFICE PICKING UP A PARKING
SPOT WALKING IN THE LOBBY.
AND SO.
THE BIG PUSH AND AND THE
DIRECTION HAS BEEN AS IS TRY TO
GET AS MANY EXTERNAL AT FIFTIES
AS POSSIBLE OUT THERE -- AND SO
WE HAVE AN INCREASE THAT THAT
BAND WITH -- IN THE VENDOR
CHARGES -- THAT'S THREE NINETY
FIVE PER TRANSACTION.
AND SO WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE VENDOR THE GOAL IS IN IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE THE
STRIKE TEAM IS THEY WANT TO
ACTUALLY EXPAND THE THE NUMBER
OF AT THIS SEASON AND ACTUALLY
DO ANOTHER -- TWO HUNDRED THE
WITH THE GOAL OF DOING ANOTHER
HUNDRED THIS SUMMER AND ANOTHER
HUNDRED BY THE END OF THE FISCAL
OR THE CALENDAR YEAR.
OKAY SO RIGHT NOW YOU HAVE A
HUNDRED FIFTY TWO THAT'S
BASICALLY THREE PER COUNTY.
IF YOU SPENT ABOUT AN HOUR THEY
ALLOCATED LIKE THAT OR HOW THEY
ALLOCATE OUR HUNDRED I'M GO TO
LA FIFTY I'M GO TO SAN FRANCISCO.
I DON'T KNOW THE ALLOCATE
SOMETIME AND I KNOW IT'S ON OUR
WEBSITE WE ACTUALLY HAVE AN AT
THIS TI -- LOCATOR I DON'T KNOW
THE LOCATION OFF THE TOP OF MY
HEAD OKAY.
WE'VE BEEN CONTACTED BY THE
SHIPPING AND FREIGHT INDUSTRY
THAT THE SAY THERE'S A
TREMENDOUS BACKLOG AND CARRIER
PERMIT APPLICATIONS.
CAN YOU DISCUSS THAT.
SO -- I KNOW THERE WAS AN ISSUE
THAT CAME UP AND I I SPOKE WITH --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF PATTERSON
ABOUT THAT AS WELL THERE WAS --
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE
WAS A PROGRAM -- GLITCH FOR LACK
OF A BETTER TERM IN THAT SYSTEM
AGAIN THAT'S KIND OF A A PRODUCT
LINE SYSTEM -- IT WAS ON BOTH
THE PROGRAM SIDE AS WELL AS THE
I. T. SIDE THE SAID NOTHING TO
DO WITH CDG IS MY UNDERSTANDING.
THAT ISSUE WAS ADDRESSED AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS WE DON'T HAVE
ANY OUTSTANDING PERMITS THAT ARE
REQUIRED TO BE PROCESS RIGHT NOW.
NOW THAT BEING SAID -- WE
CERTAINLY HAVE REACHED OUT TO
THE ASSOCIATIONS THAT WE
COMMUNICATE WITH ON A REGULAR
BASIS TO IDENTIFY ANY
OUTSTANDING ISSUES.
THAT THEY PLEASE STILL EXIST AND
I KNOW ONE OF THE ASSOCIATIONS
THAT EXPRESSED SOME CONCERNS AND
SPOKE TO SOMEONE MEMBER
PATTERSON ABOUT THAT AS WELL IS
THE A TOW TRUCK ASSOCIATION SO
I'VE ACTUALLY REACHED OUT TO
THEM AND WE WILL HAVE A MEET AND
GREET AND FIND OUT IF.
THERE'S ANY OUTSTANDING ISSUES
THAT WE NEED TO RESOLVE FOR THEM
OKAY SO IF IF SOMEONE CAN'T GET
IN BECAUSE OF AN APPOINTMENT.
LACK OF AN APPOINTMENT YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO PENALIZE THEM.
I HAVE NOT EXPIRED LICENSE -- SO
SO FROM THE STANDPOINT.
THERE ARE ISSUES THAT WE DEAL
WITH AND WE TRY TO GIVE OUR
CUSTOMERS THE NOTHING NOTICE TO
HANDLE THEIR RENEWALS IN AN
APPROPRIATE AND TIMELY WAY.
AND THEN THERE ARE THOSE THAT
RELIES ON THE ON THE DAY THAT
IT'S EXPIRING THAT THEY NEED TO
GET INTO AN OFFICE WHICH IS WHY
WE ACTUALLY MAINTAIN.
THE NOT APPOINTMENT LINES IN OUR
DMV OFFICES IN OUR OTHER
BUSINESS CENTERS -- SO TO THE
EXTENT WE TRY TO GO HEAD PROCESS
THOSE AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN WHEN
THEY COME IN WHEN THEY SUDDENLY
REALIZE THEY HAVE AN EXPIRING --
LICENSE OR REGISTRATION WE TRY
TO HANDLE THAT BUT I DO WANNA --
VISIT WITH THE THE TOW TRUCK
ASSOCIATION OTHERS TO FIND OUT
WHAT ARE THE REAL CHALLENGES
THAT THEY'RE FACING HOW CAN WE
ACTUALLY STREAMLINED PROCESSES
FOR THESE FOLKS ARE THERE SOME
FIXES.
WITHIN OUR OWN PROCESSES ARE YOU
EVEN PERHAPS OR REGULATION --
SOMETIMES OUR OUR REGULATIONS
ARE VERY DATED IN THE PROBABLY
COULD STAND TO BE MODERNIZE AND
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT THOSE AS
WELL OKAY.
OF FINAL QUESTION IS YOU KNOW SO
YOU'RE EXTENDING SATURDAY HOURS
AN EVENING HOURS.
SO IN MY HOME COUNTY OF ORANGE.
YOU HAVE EXTENDED HOURS IN SANTA
ANA AND YOU HAVE SATURDAY
SERVICES IN COSTA MESA.
BUT WE'RE A COUNTY OF THREE
POINT THREE MILLION PEOPLE IS
THERE ANYWAY TO ROTATE THE
SATURDAYS SO SAY LAGUNA HILLS
ONE SATURDAY A MONTH WILL BE
OPEN. FOR IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
RIGID WHERE MY CONSTITUENTS HAVE
TO GO TO SANTA ANA COSTA MESA
FOR THESE EXTENDED HOURS.
I WILL ALLOW COOLEY TO ADDRESS
OUR FIELD OFFICE PLANTS.
WE HAVE THOUGHT ABOUT JIMMY VAN.
EXPLORING THE IDEA OF KIND OF
HAVING THESE BUT HE SAID NOT
HAVING US REALLY SET SATURDAY'S
BUT KIND OF POP UP LOCATIONS
OPENNESS THAT RT.
IN A PARTICULAR ROTATING AREA TO
ALLOW.
THOSE FOLKS THAT MAY NOT HAVE A
SATURDAY OFFICE CLOSE TO THEM.
AND SO I THINK THAT'S DEFINITELY
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE I'M
STRONGLY CONSIDERING BUT I ALSO
WANT TO POINT OUT AS WELL IS NOT
WE DO HAVE EXTENDED HOURS FROM
SEVEN TO FIVE MANY IN YOUR
REGION.
I'M ALSO THIS SUMMER BECAUSE WE
KNOW THERE'S GOING TO BE AN
INCREASE IN FOLKS ARE COMING IN.
YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT PEOPLE OUT OF
SCHOOL VACATION THEY WANT TO
COME INTO THE ANTI THAT WE ARE
ALSO EXTEND THE ADDITIONAL HOURS
AND FIFTY TWO OF OUR OFFICES FOR
THE SUMMER FOR JULY AUGUST AND
SEPTEMBER.
SO THAT SHOULD PROVIDE YOU SOME
RELIEF AS WELL NO THANK YOU CAN
TRAIN YOUR REGION WE'VE GOTTEN
SEVERAL.
LIKE IN HERE YEAH YOU'VE GOT
WESTMINSTER DANNY I'M STANTON
THAT THOSE THOSE ARE STILL COSTA
MESA AREAS LIVE LAGUNA HILLS IN
SACRAMENTO.
I'VE GOTTEN A GOOD HEALTH YEAH.
THERE THERE ARE LESS THAN WE
RECOGNIZE THE NEED OF A PUBLIC
AND WE ACTUALLY TOUCH THE PUBLIC
WOULD YOU LIKE A CITY OF A MATE
DO YOU PREFER EARLY.
AND US BUT WE'D RATHER DO IT ON
THE WAY AND NOT STOP BY ON THE
WAY HOME FROM WORK AS WELL
THAT'S ALSO A SAFETY AND
SECURITY ISSUES.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU'RE
NOT GONNA GIVE US CHEN.
THANK MISCREANT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
SO I UNDERSTAND FROM YOUR
PREVIOUS TESTIMONY THAT IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU BELIEVE THAT YOU
ARE ON TRACK TO MEET THE MAY
TWENTY FOURTH EXTENDED THAT LINE%
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT GAVE US.
FOR REAL ID COMPLIANCE IS THAT
ACCURATE THAT'S ACCURATE OKAY MY
QUESTION IS.
WHAT IS THE CONTINGENCY PLAN IF
YOU DO NOT MEET?
AND WHAT IS THE LEGAL WHAT IS
THE LEGAL OR REAL WORLD THE FACT
OF NOT MEETING THAT DEADLINE
WHAT HAPPENS.
I THINK WE'D HAVE TO BE IN
CONVERSATION WITH HOMELAND
SECURITY -- TO EXPLAIN WHY WE
DIDN'T ROLL OUT ON APRIL TWENTY
NINTH.
BECAUSE THE GOAL IS TO ROLL OUT
IN APRIL TWENTY NINTH IN THE
WORLD AS I SAID BEFORE WERE
ALREADY ASKING FOR SECOND
RESIDENCY DOCUMENTS -- WERE
PREPARE FROM A PROGRAMMING
STANDPOINT THIS IS MORE OF A
PROGRAMMING ASPECT WE'RE PREPARE
FROM A PROGRAMMING STANDPOINT
FOR OUR COUNTER OFFICES TO
BASICALLY ACCEPT.
AND RECORD TO RESIDENCY
DOCUMENTS THAT'S READY TO ROLL --
THEY'VE COMPLETED THEIR TESTING
AND ARE YOU AWARE COLLEEN OF ANY
ISSUES AT THIS POINT I'M NOT
AWAE OF ANYTHING.
YEAH WE'RE READY TO GO HEAD
IMPLEMENTED -- OFFICIALLY APRIL
TWENTY NINTH AND SO I I I'M NOT
AWARE OF ANYTHING THAT WILL KEEP
US FROM COMPLYING.
OKAY AND I DON'T WANT TO SPEND
TOO MUCH TIME ON ON CRATER
ANALYSIS OR HISTORY OF THIS BUT
HOW DID HOW DID THIS HAPPEN.
ANYWAY.
THE REAL ID ACT PASSED IN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE AND FOR THIRTEEN
YEARS THINGS KIND OF BOB ALONG I
GUESS AND THEN ALL THE SUDDEN.
OF WHERE THE BIGGEST STATE IN
THE TECHNOLOGICAL POWERHOUSE OF
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY AND WE ARE
ARE WE ARE ABLE TO FIGURE OUT --
WHAT IT IS WE HAVE TO DO TO
COMPLY WITH THE FEDERAL LAW HOW
DO HOW DOES THAT HAPPEN -- I
REALIZE THIS ISN'T YOUR YOUR
YOUR NEW.
BUT AND BUT PLEASE JUST I MEAN
JUST TELL US.
I'D BE HAPPY TO SHARE A TIME I
ECONOMIC HIGHLIGHTS WHAT I CALL
MILESTONES AND EXCHANGES THAT
WE'VE HAD WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY.
BUT YOU THROUGH THE WHOLE
PROCESS THERE'S BEEN KIND OF A
SEQUENCE OF CONVERSATIONS AND
EVEN FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY WHEN IT CAME
THROUGH IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIVE IT WAS HOW ARE
THEY GOING TO IMPLEMENT THAT AND
HAVE OVERSIGHT WITH ALL THE
STATE'S WHAT I FIND FASCINATING
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE HISTORY OF
IT WE'VE HAD. ONE STATE THAT
ACTUALLY FILE -- FILE THEIR OWN
LEGISLATION TO NOT ACTUALLY
COMPLY -- WE'VE HAD OTHER STATES
THAT FRANKLY HAVE ONLY JUST
STARTED TO ROLL OUT REAL ID SO
YOU KNOW ARE ALL OUT TWENTY
SEVENTEEN IN SOME CASES IS WAY
AHEAD OF THE CURVE OF MANY
STATES WHO -- ARE STILL ALL
ADDRESSING THIS -- BUT PART OF
IT WAS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY ALSO BEING SURE OF WHAT
IMPLEMENTATION LOOKLIKE WORKING
THROUGH THE NUANCES OF WHAT
IMPLEMENTATION IS WHAT WOULD BE
THE STANDARD OF ACCEPTANCE AND
THEN INDIVIDUALLY EVERY STATE
FIGURE OUT HOW.
TO HOW TO MANAGE IT HINDSIGHT'S
ALWAYS TWENTY TWENTY I CAN LOOK
BACK AND SAY YEAH WE COULD HAVE
PROBABLY DONE A BETTER JOB OF
PLANNING YES WE COULD HAVE DONE
A BETTER JOB AROUND GOVERNANCE --
BUT I WOULD ALSO TELL YOU IT IT
GOES BACK TO AGAIN WHAT I SHARED
WITH YOU EARLIER WHEN YOU HAVE A
HUNDRED TWENTY BILLS COMING OUT
YOU WITH OTHER PROGRAMMING AND
YOU'VE GOT TO DO PROGRAMMING A
REAL ID.
BUT THEN YOU GET BILLS THAT HAVE
SENSITIVITY AROUND TIMELINES FOR
IMPLEMENTATION WE ARE HAVING TO
RE PRIORITIZE.
AND SO I MOVING STAFF AROUND
FROM OUR PROGRAMMING STANDPOINT
TO ADDRESS THE THINGS OF A
COMING IN LEGISLATIVELY.
AND THEN REMEMBER ON THE HEELS
OF ALL THE REAL IDEA ACTIVITY
WAS IMPLEMENTING MOTOR VOTER --
AND SO WE HAD A LOT ON OUR PLATE
IN AND OUT IT'S NOT PREFER
PERFECT I CAN'T DEFEND IT YES IT
WAS A WELL PLANNED.
BUT WE SIT HERE TODAY BUT I
THINK WE REALLY HAVE A SOLID
PLAN GOING FORWARD AND THEN OUR
HOPE IS THAT YOU RECOGNIZE THAT
WE REALLY WANT TO BE COMPLIANT --
I'M NOT IN FAVOR OF THROWING
PEOPLE AT SOLUTIONS BUT PEOPLE
AT THE SOLUTIONS TO GET US
THROUGH.
TWENTY TWENTY IS REALLY
IMPORTANT UNTIL WE IT -- REALLY
CREE ALTER OF METHODS IN GREAT
THE DMV OF THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY.
AND I THINK THE SUMMER IT AS YOU
POINTED THAT OUT THAT'S GOING TO
TAKE TIME.
THAT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN IN ONE
OR TWO YEARS -- BUT WE DO HAVE
TO MEET REAL ID AND I AGREE WITH --
THAT WHICH WAS RACES TWENTY
TWENTY ONE COULD ALSO BE A BIG
YEAR FOR US WHEN PEOPLE REALIZE
THEY WANT A REAL ID.
SO THE THE HEADLINE TODAY'S
THREE MILLION CALIFORNIANS MIGHT
HAVE TO GO BACK TO THE DMV AFTER
ID FAILURE.
I THINK YOU SAID THE REAL
NUMBERS PROBABLY THREE POINT
FOUR MILLION ARE THESE REAL
IDEAS THAT WERE ISSUE THERE AND
SUBSEQUENTLY DEEMED NON
COMPLIANT.
WHAT WHAT COMPRISES AT THREE
POINT FOUR MILLION?
SO THE ROOM THREE PORT THREE
POINT FOUR MILLION WHO RECEIVE
THEIR REAL ID ARE COMPLIANT AT
THIS POINT IN TIME.
IF THEY DON'T COME IN DURING THE
RENEWAL PERIOD AND WILL HAVE TO
WORK OUT WE'RE STILL IN
CONVERSATIONS OF WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE -- IF OF THAT THREE POINT
FOUR MILLION THEY DO NOT PROVIDE
US A SECOND RESIDENCY DOCUMENT
THE POINT IN TIME THAT THEY ARE
UP FOR RENEWAL.
WE'LL HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE SO WHAT STEPS
ARE YOU ARE YOU GUYS GOING TO
TAKE OR ARE TAKING. TO NOTIFY
OUR CONSTITUENTS THAT NEED TO
PROVIDE A SECOND RESIDENCY
DOCUMENT THAT THAT'S SOMETHING
THEY'RE GOING TO NEED TO DO SO
WE HAVE -- MAILERS GOING OUT --
TO ALL THOSE FOLKS THAT HAVE
ACTUALLY -- PART OF THE THREE
POINT FOUR MILLION WE HAVE A
LETTER.
OUR HOPE IS THAT THE LETTER
ITSELF WILL ACTUALLY SERVE AS A
FORM SECOND RESIDENCY DOCUMENT.
THEY CAN COMPLETE THAT LETTER IN
THE FORM THAT'S WITH THAT AND
THEY CAN ACTUALLY MAIL IT BACK
TO US THEY CAN ACTUALLY DO IT IN
A SEND UP PUT IN A DROP BOX AT A
DMV OFFICE.
I THINK THE OTHER PROCESS WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS THE INTERNET -- IS
HAVING THE CAPABILITY TO PROCESS
ON THE INTERNET WILL THEY BE
ABLE TO SCAN IT INTO A PDF AND
UP UPLOAD IT TO SOMETHING ONLINE
WE'VE ACTUALLY TALKED ABOUT
DOING THAT AS WELL AND THAT'S
AND THAT'S CERTAINLY.
A PROCESS I THINK FOR US -- WHEN
WE THOUGHT ABOUT THE SCANNING OF
IT?
I'M IS THAT WOULD REQUIRE
SOMEBODY AT THE DMV OFFICE AND
TO STAFF APPROPRIATELY TO GO
AHEAD AND HANDLE THE SCANNING
COMING AND AND THEN THE MAKING
SURE IT WAS THE RIGHT DOCUMENT
THAT WAS BEING SCANNED SO.
I THINK AT THIS POINT -- WE WERE
LOOKING AT WORK LOW DEMAND
ASSOCIATE WITH ALSO ADDRESSING
THE SECOND RUNS A DOCUMENT WE
FELT THAT THE THE THREE
APPROACHES WE GAVE A WOULD ALLOW
US TO MANAGE THAT FROM WORKLOAD
FOR SURE THE ACCURACY OF IT AND
BILL SAYS FIRE SECOND RESIDENCY
DOCUMENT REQUIREMENTS.
SO IT SOUNDS LIKE THAT YOU'RE
GONNA GIVE PEOPLE A VARIETY
OPTIONS TO FULFILL THAT
REQUIREMENT.
THAT DO NOT REQUIRE THEM
ACTUALLY PHYSICALLY GOING TO THE
DMV AROUND POINT IS THAT CORRECT
CORRECT AND SO THE ONES THAT
WOULD BE LEFT WOULD BE THE FOLKS
THAT DON'T OPEN THEIR MAIL OR
THEY DON'T GET THEIR MAIL OR
THEY GET.
REALLY BUSY THAT MONTH -- OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT RIGHT RIGHT
AND AND WE ALSO HAVE TALK ABOUT --
AND PUTTING INTO PLACE FOLLOW
UPS BECAUSE WE WE REALLY DON'T
WANT TO HAVE PEOPLE WHO IF HEY
WANTED TO BE COMPLIANT WE DON'T
WANT THEM TO NOT BE COMPLIANT
WELL AND I DON'T WANT TO HAVE
THE NONE OF US WANT TO HAVE
CONSTITUENTS THAT.
HAVE A FLIGHT TO GO SEE THEIR
ILL FAMILY MEMBER AROUND THE
HOLIDAYS WHEN THIS THING FINALLY
TAKES A FACT AND THEY TRY TO GET
ON AN AIRPLANE THEY'RE TOLD THEY
HAVE NOT COMPLAINED ID RIGHT.
I MEAN NONE OF US TO DEAL WITH
THAT.
RIGHT IRATE CONSTITUENT.
AND THAT'S THAT'S NOT AN
ACCEPTABLE LEVEL OF PERFORMANCE
FOR A GOVERNMENT AGENCY IF
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE AT DEGREES SO
I I JUST ENCOURAGE YOU PLEASE
YOU KNOW.
I GET I GET THE YOU'VE GOT A
BUNCH OF MANDATES AND YOU'VE GOT
A LOT OF BALLS IN THE AIR AS IT
WERE AND I ICE WHAT I'M HEARING
FROM YOU AND LISTEN TO THIS IS
THAT YOU'VE GOT.
AND IT INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUE THAT
SERVE PERMEATING A LOT OF THESE
ISSUES OLD.
YEAH LET'S FIX THAT I MEAN LET'S
FIX IT AND NOT THROW MONEY AT
MORE STAFF WE CAN SOLVE THE
PROBLEM WITH.
WITH TECHNOLOGY HEY WE IT'S TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN I MEAN I YOU
KNOW I I RUN MY BUSINESS WITH A
VIRTUALLY PAPERLESS IF IF
NECESSARY MINUTE YOU CAN UPLOAD
THINGS AND SCANNED THINGS IN
FACT THINGS BUT THERE'S JUST SO
MANY DIFFERENT WAYS.
OF THE MALE GENERALLY WORKS I
MEAN THERE'S SO MANY DIFFERENT
WAYS THAT.
THE THAT IT.
AND A GOVERNMENT AGENCY CAN USE
TECHNOLOGY TO NOT REQUIRE PEOPLE
THEY HAVE TO BURN THEIR TIME TO
GO AND PHYSICALLY STAND
SOMEWHERE IN A AND IN A LONG
LINE WE DON'T KNOW HOW LONG IT'S
REALLY.
IT'S REALLY GONNA BE.
SO.
YOU KNOW AS WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD AND THE FIVE YEAR PLAN
OR WHATEVER WHATEVER IT IS I
JUST.
ENCOURAGE YOU ASK YOU
[inaudible]
BIG YOU [inaudible]
PLEASE.
LOOK AT TECHNOLOGICAL SOLUTIONS
FIRST BECAUSE I THINK IN THE
LONG RUN THAT'S THE KIND OF
INVESTMENT AND THAT'S GOING
MODERNIZE.
THIS AGENCY I MEAN.
I THINK YOU'RE HEARING FROM
EVERYBODY HERE I MEAN PEOPLE ARE
PASSED ABOUT THIS.
AND IF YOU WERE SPENDING A LOT
OF TIME WASTED THEY'RE GOING
AFTER I GOT CONSTITUENTS ON HERE
ABOUT ALL THE TIME.
ALL THE TIME.
AND THE NUMBER.
HI.
WE GOT TO FIX THESE ISSUES AND
AYE AYE AYE.
I THINK THE STRIKE FORCE OF GIVE
YOU SOME OPTIONS.
I LIKE WHAT I'M HEARING IN TERMS
OF YOUR ANSWER.
PLEASE IF IF WE CAN CUT THAT
NUMBER OF THREE POINT FOUR
MILLION PEOPLE THAT MIGHT HAVE
TO COME BACK IN. TO GET IT AN ID
THAT THEY THOUGHT WAS VALID
BECAUSE OF A SCREW UP BY
SOMEBODY ELSE THE WASN'T THEIR
FAULT.
DOWN TO THE SMALLEST POSSIBLE
NUMBER THAT WOULD BE EXCELLENT I
AGREE WITH YOU BECAUSE THAT'S
JUST REALLY NOT FAIR TO PEOPLE
JUST ISN'T SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS PATTERSON
[inaudible]
UP.
I I DID I ACCURATELY UNDERSTAND
THEY THEY AUDIT.
WITH RESPECT. TO RELY DE SAID
THAT [inaudible]
THE DEPARTMENT REALLY DIDN'T
MAKE IT OUT OF A VERY IMPORTANT --
PRIORITY UNTIL.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WAS THAT THAT
WAS IN THE AUDIT.
I CAN'T SPEAK TO WHAT WAS
HAPPENING IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN I
ATE A I WOULD HAVE TO TURN MY
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE MORE
INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE BY THAT
LET'S JUST SAY I KNOW THAT THE
CONCLUSION OF THE AUDIT.
WAS PRECISELY THAT.
THAT WAS THAT THAT WASN'T AN AN
ISSUE UNTIL TWENTY SEVEN ANOTHER
AND UNLESS YOU.
I THINK THAT THE AUDIT.
WHAT WOMAN THIS WASN'T ACCURATE?
THE AUDITOR THE FOLKS WHO DID
THEY ARE COMING UP NEXT IF YOU
WANT TO ASK A QUESTION TO THEM
YEAH I THINK I WOULD JUST ADD WE
LAUNCHED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN SO
I HAD TO BE ENOUGH OF A PRIORITY
FOR US TO LAUNCH IN.
201-722-01820 EIGHTEEN SO.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN QUICKLY ON THE
THAT THE MOTOR CARRIER PERMIT --
WE'VE BEEN RECEIVING A LOT OF AN
INPUT IN MY OFFICE FROM THIS --
WE HAVE HAD SOME INFORMATION
FROM.
YOUR LIAISON LET LEGISLATIVE
LIAISON FOLKS WITH RESPECT. TO
WHERE IT IS AND THAT THAT
COMMUNICATION HAS BEEN.
THAT THE BACKLOG IS OVER
[inaudible]
BUT THAT THAT DOES THAT MEAN
THAT THE THE TIME PROBLEMS.
ARE STILL THERE IT'S ONE THING
TO CLEAR A BACKLOG IT'S ANOTHER
TO PROCESS.
THE CURRENT INPUT.
IN A TIMELY FASHION WE'RE
GETTING.
A LOT OF TRUCK OPERATIONS SOME
SMALL SOME VERY VERY LARGE.
GOT A GARBAGE TRUCK OPERATORS --
I MENTIONED THE THE TOW TRUCKS --
IT IS.
HAVE WE SEEN THE LAST OF THIS.
PROBLEM HERE BECAUSE IT JUST
HERE IS ANOTHER.
ONE AND THEN ANOTHER ONE AND
THEN ANOTHER.
ONE AND SO WE HEAR THAT THE
BACKLOG IS GONE.
BUT WHEN WE ASK FOR
CLARIFICATION WE REALLY DON'T
GET A CLEAR ANSWER WELL IF THE
BACKLOGS GONE IS THE TIME DELAY
GONE AS WELL I WAS NUMBER.
ONE NUMBER TWO WE SORT OF GOT AN
ANSWER WHETHER WAS ONLY FIVE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND SOME
ODD.
WELL.
THAT THAT SOUNDS LIKE WELL
THAT'S JUST A SMALL LITTLE
AMOUNT.
BUT THOSE PERMIT HOLDERS THEY
MAY HAVE A HUNDRED TRUCKS.
THEY MAKE AND IN THE CASE THAT I
MENTIONED ON THAT THE TOW TRUCK --
THAT THAT COULD HAVE SEVEN OR
EIGHT HUNDRED TRUCKS STATEWIDE
SO IT FEELS LIKE BY THE INCOMING
WE'RE GETTING THAT THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT AND SERIOUS.
SLOWDOWN THAT IS AFFECTING A
SUBSTANTIAL PART OF THE ECONOMY
OF CALIFORNIA WITH RESPECT TO
LOGISTICS AND THE TRANSPORTATION
OF GOODS SO HELP ME.
UNDERSTAND ARE WE REALLY OVER
THIS PROBLEM.
I THINK TO THE EXTENT WE ADDRESS
THE ISSUE THAT CREATED THE
BACKLOG YOU TALKED ABOUT I
BELIEVE THAT'S BEEN ADDRESSED.
AS A RELATES TO THE BUSINESS
PROCESSES SO SAY WITH PROCESSING
THESE -- VEHICLE REGISTRATIONS
ARE LICENSES -- I NEED TO VISIT
WITH NOT ONLY MY TEAM WHO
ACTUALLY MANAGES THAT.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO HEAR FROM OUR
CUSTOMER -- I HAVE SINCE I'VE
BEEN -- IN MY POSITION HAVE MET
WITH A NUMBER OF ASSOCIATIONS --
WHETHER IT'S A NEW CAR DEALERS
ASSOCIATION OF THE INDEPENDENT
CAR DEALERS ASSOCIATION AND
OTHERS. TO LOOK AT THE PROCESSES
IN WHICH WE GO AHEAD AND AND
INTERACT AND DO BUSINESS WITH
THEM.
AND THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO ACTUALLY.
LOOK AT OUR BUSINESS PROCESSES
WITH THEM HAND IN HAND -- IF
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN STREAMLINE
SOME OF THOSE PROCESSES THE
OTHER THING THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT A SOME OF OUR REGULATIONS WHO
WHICH ARE VERY OLD IN SOME CASES.
IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT
MODERNIZING OUR REGULATIONS AND
IN SOME CASES.
THERE'S A GREAT DEAL OPPORTUNITY
TO MODERNIZE OUR REGULATIONS AND
SOME OF OUR REQUIREMENTS SO TO
ME THAT'S A PARTNERSHIP
DISCUSSION WE NEED TO HAVE WITH
THEM HOW DO WE ENSURE.
THAT WE PROVIDE THE A LEVEL OF
OVERSIGHT TO ENSURE SAFETY ON
OUR ROADS ALSO.
ENSURE THAT THE PROCESSES ARE
EFFICIENT SO I WANT TO HAVE THAT
DIALOGUE WITH THEM.
IT'S JUST IT'S STILL REMAINS A A
CONCERNED WE'RE STILL GETTING
INPUT IN MY OFFICE TODAY AND
IT'S NOT JUST FROM OUR REGION.
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR
THREE YEARS IT STARTED WITH
TRUCK DRIVERS.
AND NOW HERE WE ARE.
WITH ANOTHER TRUCK DRIVING
PROBLEM MAY WE WOULD MAKE WE
WERE MAKING THESE TRUCK DRIVER
STUDENTS WHO GRADUATED FROM --
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS
ACCREDITED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT WE'RE HAVING TO
WAIT LONG LONG PERIODS OF TIME
JUST TO GET TAP TESTED.
AND THEY WERE LOSING JOB
OPPORTUNITIES AT A TIME WHEN WE
HAD SOMETHING LIKE THIRTY
THOUSAND ON FIELD.
TRUCKING POSITIONS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND NOW THREE
YEARS LATER HERE HERE'S ANOTHER
TRUCK DRIVER -- ISSUE WITH
RESPECT TO PERMITTING.
AND HONESTLY THOUGH THIS
CUSTOMER SERVICE.
FAILURE IS REALLY TROUBLING
BECAUSE MANY OF MY CONSTITUENTS
HAVE SAID.
WELL IF YOU CAN'T.
IF WE CAN'T GET YOU THE PERMIT
IN TIME.
THE ONLY THING YOU CAN DO IS
SHUT DOWN.
THAT'S NOT THAT'S NOT A SOLUTION.
AND YET MY HOPE IS THAT THE OLD.
WORK WITH THE DMV AND OTHERS
WITH RESPECT TO ENFORCEMENT YOU
CAN'T.
MISS THESE KIND OF IMPORTANT
PERMITS AND THEN MAKE THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA PAY.
THE CONSEQUENCE GETTING PULLED
OVER FOR SOMETHING THAT REALLY
WAS OUT OF THERE.
ABILITY TO CONTROL SO I WANTED
TO RAISE THAT I STILL THINK
THERE ARE SOME PROBLEMS THERE
AND LET'S HOPE WE CAN WE CAN GET
TO THOSE IT'S IT'S A FIRE DRILL
THAT I THINK NEEDS.
TO NEEDS TO HAPPEN I WOULD LOOK
FOR TO HAVE A FUTURE
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU ON ALL OF
THAT.
THANK YOU.
THANK INCLUDE SOME ARE SHORT
PANEL.
ONE SO WE'RE GOING TO BE MOVING --
TO PANEL TO WILL BE GOOD TO TALK
ABOUT THE EVALUATIONS OF THE DMV
OPERATIONS -- THANK YOU TO THE
SECRETARY BADGER FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AS WELL AS THE STAFF
FROM THE OFFICE OF STATE AUDITS
AND EVALUATIONS FROM DEPARTMENT
FINANCE
[inaudible]
SENATOR BADGER.
START WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
.
THAT I OWN.
I'M SORRY SO I NEED THE WRONG
ABOUT THE NUMBER THAT WAS ME
POLITICS.
I'D I'D BUT MY EARS ARE PLUGS SO
I WASN'T SURE I DIDN'T THINK IT
WAS ON BUT I CAN HEAR ONLY UP
WHEN YOU'RE TODAY -- ANYWAY SO I
WILL CONTINUE I WANT TO SHARE
WITH YOU SOME OF THE THINGS THAT
THE STRIKE TEAM IS DOING THAT I
BELIEVE WILL HAVE LONG TERM
IMPACT. FOR THE DMV AND ITS
CUSTOMERS THESE ACTIONS COUPLED
WITH OUR BUDGET PROPOSALS WILL
BRING SIGNIFICANT CHANGE.
AND REINVENTION THAT IS SO
CRITICALLY NEEDED IN THE DMV AND
TO THE PEOPLE.
THEY SERVE FIRST LET ME BE CLEAR.
ABOUT THE MISSION OF THE STRIKE
TEAM OBJECTIVE IS TO BEGIN THE
WORK OF REINVENTING THIS
IMPORTANT PUBLIC FACING AGENCY
WE ARE NOT SIMPLY TALKING TO
PEOPLE AND THEN PLANNING TO
WRITE A REPORT.
THE DMV'S TRACK RECORD AND
SYSTEMIC SHORT COMINGS HAVE
ALREADY BEEN WELL DOCUMENTED.
YOU'LL HEAR MORE ABOUT THEM FROM --
JENNIFER -- IS FROM THE AUDIT
AND DMV'S CUSTOMERS SHOULDN'T
HAVE TO WAIT ANY LONGER FOR THE
CHANGE THAT IS SO NEEDED.
THE STRIKE TEAM IS ACTION
ORIENTED AND ARE ALREADY MAKING
CHANGES THAT WE EXPECT WILL HELP
THE DMB AND ITS CUSTOMERS NOW
AND WELL INTO THE FUTURE.
WE ALL KNOW THE DMB IS GRAPPLING
WITH TO SIGNIFICANT ISSUES REAL
IDEA MOTOR VOTER THE REAL ID HAS
A FAST APPROACHING DEADLINE
WHICH WE'VE DISCUSSED TODAY.
EVERY CALIFORNIAN WHO NEEDS TO
FLYER AND RE SECURE FEDERAL
FACILITY OR MILITARY BASE.
AND DOES NOT HAVE A VALID.
SPORT MISS HAVE A REAL ID BY
OCTOBER.
ONE TWENTY TWENTY GETTING A REAL
ID REQUIRES A VISIT TO THE DMV
OFFICE AND WHILE THERE IS NO WAY
AROUND THAT VISIT WE ARE ALREADY
WORKING ON SEVERAL EFFORTS WHICH
I'LL DESCRIBE IN MORE DETAIL. TO
GET A REAL ID TO AS MANY
CALIFORNIANS WHO NEED ONE BEFORE
THE DEADLINE WAS SICK.
WITHOUT SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASING
FIELD OFFICE WAIT TIMES MOTOR
VOTER IS ANOTHER AREA WHERE WE
BELIEVE BETTER OUTCOMES ARE
WITHIN REACH AS A DMB IMPROVES
ITS TRAINING.
PROCESSES AND TECHNOLOGY.
AS WITH EVERYTHING WHEN CHANGE
IS NOT THE SILVER BULLET
ESPECIALLY FOR AN ORGANIZATION
IS AS LARGE AND COMPLEX AS DMV
NOT TO MENTION.
ONE WITH A HIS HISTORY OF SILO
TO TOP DOWN DECISION MAKING THE
STRIKE TEAM HAS BEEN WORKING ON
A SERIES OF ACTIONS THAT I
BELIEVE WILL BRING NEW WAYS OF
OPERATING.
BOTH INTERNALLY AND EXTERNALLY
TO DMV'S.
THESE MAY START WITH ONE FOCUS
BUT WILL.
I BELIEVE.
B. THEN ABLE TO BE CARRIED
THROUGH ALL CORNERS OF THE
ORGANIZATION THE STRIKE TEAM
WORKED WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE TO LAUNCH A SEARCH FOR A
PERMANENT DIRECTOR OF THE DMV --
IT IS NOW POSTED OF COURSE ON
THE GOVERNOR'S -- WEBSITE THE
SEARCH FOCUSES ON THE NEED FOR A
VISIONARY PRAGMATIC DIRECTOR TO
SERVE ALL OF CALIFORNIANS.
THE STRIKE TEAM IS WORKING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT.
IN SEEKING QUALIFIED APPLICANTS
TO FEEL IMPORTANT VACANCIES AND
A NUMBER OF KEY MANAGEMENT
POSITIONS INCLUDING LEADERSHIP
AND CUSTOMER CENTERED PROCESS
REDESIGNS THESE ROLES ARE
ESSENTIAL. TO A CULTURAL
TRANSFORMATION WHICH I BELIEVE
IS REQUIRED TO CREATE A CUSTOMER
CENTERED DMV ORGANIZATION THE
STRIKE TEAM REVIEWED
DEPARTMENT'S IT CAPACITY. TO
ASSESS THE DMV'S READINESS TO
MODERNIZE THE DELIVERY OF IT
SERVICES.
THIS MEANS BUILDING I TO
CAPACITY WITH AN EMPHASIS ON
HUMAN AND TECHNICAL INFO
INFRASTRUCTURE FOCUSED ON
DELIVERY SERVICE DELIVERY
SECURITY AND RELIABILITY.
ULTIMATELY THIS PORTFOLIO REVIEW
OF THEIR IT SYSTEMS WE FOUND A
GREAT DEAL A GREAT NEEDS GIVES
ME TO SHORE UP KEY TECHNOLOGY
SYSTEMS.
THE DMB AUTOMATION SYSTEM THE DM
VA WHICH HAS BEEN REFERRED TO
EARLIER.
HAS OBSOLETE PROPRIETARY
PROGRAMMING LANGUAGES AND LACKS
FLEXIBILITY TO SUPPORT
OPERATIONAL CHANGES.
WE DECIDED THAT TECHNICAL
INSTABILITY SHOULD BE ADDRESSED
PRIOR TO MODERNIZING THE FRONT
AND SYSTEMS USED BY DMB STAT IN
ORDER TO REDUCE SYSTEM OUTAGES
THAT AFFECT THE PUBLIC AND
INSURE A SOLID FOUNDATION FOR
FUTURE TECHNICAL.
AND BUSINESS CHANGES AS I MIGHT
SAY WE HAVE -- EXPERIENCE SOME
OF THOSE TODAY OUT EVER I WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT THE OUTAGE
THIS MORNING THAT WAS TALKED
ABOUT WAS A ADD.
AS DATA.
AS CENTER ISSUE AT CDT WAS NOT
AT THE DMV A ISSUE ONE OF THE
PERENNIAL FRUSTRATIONS WITH THE
DANNY IS THAT WHILE YOU CAN USE
A CREDIT CARD ONLINE OR AT A
KIOSK YOU CAN'T USE.
ONE WHEN YOU GO TO THE FIELD
OFFICE GOVERNOR NEWSOME HAS
CALLED THIS OUT AND I CERTAINLY
AGREE THAT IT MAKES NO SENSE.
THAT IN AN ERA WHERE I CAN USE
MY CREDIT CARD ALMOST ANY
LOCATION THE WORLD I CAN'T USE
THE DMV OFFICE.
THE STRIKE TEAM LOOKED AT
PERCEIVED BARRIERS TO CREDIT
CARD USE AT THE DMV INCLUDING
SECURITY AND PRIVACY ISSUES.
THE STRIKE TEAM IN THE DMV
RELEASED AN INVITATION TO
NEGOTIATE FOR BIDDERS TO RESPOND.
TO ON MARCH ELEVENTH THE
CONTRACT WILL BE AWARDED BY THE
END OF APRIL TO A CREDIT CARD
VENDOR.
IN MAY JUNE WILL WORK TO
COMBINED DEBIT AND CREDIT CARD
SERVICES BEGIN TO PILOT IN THE
FIELD OFFICE BY JULY WITH FULL
IMPLEMENTATION BEFORE THE END OF
THE YEAR.
AS ACTING DIRECTOR WEB MENTIONED
ONE OF OUR KEY EFFORTS IS TO
AVOID UNNECESSARY VISITS TO THE
FIELD OFFICE.
WE WANT TO IMPROVE.
THE DMV WEBSITE AGAIN THIS BEEN
MENTIONED EARLIER TODAY HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS. TO MAKE SURE --
CAN EASILY FIND INFORMATION THEY
NEED WE PROPOSE AN OPERATION TO
DO A COMPLETE OVERHAUL OF THE
WEBSITE USING BEST PRACTICES OF
HUMAN CENTERED DESIGN WITH A
FOCUS ON ONLINE SERVICES.
THIS WILL ALLOW US TO DESIGN A
MODERN WEBSITE THAT PUTS
CUSTOMERS FIRST AND MAKES IT
MAKES IT EASIER TO CONDUCT
ONLINE TRANSACTIONS.
IF YOU CAN'T FIND WHAT YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR ON THE WEBSITE THE
NEXT STEP IS OFFICE TO OFTEN TO
PICK UP THE PHONE.
WELL THAT EXPERIENCE HAS ALSO
BEEN FRUSTRATING FOR DMV
CUSTOMERS THE STRIKE TEAM
BROUGHT IN THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD WHO OPERATES ONE OF THE
MOST EFFICIENT.
CALL CENTERS IN THE STATE TO DO
A THOROUGH REVIEW OF THE DAM
THESE CALL CENTER PRACTICES AND
SHARE BEST PRACTICES.
AMONG ITS FINDINGS WERE.
THAT THE DMB SHOULD DEVELOP AN
ANNUAL COMP COMPREHENSIVE HIRING
AND TRAINING PLAN USE CUSTOMER
SERVICE SIMULATION SIMULATIONS
TO EVALUATE CANDIDATES FOR BASIC
SKILLS.
NEEDED IN A CALL CENTER MANAGER
ONES HAVE SPENT UP 280% OF THEIR
TIME ON PHONE SINCE AUGUST
THEY'RE NOT AVAILABLE FOR STAFF
DEVELOPMENT COACHING COMPLETING
REPORTS OTHER SUPERVISORY
FUNCTIONS WHICH WE BELIEVE THEY
SHOULD BE.
OUT OF FOREIGN AND TWENTY NINE
PHONE AGENTS AN AVERAGE OF TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE OR ON
THE PHONES BECAUSE THEY'RE
PERFORMING BASIC OFFICE WORK.
UPGRADE TO PERSONAL COMPUTERS SO
THAT TECHNICIANS WILL HAVE
ACCESS TO EMAIL AND ONLINE
MANUALS CURRENTLY TECHNICIANS
MUST REFERENCE PAPER MANUALS TO
LEARN THE PROCESSES MONOPODS
HERE FOR ONE SECOND BECAUSE A
MEMBER COOPER RAISED A REFRESH
OF OF COMPUTERS ON OUR IN OUR
LEARNING AND THAT OF A FINANCE.
THERE WERE -- YEAR AFTER YEAR
REFRESHING OF COMPUTERS AND THE
TECHNICIANS OF THE CALL CENTERS
DON'T EVEN HAVE A COMPUTER SO
WHEN A WHEN A CUSTOMER CALLS UP
AND HAS SOMETHING THEY CAN'T DO
A WORD SEARCH EXCEPT BY DOING IT
THIS WAY.
IT'S TOTALLY INEFFECTIVE AND
INEFFICIENT THE DMB IS ALREADY
PREPARING AN ACTION PLAN TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CHALLENGES --
THAT AD FTP HAS DISCOVERED AND
THEY ARE ALREADY BEGINNING. TO
MAKE IMPROVEMENTS ADDITIONALLY
AS ACT ACTING DIRECTOR WEB
TESTIFIED WE HOPE TO EXPAND
SERVICES FOR THE PUBLIC BY
ADDING TOOLS SUCH AS CHAT BOT.
LIVE CHAT AS WELL AS THE ABILITY
TO PROCESS MORE ROUTINE
TRANSACTIONS BY PHONE
TECHNICIANS THE LIMITED ANOTHER
NUMBER OF TRANSACTIONS THAT THEY
CURRENTLY ALLOWED TO PERFORM
WE'RE WANTING TO EXPAND THOSE.
ALL OF OUR EFFORTS ARE DESIGNED
TO HELP CUSTOMERS FIND ACCURATE
EASY TO UNDERSTAND INFORMATION
IN THE MANNER THAT BEST WORKS
FOR THEM WITHOUT HAVING TO GO TO
THE FIELD OFFICE. TO THAT END WE
ARE PLANNING TO EXPAND THIS WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER AS WELL THE
NUMBER OF SELF SERVICE TERMINALS
ARE KIOSKS AVAILABLE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
AND ADDING SERVICES TO THOSE
KIOSKS.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY WHICH YOU'VE
HEARD A HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO
KIOSKS IN FIELD OFFICES AND
RETAIL AND OTHER NON FIELD
OFFICE LOCATIONS.
WE HOPE TO ADD I THINK ROBBIE
SAID THIS EARLIER WE HOPE TO ADD
AT THE STRIKE.
TEAMS A SUGGESTION A HUNDRED
SELF SERVICE TERMINALS AT KEY
LOCATIONS BY SUMMER AND ANOTHER
ONE HUNDRED BY THE END OF THE
YEAR.
THE USAGE OF THESE CHAOS HAS
RISEN AGAIN WAS.
MENTIONED EARLIER AND MORE THAN
A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND TRANSACTIONS WERE
PROCESSED ON THE KIOSKS IN
FEBRUARY.
THIS IS WHY WE HOPE TO NOT ONLY
ADD MORE KIOSK BUT ALSO TO ADD
MORE SERVICES -- CURRENTLY THE
ONLY PROCESS.
THE ONLY MACHINES THAT THE
MACHINES CURRENTLY ONLY PROCESS
SKEWS ME VEHICLE REGISTRATION
RENEWALS BUT WE HAVE LEARNED
THAT THEY DO MANY MORE FUNCTIONS
AND OTHER STATES SAME VENDOR.
FOR EXAMPLE THE ABILITY OF CHAOS
TO ISSUE A REPLACEMENT DRIVER'S
LICENSE WOULD SAVE THOUSANDS OF
FIELD OFFICE VISITS A YEAR.
AS ONE MILLION CALIFORNIANS LOSE
THEIR DRIVER'S LICENSE A YEAR
AND THEY END UP VISIT IN A FIELD
OFFICE TO HAVE A REPLACEMENT THE
STRIKE TEAM IS ALSO WORKING ON A
PILOT PROJECT TO BRING THE DMV.
TO MAJOR COMPANIES IN THE STATE
IN ORDER TO HELP THEIR EMPLOYEES
GET A REAL ID THIS POP UP DMV IS
AIMED AT STATES BUSINESS
TRAVELERS WITH ADVANCE NOTICE
AND COORDINATION EMPLOYERS COULD
PREPARE EMPLOYEES TO PULL
TOGETHER.
REQUIRED DOCUMENTS FOR THE REAL
ID BRING THEM TO WORK ON A
DESIGNATED DAY AND COMPLETE THE
ENTIRE APPLICATION PROCESS AT
THEIR WORK LOCATION IN MINUTES.
WE HAVE THE FIRST PILOT
SCHEDULED FOR HEALTH NET HERE IN
SACRAMENTO REGION FOR LATER THIS
MONTH IF IT IS SUCCESSFUL WE
HAVE HOPE TO HAVE MANY MORE X.
LARGE CORPORATIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE INVOLVED IN OUR DMB
POP UP -- PLAN WE ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE PEOPLE CAN GET
APPOINTMENTS AT THE DMV WHEN
THEY NEED THEM.
THAT IS WHY I HAD MET WITH THE
CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER TO MATIC
THE DMV'S APPOINTMENT BETTER.
VENDOR TO IMPROVE THE PROCESSES
AND TO ESCALATE AND RESOLVE
ISSUES AND MAKE MODIFICATIONS TO
PREVENT INDIVIDUALS AND
COMPANIES FOR MAKING MULTIPLE
APPOINTMENTS.
WE ALSO ARE GOING TO EXAMINE THE
COMMUNICATIONS AROUND REAL ID WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
WHOSE LICENSES ARE EXPIRING
BETWEEN NOW AND OCTOBER ONE
TWENTY TWENTY KNOW THAT THEY
NEED A REAL ID IF THEY INTEND TO
FLY OR ENTERING SECURE FEDERAL.
FACILITY OR DO NOT HAVE A VALID
PASSPORT JUST AS IMPORTANT AS
KNOWING WHETHER A REAL IDEAS
NEEDED IS KNOWING WHAT DOCUMENT
TO BRING WITH THEM TO THE FIELD
OFFICE.
OUR GOAL IS TO HAVE ONE VISIT
ONLY IN ORDER TO GET A REAL ID
THAT MEANS WE NEED TO
COMMUNICATE CLEARLY ABOUT WHAT
EVERY PERSON NEEDS TO BRING WITH
THEM.
AND IN SOME CASES SUCH AS WHEN
THERE HAS BEEN A NAME CHANGE IT
CAN BE EXTREMELY COMPLICATED
UNTIL NOW DM THE HAS CREATED ALL
OF THE MESSAGING AND MATERIALS.
AROUND REAL ID IN HOUSE WITHOUT
THE BENEFIT OF KNOWING WHETHER
THE MESSAGING IS RESONATING.
AT A TARGET AT A TARGETED
AUDIENCE THIS IS WHY THE STRIKE
TEAM IS ASKING FOR FUNDING FOR A
MAJOR OUTREACH CAMPAIGN.
THE STRIKE TEAM.
INTERVIEWED VENDORS WITH
EXPERIENCE RUNNING NATIONAL AND
STATE WIDE CAMPAIGNS WE TALKED
TO OUR COLLEAGUES AT COVER
CALIFORNIA AND COMPLETE COUNT
SENSES.
TWENTY TWENTY OFFICE ABOUT THE
SCALE AND SCOPE OF THEIR CURRENT
MARKETING AND OUTREACH EFFORTS
ON STATEWIDE CAMPAIGNS.
RESEARCH IS CRITICAL AND WE
EXPECT THE CAMPAIGN TO USE A
NUMBER OF STANDARD AND CUSTOM
TOOLS TO ASSESS THESE DIFFERENT
MARKET SEGMENTS.
AND LEVERAGE PEOPLE WHO ARE
INFLUENTIAL IN THOSE SEGMENTS TO
HELP SPREAD OUR MESSAGE IN A WAY
THAT RESONATES WITH SPECIFIC
SEGMENTS OF THE COMMUNITY.
WE WANT A COMPREHENSIVE CAMPAIGN
THAT IS BOTH EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT THE DEADLINE FOR
GETTING THE REAL ID WELL STATED
OCTOBER.
ONE TWENTY TWENTY HAPPENS TO
FALL IN THE THICK OF THE GENERAL
ELECTION WHEN MEDIA BUYS ARE AT
A PREMIUM PREMIUM. TO MEASURE
SUCCESS WILL GAUGE AWARENESS
WITH A PRE CAMPAIGN SURVEY AND
THEN FOLLOWED UP WITH A POST
CAMPAIGN SURVEY TO ASSESS IT.
WE ALSO WANT TO INCREASE OUR
COMMUNICATION AROUND REAL ID BY
ESTABLISHING BOOTHS AT THE MAJOR
CALIFORNIA AIRPORTS TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION AND ANSWER QUESTIONS
AROUND RELY DE.
AND OTHER DMV SERVICES THE
STRIKE TEAM AND DMB ARE WORKING
WITH TSA -- ON THE PLACEMENT OF
THESE POSTS NOW IN ANOTHER
EFFORT TO REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
CUSTOMERS VISITING FIELD OFFICES
TO COME.
PLATE TASTIC COULD BE DONE
ONLINE WE ARE TALKING TO VENDORS
ABOUT MODERNIZING THE DMV'S
APPROACH TO AUTHENTICATING
CUSTOMERS IDEA ONLINE SERVICES.
CURRENTLY DIEM THESE CUSTOMERS
CAN CONFIRM THEIR ID ONLINE --
FOR DRIVER'S LICENSE AND
IDENTIFICATION CARD APPLICATIONS
THE SERVICE COULD BE EXTENDED TO
STREAMLINE THE REAL ID
APPLICATION PROCESS.
BY ALLOWING DMV CUSTOMERS TO
UPLOAD AND STORE REQUIRED
DOCUMENTS BEFORE GOING INTO THE
FIELD OFFICE OR WHILE WAITING IN
LINE.
THE GOAL IS TO ENSURE THE
CUSTOMER HAS A COMPLETE
APPLICATION AND REQUIRED
DOCUMENTATION WHEN VISITING A
FIELD OFFICE THAT THE PROCESS
CAN BE COMPLETED QUICKLY
AVOIDING RETURN VISITS.
THE FIELD OFFICE TECHNICIAN
WOULD ONLY NEED TO VERIFY THE
CUSTOMER'S DOCUMENTS THIS COULD.
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE THE
TRANSACTION TIMES THIS IDENTITY
AUTHENTICATION WILL BE SEAMLESS
TO THE CUSTOMER AND CUSTOMERS
WILL NO LONGER NEED TO REMEMBER
A LOG IN.
OR PASSWORD TO USE ONLINE
SERVICES CURRENTLY DMV'S
IDENTITY MANAGEMENT REQUIRES
CUSTOMERS INTO THE LAST FOUR
DIGITS OF THEIR SSN.
THIS CHANGE WILL ALLOW MORE
CUSTOMERS THE ABILITY TO ACCESS
AND USE DAM THESE ONLINE
SERVICES.
DMV ESTIMATES THAT THERE ARE
THREE POINT SIX MILLION
CUSTOMERS WHO USE ONLINE TRACKS
ACT TRANSACTIONS REQUIRING A LOG
IN ANNUALLY.
AND AS WE LOOK TOWARD DMB OF THE
FUTURE THE STRIKE TEAM IS
LOOKING TO PUT OUT A REQUEST FOR
QUOTE. TO DEVELOP WORKPLACE
STRATEGIES ANALYTICS AND USE
RETAIL DESIGNED TO PROVIDE THE
BASIS OF A NEW DESIGN THAT WILL
OPTIMIZE THE MOVEMENT OF PEOPLE.
TO A MORE FUNCTIONAL
ARCHITECTURAL DESIGN A DMV
INDEED OF THE FUTURE FINALLY WE
BELIEVE THERE MUST BE A
COMPREHENSIVE CHANGE IN HOW THE
DMV WORKS.
THE STRIKE TEAM AND DMV HAVE
ENGAGED MCKINSEY AND COMPANY
TELL DMB FOCUS.
THE START OF ITS CULTURAL CHANGE
ON IMPROVING CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE
AROUND REAL ID THEY HAVE BEEN
ASKED TO UNDERTAKE A SERIES OF
THREE RELATED DESIGN SPRINTS.
FOCUSING ON COMMUNICATIONS
EMPLOYEE TRAINING AND FIELD
OFFICE ACTIVITIES FOR ISSUING
REAL ID'S.
EMBEDDING DIEM THE EMPLOYEES
INTO THE PROCESS IS ESSENTIAL TO
GETTING IT RIGHT AND KEY TO
TEACHING STAFF NEW WAYS TO
REDESIGN OUTMODED PROCESSES
QUICKLY.
LAST WEEK AND MAKING Z. MADE
THREE FEEL BEST AT OFFICE VISITS
AND PLAN TO VISIT ANOTHER DOZEN.
IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE.
MCKENZIE SENT OUT A SURVEY TO
LEARN ABOUT REAL ID MARKET
SEGMENTS AND WHAT MOTIVATES
DECISION MAKING THEY ARE
ANALYZING FIELD OFFICE DATA FROM
DMV AS WELL AS FIELD OFFICE
OBSERVATIONS FROM SITE VISITS
INCLUDING THE MAPPING OF
CUSTOMER JOURNEYS. TO THE FIELD
OFFICE THEY WILL USE THESE
ELEMENTS AND OTHERS TO START
DEVELOPING PROTOTYPES FOR
IMPROVED FIELD OFFICE CUSTOMER
FLOW.
THEY WILL THEN TEST AND REFINE
SIMILAR PROTOTYPING SPRINTS FOR
COMMUNICATIONS ABOUT REAL ID IN
TRAINING FOR THE FIELD OFFICE
EMPLOYEES WILL RESULT IN BETTER
PREPARED CUSTOMERS BETTER
TRAINED EMPLOYEES AND REDUCTION
IN TIME.
THE TRANSACTIONS TAKE.
THIS WILL HELP THE FIELD OFFICE
TO HANDLE THE EXPECTED INCREASE
IN CUSTOMER SEEKING REAL THE
ID'S AND ENSURE THAT CUSTOMERS
WHO LACKED THE REQUIRED
DOCUMENTS DON'T WAIT IN LINE
ONLY TO LEARN.
THAT THEY ARE PREPARED ONCE THEY
GET TO THE COUNTER.
WELL ALL OF THE MACKENZIE'S WORK
IS FOCUSED ON THE PROCESSING
SURROUNDING REAL ID'S THESE
LESSONS OUR RESEARCH OUR USER
RESEARCH USING PROTOTYPES TO
TEST NEW APPROACHES AND FOCUSING
SOLUTION ON CUSTOMER NEEDS WILL
CASCADE AND TRANSLATE. TO OTHER
KEY DMB FUNCTIONS ANOTHER KEY
AREA THAT BOTH THE STRIKE TEAM
N. O. S. I..
O. SE SKEWS ME -- AS A SAY LET'S
SEE ALSO WAS AYE.
SKEWS ME AUDIT FOUND LACKING IS
TRAINING TRAINING MATERIALS ARE
OUT OF DATE AND WHILE DMB SETS
ASIDE AN HOUR FOR TRAINING EACH
WEEK IT IS UNCLEAR HOW WELL THIS
TIME IS USED AND HOW EFFECTIVE
IT IS.
THE LACK OF ROBUST TRAINING IS
WHY WE ARE ORGANIZING A TRAINING
STAND DOWN.
DAY THIS SUMMER FOR ONE DAY WE
WILL CLOSE DMV OFFICES TO
PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE UNIFORMED
TRAINING AND ALL FIELD OFFICES.
I KNOW THAT THIS IS IT
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT BUT I
THINK WE NEED.
BUT I THINK WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING SIGNIFICANT TO MAKE
CLEAR TO OUR DIEM THE EMPLOYEES.
HOW IMPORTANT THEIR WORK IS TO
THE STATE AND INDEED TO THEIR
CUSTOMERS?
I HOPE THIS IS GIVING YOU AN
IDEA OF WHAT THE STRIKE TEAM HAS
BEEN DOING.
I BELIEVE WE'VE MADE SOME
SIGNIFICANT PRODUCT PROGRESS AND
ARE ON A PATH TO MAKE MEANINGFUL
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE DMV AND OF
COURSE I'M VERY HAPPY TO TAKE
YOUR QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YOU WANT.
TO YOU WANT TO GO NEXT.
PLEASE.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS ON GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JENNIFER
WOULD OCCUR AND I'M FROM THE
OFFICE OF STATE AUDITS AND
EVALUATIONS AND ALSO WITH ME IS
MARYLAND STANDING HORSE WHO IS
THE MANAGER ON THE ASSIGNMENT.
AND WE'RE GOING -- TO GIVE YOU A
I DON'T THINK IT'S ON SO THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
INVITE US TO THIS HEARING SO
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE A BRIEF --
SUMMARY OF OUR DMV AUDIT RESULTS
AS YOU KNOW IN SEPTEMBER TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AT THE
DIRECTION OF GOVERNOR BROWN
FINANCE BEGAN.
THE PERFORMANCE AUDIT AT THE DMV
AND WE ISSUED OUR REPORT IN
MARCH OF MARCH OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AND WE HAD TO AUDIT
OBJECTIVES AND WE BEGAN THE
AUDIT THE FIRST AUDIT OBJECTIVE
WAS THE ASSESS THE EFFICIENCY
AND EFFECTIVENESS OF DMV'S
OPERATIONS AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE THEIR
PRACTICES.
AND ENHANCE THE FIELD OFFICE
CUSTOMER SERVICE OUR SECOND
OBJECTIVE WAS TO EVALUATE DMV'S
IT SYSTEM AND ITS IMPACT ON THE
FIELD OFFICE CUSTOMER SERVICE
BOTH OBJECTIVES -- WERE AROUND
THE CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE.
WELL PERFORMING OUR AUDIT WE
INTERVIEWED OVER A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY EMPLOYEES AT DMV
SACRAMENTO HEADQUARTERS IN FIELD
OFFICES RANGING FROM THE FORMER
DIRECTOR OF DMV. TO MOTOR
VEHICLE REPRESENTATIVES IN THE
FIELD OFFICES WE EVALUATED OVER
THREE HUNDRED RESPONSES RECEIVED
VIA OUR WEBSITE WE HAD A A
EMPLOYEE CAUGHT PLAY OR A
CUSTOMER FORM ONLINE WHERE
PEOPLE COULD COME IN AND PROVIDE
ANONYMOUS FEEDBACK TO US.
AND WE ALSO AND DESERVE
OPERATIONS FROM THE CUSTOMER AND
EMPLOYEE PERSPECTIVE AT THREE
THIRTY FIELD OFFICES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WHERE AND STAFF WERE --
WENT IN AND NOT ON IT THEY WERE
ANNOUNCED THEY WERE NOT AN
AUDITOR ON THAT PARTICULAR DAY
WHEN THEY WENT AND THE AUDIT
MANAGER WILL NOW SHARE THE
RESULTS OF THE BOTH OBJECTIVES.
THANK YOU THE AFTERNOON MARYLAND
STANDING HORSE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE.
AS DESCRIBED IN OUR AUDIT REPORT
DMV OPERATIONS ARE NOT ALWAYS
EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE IN
DELIVERING SERVICES TO THEIR
CUSTOMERS.
MANY OPPORTUNITIES EXIST TO
IMPROVE DMV'S PRACTICES AND
ENHANCE THE FIELD OFFICE
CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE.
OUR AUDIT REPORT RESULTS ARE
ORGANIZED INTO TWO CHAPTERS ONE
FOR EACH OF OUR AUDIT OBJECTIVES.
EACH FINING THE COMPANY BY
DETAILED RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
ARE FOCUSED ON THE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT DMV HAS TO ENHANCE THEIR
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE AND
ORGANIZATIONAL CULTURE.
WITH REGARD TO THEIR OPERATIONS
AND IT -- I WILL NOW PRESENT A
SUMMARY OF THOSE FINDINGS.
OURFIRST AUDIT OBJECTIVE ON DMV
OPERATIONS AND THE FIELD OFFICE
CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE.
RESULTED IN SEVEN FINDINGS AS
FOLLOWS [inaudible]
FINDING.
ONE THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
DEFICIENCIES IN PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE REAL ID
PROGRAM.
THESE INCLUDED AN INCONSISTENT
APPROACH FOR PLANNING FOR REAL
ID AND THE DECADE LEADING UP TO
IMPLEMENTATION.
DELAYED PRIORITIZATION OF THE
RELATED IT PROJECT UNTIL.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND MISSED
OPPORTUNITIES TO REDESIGN POLICY
FOR THE FREQUENCY THAT CUSTOMERS
REQUIRED DMV SERVICES.
THE SECOND FINDING.
IS THAT DMV OPERATES UNDER AN
OUTDATED ORGANIZATIONAL AND
REPORTING STRUCTURE. FOR EXAMPLE
FIELD OFFICE GRADES GRADES WHICH
DETERMINE THE SIZE AND RESOURCE
NEEDS OF FIELD OFFICES.
WERE LAST ASSESSED STATEWIDE IN.
NINETEEN NINETY FURTHER MORE
REGIONAL OFFICE OVERSIGHT OVER
FIELD OFFICES IS IT.
INCONSISTENT AND DMV'S INTERNAL
COMMUNICATIONS STRUCTURE TO
FIELD OFFICES IS INEFFICIENT.
IN PART DUE TO FIELD OFFICE
EMPLOYEES NOT HAVING -- A DMV
EMAIL -- DMV EMAIL ACCESS.
OUR THIRD FINDING IS THAT DMV
STAFFING AND BUDGETING APPROACH
IS NOT FOCUSED ON MAXIMIZING
FIELD OFFICE CAPACITY.
ON AVERAGE 30% OF FIELD OFFICE
WINDOWS WERE CLOSED AND
THEREFORE NOT ASSISTING
CUSTOMERS DURING OUR
OBSERVATIONS.
IN ADDITION LONG TERM RELIABLE
DATA ON FIELD OFFICE ABSENTEEISM
WAS NOT READILY AVAILABLE.
ALSO DMV DOES NOT HAVE AN
EFFECTIVE PROCESS TO ALLOCATE
POSITIONS TO FIELD OFFICES TO
EFFECTIVELY HANDLE THEIR
CUSTOMER DEMAND.
OUR FOURTH FINDING IS THAT
APPOINTMENT PRACTICES NEED
IMPROVEMENT.
SPECIFICALLY DMV'S APPOINTMENT
SYSTEM ALLOWS FOR DIFFERENCES
AND APPOINTMENT AVAILABILITY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND THE RESERVATION OF DUPLICATE
APPOINTMENTS.
OUR FIFTH FINDING IS THAT
STATEWIDE MONITORING OF THE
FIELD OFFICE CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE
THESE IMPROVEMENTS.
INITIATIVE SUCH AS THE COMMAND
CENTER AND LEAN SIX SIGMA TEAM
WERE UNTIMELY AND IMPLEMENTED
WITH REGARD TO THE SUMMER TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WAIT TIMES.
AND THESE GROUPS COULD DO MORE
TO IMPROVE THE CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE.
ALSO DMV'S INTERNAL AUDIT UNIT
DOES NOT AUDIT CUSTOMER SERVICE
RELATED TOPICS.
OUR SIXTH FINDING IS THAT THE
FIELD OFFICE -- FIELD OFFICE
CUSTOMER SERVICE TOOLS SUCH AS
LINE TRIAGE AND ACCURATELY
TRACKING AN ADVERTISING CUSTOMER
WAIT TIMES.
AND TABLET IN TEXAS A FEW
CATIONS WERE INCONSISTENTLY
IMPLEMENTED.
OUR SEVEN FINDING.
IS THAT FIELD OFFICE EMPLOYEE
TRAINING AND RESOURCES ARE
INADEQUATE FOR EXAMPLE MORE THAN
20% OF EMPLOYEES FROM THE
OFFICES WE VISITED.
HAD ATTENDED NEITHER A DRIVER'S
LICENSE NOR VEHICLE REGISTRATION
TRAINING -- ARE SECONDS AUDIT
OBJECTIVE AND THE SECOND CHAPTER
REPORT FOCUSES ON I TEASE IMPACT
ON THE FIELD OFFICE CUSTOMER
EXPERIENCE.
AND THAT SECTION HAS THREE
FINDINGS.
THE FIRST FINDING IS THAT THERE
ARE INSUFFICIENT NETWORK
INFRASTRUCTURES AND LACK OF
NETWORK MONITORING PROCESS SEES
WHICH CONTRIBUTED TO FIELD
OFFICE OUTAGES.
ALSO DMV'S PRIORITIZATION AND
RESOLUTION OF I. T. ISSUES NEEDS
IMPROVEMENT.
THE SECOND I. T. RELATED FINDING
IS THAT THE REAL ID I. T.
PROJECT DID NOT FOLLOW IT
INDUSTRY STANDARDS WITH REGARD
TO PRIORITIZATION.
RESOLVING PROJECT THE FAX
TESTING AND DOCUMENTATION.
AND THE THIRD FINDING.
IS THAT DMV'S USE OF LEGACY
COMPUTER PROGRAMMING LANGUAGES
CONTRIBUTE TO THEIR SUCCESSION
PLANNING RISKS.
WITHOUT ADDRESSING THE AUDIT
FINDINGS AND RECOMMENDATIONS OF
OUR REPORT DMV WILL CONTINUE
FACING CHALLENGES AND
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY
DELIVERING SERVICES TO ITS
CUSTOMERS.
WE REQUESTED DETAILED CORRECTIVE
ACTION PLAN FROM DMV WHICH IS
DUE IN MAY.
DESCRIBING THEIR PLANNED ACTIONS
TO ADDRESS THESE FINDINGS ARE
CORRESPONDING RECOMMENDATIONS.
OUR PLAN IS TO MONITOR THEIR
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN PROGRESS.
ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
INVITING US TO SHARE AND DISCUSS
THE RESULTS WITH YOU TODAY.
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE REGARDING
THESE RESULTS.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS.
THIS BOOK.
SO THANK YOU FOR THOSE
PRESENTATIONS BUT YOU KNOW
UNFORTUNATELY NOT UNLIKE THE
FIRST PANEL WHAT I'M NOT HEARING
TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE
COUNTY'S POINT EARLIER IS.
I AM AND AND PERHAPS THAT'S PART
OF THE THE AUDIT CORRECTIONS
SUGGESTIONS BUT A SYSTEM BY
WHICH THE MOST CRITICAL
DEFICIENCIES ARE MET IN A TIMELY
MANNER.
METRICS FOR MEETING THOSE MOST
CRITICAL NEEDS TO TRY TO RIGHT
THE SHIP AND THEN WHAT THE TIME
LINE FOR THAT WORK LOOKS LIKE
BECAUSE WHAT I AM HEARING AS WE
UNDERSTAND THERE ARE THERE ARE
MYRIAD CONCERNS.
THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED BUT
VERY OFTEN INSTITUTIONALLY WHEN
YOU GO TO ADDRESS ALL OF THOSE
ALL AT ONCE YOU'RE ACCOMPLISHING
RELATIVELY NOTHING IN AND IT
TAKES A VERY LONG TIME TO DO
THAT.
AND SO I THINK AND I'VE HEARD
CONSISTENTLY FROM THIS COMMITTEE
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
WHAT DOES THE TIMELINE LOOK LIKE
WHAT ARE THOSE MEASURABLE
METRICS WHEN CAN WE EXPECT TO
SEE IT?
ALL SPEAK THE REGARDING THE
AUDIT -- ARE CORRECTIVE ACTION
PLAN WHICH IS DUE SIXTY DAYS
FROM THE AUDIT ISSUANCE WHICH
WILL BE AROUND MAY -- TWENTY SIX
WE'VE REQUESTED THAT DMV INCLUDE
MILESTONES TIME LINES -- FOR
EACH OF OUR RECOMMENDATIONS AND
FINDINGS.
GREAT [inaudible]
ARM. ONE THANK YOU SECTOR BATCH
OF YOUR COMMENTS ARE APPRECIATE
THE ACTING DIRECTOR FOR YOUR
COMMENTS JUST GOING BACK -- TO
AUDIT.
AT THE OTHER TEAM THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR VERY --
COMPREHENSIVE AUDIT -- WHAT
WHAT'S CLEAR IS THAT YOU PAINT A
PICTURE OF AN ORGANIZATION?
THAT HAS THE INABILITY TO
IMPLEMENT THINGS THROUGH
IMPLEMENTED -- PROJECTS AND PUT
MY IMPLEMENTED GOALS IMPLEMENT --
THE MOST -- BASIC -- OF BUSINESS
PROCESSES THROUGHOUT THE
ORGANIZATION IN A CONSISTENT.
MANNER IS THAT A FAIR
CHARACTERIZATION [inaudible]
YEAH.
SO SO GIVEN THAT -- IT SOUNDS
LIKE YOU DON'T JUST NEED.
MILESTONES IN DATES BUT YOU NEED
A COMPLETE OVERHAUL.
OF THE DEPARTMENT BECAUSE WHAT
WHAT WE AGAIN.
YOU KNOW THIS IS UNFORTUNATELY A
REPEAT OF THE AUGUST HEARING.
WE HAD A FORMER DIRECTOR WHO
CAME HERE.
EVERYTHING THAT WAS SAID TODAY
WAS SAID.
IN AUGUST.
THE BIG DIFFERENCES.
GOING THE THE AUDITOR'S VERIFY
EXACTLY WHAT WE BELIEVED
[inaudible]
THAT.
WE DIDN'T TRUST THE
IMPLEMENTATION.
WITHIN TRUST THAT THE RESOURCES
WOULD GET TO THE FIELD -- THE
DMV STAFF WHO WORK HERE BECAUSE
SOME MORE SOMEWHERE HERE IN
AUGUST CAN ATTEST. TO THE
CONSISTENCY OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT WE HAD.
IN THE CONSISTENCY OF THE
ANSWERS.
ON BEHALF THE DM B. B. HERE'S
WHAT WAS INCONSISTENT.
WAS WHAT ACTUALLY GOT PUT INTO
ACTION.
SO.
RATE RELATIVE TO OTHER
DEPARTMENTS SO YOUR AUDITING --
WHERE IS THIS WAS HIS FAULT A
FAIRLY -- CONSISTENT WITH OTHER
DEFICIENCIES OR IS THIS -- YOU
KNOW.
WE WITH THIS WITH THIS CALL IN A
FIVE ON A SCALE OF ONE TO FIVE
WITH FIVE BEING -- SORT OF THE
MOST -- MOST CONCERNING WITH --
ONE KIND OF BEING -- SORT OF
JUST A MINOR CONCERN WHAT WE'RE
WE'RE THIS FALL AND ALL THE
DIFFERENT ARTISTS THAT YOU DO.
IN THE STATE.
THAT WOULD BE A DIFFICULT
QUESTION TO ANSWER BECAUSE LIKE
WE SHARED AT THE BEGINNING OUR
OBJECTIVES WERE VERY NARROW FOR
DMV AND EVERY TIME WE GO INTO A
DIFFERENT STATE IS AGENCY WE'RE
LOOKING AT DIFFERENT THINGS
DIFFERENT OBJECTIVES -- BUT TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION THERE WAS
SOME LEADERSHIP THAT YOU KNOW
THAT I THINK THE UNDERLYING
MESSAGE OF THE REPORTERS THERE
WERE SOME LEADERSHIP FAILURES
AND SO -- I THINK THAT IT IS
DIFFICULT FOR US TO SAY WELL IS
THERE LEADERSHIP BETTER THAN
SOMEONE ELSE'S LEADERSHIP IT WAS
AT THE TIME WHEN WE ENTERED AND
WE WERE LOOKING AT THE PROCESSES
AND PROCEDURES THAT THEY HAD IN
PLACE.
THAT THEIR COME AND PREVENTS
COULD AND MAKE.
SO SO GIVEN THAT -- THE
SITUATION.
HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT
IMPLEMENTATION OCCURS FROM?
TOP TO BOTTOM WE WE HAVE AN
ACTING DIRECTOR THE CAME FOR
SHE'S BEEN THERE FOR TWO MONTHS.
ON HOW HOW DO WE ENSURE.
ACTUAL IMPLEMENTATION.
AGAIN A DIFFICULT QUESTION
BECAUSE GENERALLY THE AUDITOR'S
GO OUT THEY PROVIDE A REPORT
THEY CITE WHAT THEY SEE BUT IT
IS AT THE DEPARTMENTS DISCRETION
TO IMPLEMENT OUR UP
RECOMMENDATIONS.
SO -- AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY KIND
OF TEETH TO SAY NO FULLER DIDN'T
YOU DIDN'T DO IT RIGHT BUT WE DO.
YES SO I GET THAT SO I GUESS THE
THE THE QUESTION IS IS -- AT
THIS POINT THERE'S A COMPLETE
LACK OF CONFIDENCE ACROSS THE
BOARD.
IN THE DEPARTMENT'S ABILITY.
TO DO WHAT THEY SAY.
SO HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT CAN
ACTUALLY HELP.
WELL DONE IF I MAY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN GOVERNOR NEWSOME
IS AB ADDED THAT THAT CHANGE
WILL HAPPEN AT THE DMV.
ANY STARTING OFF WITH THE TOP
THE LEADERSHIP.
AND AS I SAID RECRUITMENT HAS
BEGUN -- FOR A NEW DIRECTOR
THERE ARE OTHER VCANCIES --
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR AND OTHER.
OTHER VACANCIES IN THE TOP
LEADERSHIP -- THE GOVERNOR WILL
ENSURE THAT THE RIGHT MOTIVATED --
PERSONS PERSONS WILL BE
APPOINTED AND THEIR THEY WILL BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR NOT ONLY
THE THINGS THAT THE STRIKE TEAM.
IS IS -- DEVELOPING BUT ALSO TO
THE TO AS YOU SAID THIS
EXTREMELY THOROUGH AUDIT THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DID.
SO SO I I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
WORDS THAT THEY WILL BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE RIGHT HERE'S WHAT'S
MISSING.
THEY'LL BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE TO
WHAT. TWO TWO AND IN MAKING THE
MANY IMPROVEMENTS THAT THE AUDIT
HAS HAS -- IDENTIFIED THINGS
THAT THE STRIKE FORCE HAS
IDENTIFIED AND HAS ALREADY TAKEN.
INTO ACCOUNT AND IS WORKING ON%
HERE BECAUSE A PROBLEM EVEN IN
YOUR OWN SPEECH I GIVE YOU SOME
LATITUDE BECAUSE IT WAS A LITTLE
BIT LONG I AM CALLING -- AND
ALSO TO THE DIRECTOR SPEECH WAS
EXCESSIVELY LONG THERE WERE --
THINGS THAT WERE MISSING.
SO THEN WHAT WHAT WAS MISSING
WAS DATA [inaudible]
FAX TIMELINE BENCHMARKS
PERFORMANCE MEASURES SO I DON'T
HAVE ANYTHING. TO DETERMINE.
OR TO HOLD HER ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THE DEPARTMENT ACCOUNTABLE.
THERE WAS NO WE'RE GONNA REDUCE
WE TIMES BY THIS MUCH THIS IS
HOW MANY CUTS WAS WE'RE GOING TO
SERVE WE'RE GONNA.
YOU KNOW IT TOOK. SEVEN MONTHS
TO ROLL OUT WHY FIGHT TO THE
EXTERNAL.
OF ONE D. M. V. FIELD OFFICE.
HOW MANY FIELD OFFICES ARE
THEY'RE PRETTY IN THE? SEVENTY
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO SO BASED
ON THAT PAGE HOW MANY YEARS
WOULD IT TAKE TO ROLL OUT EVERY
SINGLE ONE I DON'T THINK THAT
WILL DO THEM SOME SEQUENTIALLY --
BUT BUT BUT I A WEALTH BUT BUT I
GET THE FEELING.
BUT I'M JUST SAYING THE POINT IS
IN AUGUST WE DISCUSS THIS ISSUE.
THIS WAS A MAJOR PRIORITY HOW
LONG ARE PEOPLE WAITING IN LINE
WE ARE ASSURED WE'RE GONNA WE'RE
GONNA -- WE'RE GONNA FIGURE OUT
HOW TO DO THIS BETTER FASTER.
SO SEVEN MONTHS LATER WE FOUND
OUT.
ONLY ONE IN CARMICHAEL HAS BEEN
DONE.
SO WE DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW LONG
PEOPLE I MEAN SO THE WAIT TIMES
ARE DOWN HER.
THE CALCULATION BUT WE DON'T
EVEN REALLY KNOW THE WAIT TIMES
ARE DOWN BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW.
AGAIN THE THE THE PEOPLE IN MY
AREA.
STAR WAITING IN LINE LIKE AT
FIVE AM.
AT SIX AM SOLD FOR THE THREE
HOURS THAT THEY WERE IN LINE.
BEFORE MAYBE THIS THREE OR FOUR
HOURS THEIR ONLINE BEFORE THE
STAFF EVEN GET THERE GUESS WHAT.
THAT'S NOT HELD.
THAT'S STILL TIME OUT OF THERE
SO SO I I MEAN I'M TRYING.
TO BE UNDERSTANDING AND
UNFORTUNATELY -- I'M THE ONLY
ONE LEFT SO YOU JUST HAVE ME
[inaudible]
BUT THIS BUDGET REQUEST CANNOT
WILL NOT BE APPROVED BY THIS
COMMITTEE.
HAS THIS.
THERE ARE NO MEASUREMENTS
THERE'S NO YOU'RE ASKING FOR A
25%.
BUDGET INCREASE AFTER THIS AUDIT
WHICH POINTS OUT FLAWS TO EVERY
SINGLE PART.
O. V. DEPARTMENT.
ON TOP OF THAT IT DOES EVEN IN
THIS IS AND WE'VE A GOT TO AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
SO HOW HOW CAN [inaudible]
THIS PROPOSAL.
WHAT FORWARD IN THIS FASHION?
WITHOUT ANY WAYS SO HOW HOW WAS
THAT WE'RE SUPPOSED TO PROVE
THIS WITH THE TRUST US WE'RE
GOING TO DO IT. FOR TWO HUNDRED
FORTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
HOW HOW CAN ANYBODY ELSE FOR
THAT WITH A STRAIGHT FACE I
DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT?
I'M A I'M A LITTLE BIT IN SHOCK
BECAUSE WE MET YESTERDAY MY
OFFICE OKAY WE HAVE A PLAN WE
HAVE PRESENTATION.
SO AGAIN.
NO FAX NO DATA.
NO PLAN.
ALL I HAVE IS A LINE ITEM. TO
TWO THOUSAND PEOPLE.
I'M SORRY. TWO THOUSAND PEOPLE
WITH IT RIGHT.
WHERE THEY DON'T?
WHERE THEY DO IT? TO THE OTHER
THE OTHER PART THE AUDIT MENTION
WAS THERE THEY'RE NOT EVEN BEING
TROUT THE GONNA BE TRAINED THE
TWO THOUSAND PEOPLE.
IS THERE IS THERE COUNTER SPACE
AT EACH THE FIELD OFFICES TO DO
THIS ARE THERE ENOUGH COMPUTERS.
FOR THE TWO THOUSAND PEOPLE.
SO WHAT ARE THESE TO THOSE
PEOPLE WILL BE DOING.
I I THINK THE FOLLOWING PANEL IS
GOING TO BE ADDRESSED -- AND
UPDATING THE BUDGET -- LOOK LET
ME JUST CONTINUE TO GO THROUGH
MY AUDIT QUESTIONS IF THAT'S
OKAY HE THE FIRST.
HOW DO THEY RESOLVE THE PLANNING?
AND IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES.
HOW HOW HOW DOES THE DEPARTMENT
THAT DOESN'T KNOW HOW TO TAKE?
HOW TO PRIORITIZE HOW DO YOU
TEACH THEM HOW TO PRACTICE?
SORRY CONDITIONS SPECIFICALLY
FOR THE EXAMPLE OF THE RELY D.
I. T. PROJECT PRIORITIZATION.
OUTLINED PRACTICES THAT WE HAVE
OBSERVED THAT OTHER STATE
ENTITIES -- REGARDING USING
METRICS TO PRIORITIZE PROJECTS.
CAN HAVING CONSISTENCY AND HOW
THEY DO THAT
.
DO YOU WANT TO PROVIDE AN
EXAMPLE [inaudible]
SURE.
SO.
OUR REPORT FINDINGS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE ALL SUMMER
AS AN APPENDIX C. OF OUR REPORT
WHICH I BELIEVE WAS ALSO AN
ATTACHMENT TO THE AGENDA TODAY.
TOWARDS THE END FOR FINDING TO
POINT TO A WE TALK ABOUT
REVIEWING HOW.
THE IN THE PRIORITIZE THEIR
PROJECTS AND EXCUSES ACCEPTED
SCORING AND RANKING TABLETS TO
DO SO.
SO WE RECOMMEND THAT THEY HAVE A
SYSTEMATIC SCORING SYSTEM FOR
THEIR I. T. PROJECT SO THAT THEY
CAN -- HAVE A UNIFORM METHOD FOR
PRIORITIZING DIFFERENT THINGS AS
THEY COME ACROSS THEIR TO DO
LIST -- WE ALSO RECOMMEND THAT
THEY REFINE THEIR EXISTING
TEMPLATE SO THAT THEY ALIGN WITH
THAT SYSTEMATIC SCORING SYSTEM.
AND WE RECOMMEND THAT THEY USE
THEIR EXECUTIVE GOVERNMENT'S
COUNSEL TO ADVISE THEM ON WHAT.
PROJECTS ARE FACING DMB.
SO SUGGEST TO SECRETARY ROGER SO
WHO WHO ON THE DMV TEAMS BEEN
ASSIGNED THIS.
WHEREAS THERE'S AN ASSEMBLY LINE
ANSWER TO THE AUDIT YES.
THE THE REST OF THE AUDIT
RECOMMENDATION WAS TO ASSIGN A
DEDICATED TEAM. TO TO ENSURE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF RELY T. BUT
ALSO TO MAKE SURE THAT PROPER
PRIORITIZATION OF FUTURE
PROJECTS AND MY UNDERSTANDING IS
ACTING DIRECTOR WEB IS -- HAS
ASSIGNED ALREADY EIGHT EIGHTEEN
THAT IS PUTTING TOGETHER THE
RESPONSE TO THE TO THE AUDIT.
AND I'M ASSUMING IT IS OUR
EXECUTIVE TEAM -- THEY COUNSEL
THAT WAS JUST REFER.
TO I'VE ASKED HER WHAT IF THEY
PUT A PLANNING DOCUMENT TOGETHER
I DIDN'T ASK -- IT IT IT HAD
BEEN ASSIGNED.
TO I SHOULD SAY TO HOME.
IN TERMS OF ORGANIZATIONAL
[inaudible]
STRUCTURE -- YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS IN TERMS OF HOW
HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU.
PLAN TO HAVE BETTER ALIGNMENT
BETWEEN CENTRAL OFFICE IN THE
FIELD OFFICES.
WHAT WAS THE RECOMMENDATION
THERE?
SO FOR ORGANIZATIONAL STRUCTURE
WE LOOKED AT THE DIVISION AND
THE SPREAD OF THEIR REGIONAL
OFFICES THAT OVERSEE THE FIELD
OFFICES -- AND AS WE SAY IN THE
REPORT.
THERE ARE CONSTRAINTS ON THE
GEOGRAPHICAL LOCATION OF THE
REGIONAL OFFICES AND THEN THE
QUANTITY.
OF REGIONAL OFFICES WITH RESPECT
TO THE FIELD OFFICES THERE'S
EIGHT REGIONS AND OVER A HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIELD OFFICES.
SO -- WE RECOMMEND DMV.
ANALYZE THEIR MAKE UP A FIELD
OFFICES IN AND IN ADDITION TO
REASSESS THE GRADING.
OF FIELD OFFICES TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY HAVE THE ADEQUATE
LEVEL OF SUPPORT -- BUT THE
OVERALL I I GUESS JUST A STEP
BACK I UNDERSTAND YOUR HONOR WAS
WAS VERY SPECIFIC RIGHT TO STEP
BACK TO THE OVERALL PICTURE.
YOU PAINTED WAS AN AGENCY
SOMEWHAT UNDER SIEGE FROM FOR
LACK OF FOR LACK OF A BETTER
WORD.
AN ORGANIZATION THAT IS SORT OF
ON THE ASSEMBLY LINE JUST DOING
TO INSPECT EVERY DAY BUT DOESN'T
STOP AND ACTUAL PLAN AND
IMPLEMENT -- DIRECTIVES ORDERS A
STEP BACK AND ACTUALLY THINK
ABOUT KIND OF WATER WHAT WE KNOW.
NOW WHAT I HAVE TO DO TODAY BUT
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT ARE SOME OF
THE BIG THINGS COMING DOWN THE
PIKE.
SO HOW DO YOU GET AN
ORGANIZATION LIKE THAT TO
ACTUALLY.
STOP NOT JUST TO WORK EVERY DAY
BUT ACTUALLY.
SIT BACK AND PLAN.
WHAT I THINK IT GOES BACK TO THE
LEADERSHIP THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER IS THAT IF THEY HAVE A
STRONG LEADERSHIP -- GUIDING
THEM THROUGH WHATEVER. THREE
THIS AND THEIR VISION -- SO.
THERE WAS A DISCONNECT BETWEEN
THE SACRAMENTO HEADQUARTERS AND
THE FIELD OFFICES AND SO WE
RECOMMENDED IN OUR REPORT HAT
THERE BE A BETTER.
ALIGNMENT OF COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN THOSE.
TWO MANY PEOPLE ARE IN THE
SACRAMENT HEADQUARTERS.
I DO NOT HAVE THAT NUMBER
APPROXIMATELY.
I MEAN I GUESS THREE THOUSAND I
I DON'T I REALLY DON'T HAVE THAT
NUMBER EITHER.
IN IN OF THE THREE THOUSAND HE
SAID THERE'S A LEADERSHIP VACUUM
ON AND THE GOVERNMENT'S VACUUM
AS WELL.
AND HOW MANY PEOPLE AT THE TOP
OR ARE ARE THERE.
PARDON HOW MANY PEOPLE AT THE
TOP AND CERTAINLY THE NAP LEVY
DIRECTOR BILL ROUGHLY LIKE WHAT.
SIXTEEN TWENTY EXCELLENT LATEST
CHANGED SINCE WE'VE BEEN THERE.
LIKE WHAT TWELVE I BELIEVE
THERE'S EIGHT DIVISIONS AND SO
BE AS MUCH OF IT BUT YOU HAVE A
TEN YEAH RIGHT AND THEN THERE'S
SOME ADDITIONAL DIRECT REPORTS
INTO THE THE DIRECTOR'S OFFICE
LIKE PUBLIC AFFAIRS AND SO FORTH.
SO IT'S WE HAVE A COUPLE
VACANCIES I KNOW THAT RIGHT.
BUT WITHIN THEIR THEY'RE STILL.
TWO THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY FIVE PEOPLE WHO ARE STILL
THERE [inaudible]
SO HOW.
HOW DO YOU HAVE THE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN DISCONNECTED FROM THE
FIELD OFFICES AND RECONNECT THEM?
YOUR YOUR AND YOUR ANSWERED
EVERYTHING IS IS.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT I REALLY --
THE CAPTAIN OF THE SHIP HAS TO
RUN THE SHIP AND IF AT RISK IF
OF RUNS AGROUND IT'S THE
CAPTAIN'S CAPTAINS
RESPONSIBILITY RIGHT WHICH IS
WHICH IS WHY MY MY POINT IS IT'S
HARD TO DO IT. 25% BUDGET
AUGMENTATION WHEN THERE'S NOT
CLEAR LEADERSHIP.
NOT CLEAR RESPONSIBILITY.
NOT CLEAR BENCHMARKS NOT CLEAR
GUIDELINES NOT CLEAR TIMELINE
IT'S NOT CLEAR.
RIGHT THIS IS I MEAN THIS IS NOT
UP POLICY COMMITTEE THIS IS
BUDGET COMMITTEE.
IN A BUDGET COMMITTEE WE PREFER
TO DO THINGS AND DATA.
AND WHAT I HEARD TODAY WAS A LOT
OF TALK BUT NOT A LOT OF DATA
[inaudible]
OR FAX.
SO I MADE TO THE TOM EXCUSE THE
THE HONORS BECAUSE WE'LL GET TO
THE NEXT PART.
BUT BID WHAT CAN REALLY
APPRECIATE.
AUDIT I MEAN I THINK I THINK THE
ON IT WAS VERY VERY WELL DONE
VERY THOROUGH REALLY APPRECIATE.
YOUR YOUR JOB I KNOW -- THE
QUESTIONS THAT ARE BEING.
HOUSE YOU ARE YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
ARE NOT IN THE BUSINESS OF
COMPLETING ABLE TO ANSWER ALL OF
THEM BUT HAVING SAID THAT I
THINK.
THE AUDIT PAINTS A VERY CLEAR
PICTURE OF THE DEFICIENCIES.
I THINK WHAT'S WHAT'S NOT CLEAR
IS.
WHO'S GOING.
TO AGAIN BE ACCOUNTABLE. TO
CORRECT THEM.
AND WHO DO WE HAVE CONFIDENCE
AND TO APPROPRIATE THE RESOURCES
AND GIVE THE UNIVERSE.
WHO WHO WHO'S GONNA BE THERE TO
RESTORE THE PUBLIC TRUST?
SO THANK YOU THANK YOU WHAT
WE'RE GONNA PANEL THREE NOW
[inaudible]
IN -- NOT.
OKAY THANK YOU AS A TRAVESTY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR FREEDOM BY
DIRECT WEB YOU CAN FEEL FREE TO
BEGIN OR SECRETARY PATRICK.
SO -- GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- AGAIN CAPPING WEB
ACTING DIRECTOR IN I WOULD POSE
A QUESTION I CAN GO INTO HIGH
LEVEL SUMMARY UNLESS YOU WOULD
LIKE TO GO INTO QUESTIONS ON THE
ESSENCE OF TIME.
YOU CAN DO A VERY.
HIGH LEVEL SUMMARY YOU WISH ALL
RIGHT.
SO FOR THE CURRENT YEAR TO
REQUESTS HAVE BEEN SUBMITTED TO
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE PERSON TO PERSON TO OF
THE BUDGET ACT.
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO AUGMENT
DMV'S FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET -- THAT
AMOUNT IS FORTY SIX POINT FOUR
MILLION TO PREVENT INCREASED
WAIT TIMES AND REALLY ADDRESS
IMMEDIATELY THE REAL ID DEMANDS
THAT WE HAVE.
THE THORNY WOULD FUND CURRY
ACOSTA SAYS THEY WITH INCREASED
HOURS OF OPERATION OVER TIME
INCREASED PERMANENT PI HOURS.
USE OF RETIRED ANNUITANTS THE
STAFF BORROWED FROM OTHER
DEPARTMENTS AND STAFF TRAINING.
THIS FUND.
THIS WILL ALSO FROM THE EARLY
HIRING OF TRADING THREE HUNDRED
ADDITIONAL TRUMP TEMPORARY
POSITIONS BEEN REQUESTED IN THE
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET -- ALONG
WITH THE EARLY HIRING TV IS
REQUESTING A MILLION DOLLARS IN
CURRENT YEAR FOR AN INSERVICE
TRAINING DAY WHICH IS ESSENTIAL
TO BASICALLY BASELINE AND
EVERYBODY ON THE SAME PAGE WITH
OUR SIMPLE MANY REAL ID -- AND
IS ALSO BASED ON RECOMMENDATIONS
IN COORDINATION WITH THE COVER
UPS RIGHT TEAM.
THIS WILL BE CRITICAL TO ENSURE
I THINK THAT CONSISTED OF
DELIVERY THAT YOU'VE BEEN ALL
TALKING ABOUT THE BUDGET YOUR
TOTAL REQUEST.
IS FOR TWENTY TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE POINT NINE MILLION TO FUND
A HUNDRED SEVENTY POINT EIGHT
PERMANENT.
ADDRESS SHORT TERM CHALLENGES
ALONG WITH LONG TERM OPERATIONAL
IMPROVEMENTS.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
BOUNCES IMMEDIATE NEEDS FOR
TEMPORARY RESOURCES TO ADDRESS
REAL ID.
WITH THE AVAILABLE RESOURCES BUT
ALSO -- REALLY ADDRESSING WHAT I
CALL SYSTEMIC -- AND
INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUES THAT WE
HAVE TO ADDRESS AT DMV.
IN RESPONSE TO THE OFF THE STATE
ALSO VALUATIONS PERFORMANCE
REVIEW -- AND THE GOV UP TO YOU
THE DMV REINVENTION TEAM THE
PROPOSAL INCLUDES FUNDING FOR
THE NUMBER OF LONG TERM PROGRAMS
THAT WILL TRANSFORM DMV FOR THE
BETTER.
THESE NEED A CUSTOMER FOR WAS
WILL INCLUDE ACCEPTING CREDIT
CARD PAYMENTS THE FIELD OFFICES
OFFICES WHICH WILL MAKE
TRANSACTIONS FASTER AND EASIER.
ALSO INCLUDES PASSING ON THE
CREDIT CARD TRANSACTION FEES TO
THE CUSTOMER SIMILAR TO THE
EMPLOYEE DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD WHICH
WILL REDUCE OVERALL EXPENDITURES
FOR THE DMV.
AND GENERATE BUDGETARY SAVINGS
OF A HUNDRED FOURTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE MOTOR VEHICLE
COUNT FOR OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS.
THE REDESIGN IS STREAMLINING OF
THE DMV'S WEBSITE IS REALLY
ESSENTIAL AND WILL MAKE IT
EASIER TO COMPLETE TRACK
TRANSACTIONS ONLINE REDUCE
UNNECESSARY.
FIELD OFFICE VISITS -- INCLUSIVE
IN THE REQUESTED SOMETHING AS
SIMPLE AS AN EMAIL ADDRESS FOR
CUSTOMERS TO MAKE ENQUIRIES
SOMETHING YOU WOULD THINK WE
COULD DO ALREADY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
BUT WILL ALSO REQUIRE RESOURCES
FOR D. V. TO APPROPRIATELY STAFF
AND READ AND BE RESPONSIVE.
TO THE PROPOSAL ALSO FUND A
NUMBER OF OPERATIONAL
IMPROVEMENTS BESIDES TRAINING
INCREASE RANCH REGIONAL MAN FROM
PROVIDER SIDE OF THE FIELD
OFFICE OPERATIONS TO MONITOR
PERFORMANCE ENSURE THE TRAINEES
IMPLEMENTED CONSISTENTLY.
WE ALSO WANT TO BRING AID --
CONSULTANT DMV TO ADDRESS THE
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE DESPERATELY
NEEDED AT DMV AND TO LOOK FOR
WAYS TO BETTER CORDY AND MANAGE
RESOURCES ACROSS THE
ORGANIZATION.
MY GOAL ALSO WITH REGARD TO THIS
REQUEST IS TO ESTABLISH A
PERFORMANCE OF MANAGEMENT
ENVIRONMENT.
THAT INCLUDES KEY PERFORMANCE
INDICATORS THERE ARE TIED TO
STRATEGIC PLANS AND THE
OPERATING GOALS THAT WE ARE
TRYING TO ACHIEVE -- IN ADDITION
WE ARE SEEKING A MILLION DOLLARS
FOR A VENDOR TO HELP REDESIGN IS
STREAMLINED THE DMV FIELD OFFICE
FOR THE FUTURE WE THEN WOULD
CONDUCT A FIELD OFFICE THE PILOT
THAT DMV OFFICE OF THE FUTURE.
AS DISCUSSED PREVIOUSLY PLANS TO
EXPAND TRANSACTIONS THAT
CUSTOMERS COMPLETE ON ITS
WEBSITE CIVIL SERVICE TERMINAL
HE ALSO CUSTOMERS DO NOT NEED TO
VISIT A FIELD OFFICE.
AT THE REQUEST ALSO PROVIDES FOR
CRITICAL INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
IMPROVEMENTS INCLUDING
REPLACEMENT OF OUTDATED
UNRELIABLE HARDWARE.
SUCH AS TERMINAL SERVICES
CIRCUITS AND EXPANDED NETWORK
REDUNDANCIES TO STABILIZE OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE.
I'M DIEM FOR THE DMV BELIEVES
THE CUSTOMER OUT REGION
EDUCATION IS A KEY COMPONENT I
KNOW I'M RUNNING OUT OF TIME.
RIPPLES INCLUDES NINE POINT FIVE
MILLION FOR COMMUNICATION
CAMPAIGN FOR VARIOUS MEDIA
CHANNELS AIMED AT REDUCING WAIT
TIMES TO BETTER PERFORM AND
INFORM THE PUBLIC -- I THINK THE
END OF THE DAY I JUST WANT TO
REASSURE HER THAT THERE ARE SOME
SHORT TERM NEEDS ABSOLUTELY NEED
TO ADDRESSED TO ADDRESS REAL ID
BUT THERE ARE TRULY SOME LONG
TERM SYSTEMIC AND INFRASTRUCTURE
ISSUES THAT WERE ALSO ADDRESSING.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
BRIEFLY SINCE THIS IS THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT LIKE TO ADDRESS --
A NUMBERS ISSUE THE AGENDA DOES
SAY TWO AND FORTY TWO AND THAT
IS THE TOTAL ASK WITH AND BE A
THE TWO TWENTY FIVE THE DIRECTOR.
REFERENCE IS ALSO ACCURATE WHEN
YOU TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
REDUCTION FROM OTHER FUNDS
RELATED TO PASSING FOR THE
CREDIT CARD.
FEES SO IT THERE ARE MANY
NUMBERS AROUND THE SUPPOSED
DEPENDING ON WHICH ASPECT YOU
ARE LOOKING AT THANK.
THANK YOU ANYTHING ELSE FROM THE
L..
QUESTION TO THE COMMITTEE.
SO I HAVE A QUESTION WHICH LEADS
OVER FROM FROM THE THE PRIOR
PANEL AND AND NOW WITH ACTING
DIRECTOR AND AND THE HEAD OF THE
STRIKE TEAM HERE.
NO I THE ENVIRONMENT I COME FROM
IS PUBLIC EDUCATION SENATE SERVE
NINE YEARS ON THE SCHOOL BOARD.
AND OVER THE LAST DECADE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS HAVE HONORED UNDERGONE
TREMENDOUS STATE MANDATED
TRANSFORMATION WE'VE GONE ON TO
A NEW COMMON CORE SET OF
STANDARDS WE'VE IMPLEMENTED
SMARTER BALANCED ASSESSMENT
TESTING WHICH MEANT THAT EVERY
STUDENT HAD TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
PIECE OF TECHNOLOGY IN THEIR
HAND IN ORDER. TO BE ABLE TO DO
THOSE ASSESSMENTS IN A VERY
SHORT TIME WINDOW THAT WAS
PROVIDED. TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
DISTRICTS ROSE TO THAT CHALLENGE
IN A DIMINISHED FUNDING
ENVIRONMENT RIGHT THERE THERE IS
NOT ENOUGH SCHOOL FUNDING TO
REALLY RESOURCE WHAT ALL OF THE
NEEDS ARE.
AND SO I'M LEFT AT THE END OF
THESE THREE PANELS CONVERSATION
SAYING IS THE LEADERSHIP CHANGE
THAT'S NEEDED.
A DEVOLVING A DMB LEADERSHIP TO
THE LOCAL LEVEL.
DOES IT MAKE MORE SENSE AT THIS
POINT TO SHIFT THIS
RESPONSIBILITY TO LOCAL
LEADERSHIP AND INSTITUTIONS
WHERE THERE'S A DIRECT
RELATIONSHIP TO THE CONSTITUENTS
BEING SERVED AND THEREFORE A
REAL TIME NEED TO ACTUALLY MAKE
THESE CHANGES HAPPEN.
BECAUSE I AM I JUST BEING HERE
IN FEW HOURS THAT I'VE BEEN HERE
TODAY IN THE FEW MONTHS THAT
I'VE BEEN IN THE CAPITAL THE DMV
IS MY SINGLE BIGGEST FRUSTRATION
AND I'M A PROBLEM SOLVER.
AND I'M STILL NOT HEARING A
COUPLE OF HOURS IN HOW WE'RE
GOING TO SOLVE THIS I HEAR A RE
FRAMING OF WHAT THE ISSUES ARE
BUT I AM NOT HEARING A ROAD MAP
FOR HOW WE FIX IT.
AND IN MANY CASES WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT GOOD GOVERNMENT
SERVICE THE BEST.
MODEL TO PROVIDE THAT.
IS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SO SHARE TO
ME YOUR CONCEPT OF WHAT THE NEW.
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE LOOKS LIKE
BECAUSE I WANT SOME MEASURE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY IN MY DISTRICT
THAT I CAN GO TO DIRECTLY NOW TO
GET THESE QUESTIONS ANSWERED --
YOUR READERS THAT FROM NOW ON
YOU MAY HAVE SOME THOUGHTS YOU
WANT TO SHARE.
I'M.
SO.
GREAT QUESTION IN ONE OF THESE I
WILL TELL YOU THAT -- IF YOU'RE
FAMILIAR WITH IT I AM A BIG
ADVOCATE OF WHAT THEY CALL THE
BALANCED SCORECARD IT SOUNDS
LIKE THE SCHOOLS WERE ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENTING SOMETHING ALONG
THOSE LINES -- AND WHEN YOU LOOK
AT ANY ORGANIZATION YOU HAVE TO
LOOK AT WHO ARE YOUR CUSTOMERS
ONE OF THE PRIMARY GOALS FOR
SERVING YOUR CUSTOMERS AND ONE
OF THE METRICS YOU NEED TO BE
PUTTING IN PLACE.
AND THEN YOU NEED TO LOOK AT THE
STRUCTURE TO ENSURE YOU HAVE
WHAT I CALL HORIZONTAL --
ENTERPRISE FOCUS OF HOW RICH
EVEN BECAUSE ONE IS I FIND
INTERESTING AND GOVERNMENT.
IS THE PROGRAMS GET GOING BUT
THERE IS SOMETIMES AND THEY
DON'T FEEL LIKE THEY'RE ACTUALLY
ON IT ON THE SAME TEAM TOGETHER
A PART OF WHAT I NEED TO DO IS
AT DMV IS MAKE SURE THERE'S A
CLEAR UNDERSTANDING.
OF OUR MISSION OUR VISION OUR
CUSTOMERS THE GOALS WERE ALL
TRYING TO ACHIEVE THE ROLE THAT
EVERYBODY HAS BEEN ALIGNED WITH
THE WHOLE EVEN THOUGH THEY MAY.
HAVE AN ADMINISTRATIVE
RESPONSIBILITY -- FACILITIES MAN
FOR SOUNDS LIKE HOW DO THOSE
GOALS ALIGNED WITH ACTUALLY
DELIVERING SERVICE TO OUR
CUSTOMERS.
BUT IT ALL STARTS WITH A STRONG
ENTERPRISE GOVERNANCE TEAM AND
SO THAT WOULD BE THE EXECUTIVES
THE DEPUTIES ALL LINED AND
MEASURING AND HOLDING EACH OTHER
ACCOUNTABLE.
BECAUSE I ALSO THINK IT'S
HOLDING EACH OTHER ACCOUNTABLE
TO ACHIEVING THE GOALS BUT I
THINK EVEN MOST IMPORTANTLY
YOU'VE ALL STRESSES AND I I
COMPLETELY AGREE IN I KNOW
SECRETARY AGREES AS WELL.
AS WE DO NEED TO PUT OUT A
PERFORMANCE MANAGER REPORT NOW I
I KNOW THAT WE'VE BEEN PUTTING
OUT A REPORT ON A MONTHLY BASIS --
THAT TALKS ABOUT THE INITIAL
WAIT TIMES AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
I WOULD OFFER AND I'VE TALKED TO
SOME OF THE BUDGET STAFF THAT WE
RE VISIT THE REPORT THAT WE GIVE
TO YOU ON A MONTHLY BASIS.
AND THAT WE AGREED TO ONE OF THE
KEY PERFORMANCE MEASURES THAT WE
NEED TO BE FOCUSED ON TO ADDRESS
THE MOST PRESSING ISSUES.
BUT ALSO ASSURE YOU GOOD
STEWARDSHIP OF THE FUNDS THAT
YOU WERE ACTUALLY.
GIVING TO US I OFTENTIMES TELL
MY STAFF TO THOSE WHO ARE GIVEN
MUCH MUCH IS EXPECTED.
AND I THINK YOU HAVE A FAIR FAIR
REQUEST TO EXPECT US TO REPORT
TO YOU -- ON THOSE EFFORTS --
WHAT I WILL TELL YOU IT'S A
CULTURE THAT'S EXISTED FOR A
LONG PERIOD TIME IN THE WAY THAT
ARE CURRENTLY OPERATES?
SO WHAT I DO AND WHAT WE GO IN
WITH THE GOV UP STRIKE TEAM
ISN'T GOING TO JUST TURN IT
AROUND ON A DIME THERE'S GOING
TO HAVE TO BE A FULL EFFORT THAT
ADDRESS WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
THE DRESS IS BUSINESS PROCESS
DEVELOPMENT.
DRESSES TECHNOLOGY
TRANSFORMATION IN ADDITION TO
REALLY KIND OF THINKING ABOUT
WHAT IS THE BUSINESS MODEL FOR
THE DMV GOING FORWARD.
I DON'T KNOW IF INCORPORATES
WHAT YOU'VE BROUGHT UP.
BUT I THINK THERE'S SOME GOOD
DISCUSSIONS WE CAN HAVE IS WHAT
IS THE RIGHT BUSINESS MODEL FOR
DMV IN CALIFORNIA ON A GO
FORWARD BASIS.
SECRETARY VETERAN DON'T KNOW IF
YOU WANT NO I I I AGREE WITH
WHAT YOU'VE SAID AND I ALSO
AGREE MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THAT -- METRICS AND AND SOME
BENCHMARKS ARE EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AND NEEDED -- WE WE
HAVE BEEN LOOKING AT A LARGER
ORGANIZATIONAL AND REVIEW AT THE
STRIKE TEAM WE HAVE LEFT
OPERATIONAL STATISTICS -- TO WE
KNEW THEY ON IT WOULD BE --
FORTHCOMING ON THOSE THINGS AS
WELL AS THE DMV BUT I DO AGREE
THAT METRICS ARE IN VERY
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND WILL
COME FORTH WITH THEM WITH THE
METRICS THAT WE NEED.
ON THE GOVERNANCE.
STRUCTURE BOTH BOTH SPECIFIC IN
CERTAIN AREAS OF DMV THE I. T.
AREA IN PARTICULAR.
AS WELL AS THE OVER ALL
EXECUTIVE TEAM I'M IS LACKING
AND HAS BEEN LACKING -- I CAN'T
ADDRESS THE REASONS AS TO WHY --
BUT WE HAVE TO ADDRESS GOING
FORWARD -- FIXING THOSE THINGS
AND HAVING THE RIGHT LEADERSHIP
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AS WE
HAVE STATED.
AS WELL AS THE RIGHT STRUCTURE
THAT INDEED DOES TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THOSE FIELD
OFFICES ARE CRITICAL THEY ARE.
SMALL LITTLE CITIES AND TO
THEMSELVES DO THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT STRUCTURE AS I THINK
ACTING DIRECTOR WEB SAID EARLIER.
ALL OF THE FIELD OFFICES ARE
EXTREMELY DIFFERENT AND WHEN
THEY'VE BEEN BUILT I MEAN THE
PHIL OFFICE IN SAN FRANCISCO IS
EXTREMELY DIFFERENT THEN THE
DALY CITY.
THEN -- AND THOSE THAT ARE IT
MORE MODERNIZED AND THEY THEY
LACK TRAINING ROOMS THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN STUDIED IN TERMS OF THE
MOVEMENT OF PEOPLE THROUGH THEM --
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
WE'VE.
BEEN WORKING WITH MACKENZIE ON
IS HOW DO YOU AND OPERATE WITHIN
THE SPACE WHEN THE SPACE IS VERY
DIFFERENT YOU HAVE YOU HAVE THE
THE PEOPLE WAITING IN LINE IF
THEY HAVE -- CHAIRS THERE FOR
THEM THEY'RE LITERALLY SITTING
THERE LOOKING AT AT THE
FUNCTIONING OF DMV THE
INEFFICIENCIES BEFORE THEM
WINDOWS OPEN IN SO FOURTH WE
REALLY HAVE TO LOOK AT HOW
PEOPLE FLOW THROUGH THESE
OFFICES.
AND ON COME UP WITH A MUCH
BETTER AND MORE EFFICIENT PLAN --
FOR FOR ALL OF THE DMV'S IF YOU
WILL BUT LOCAL -- CONTROL IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND LOCAL
OUR CONCERN IS NATION'S GETTING
THE PROPER TRAINING.
DO WE HAVE THE PROPER AND
STRUCTURE IN TERMS OF HAVE THE
REGION'S ALLOCATED PROPERLY ARE
THEY AS THE AUDIT DONE WELL
INDICATED -- I THINK COLLEEN'S
LOOKING VERY CLOSELY THROUGH THE
THROUGH THAT AND TO THAT -- I
THINK THE AUDIT POINTED OUT WELL
THAT THE THE REGIONS AND THE DM
B. FIELD OFFICES HAVE BEEN
LOOKED AT AND SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY WE ADVANCE GREATLY IN HOW
WE PERFORMED WORK.
HAVE THOSE PROCESSES THAT THEY
PERFORMED IN LIKE THAT AND THOSE
ARE THINGS WE HAVE TO HAVE DONE
NOW.
THE SPEECH IN OURS.
I THINK WHEN SO ONE RECURRING
THEME IN OUR CONVERSATION HAS
BEEN I THINK SOME CONCERN ABOUT.
A LACK OF A CLEAR READ MATH AND
A LACK OF SEEMING LACK OF CLEAR
DELIVER ALSO.
JUST GOING BACK TO I THINK WE
TALKED ABOUT FIVE OR LIKE I'M
TAKING A THAT THERE'S LIKE FIVE
HIGH PRIORITY PROJECTS.
REAL ID OVERALL TECH REMEDIATION
AND REDEVELOPMENT ONLINE CALL
CENTERS AND KIOSK ROLLOUT I
THINK THOSE ARE THE FIVE SO FOR
EACH OF THOSE IS THERE RIGHT NOW
TODAY A DOCUMENTED PROJECT PLAN.
THAT YOU WOULD BE ABLE TO TO
SHARE WITH US FOR EACH OF THOSE
FIVE PROJECTS.
SO WE DO HAVE A PLAN AND I THINK.
WHAT I WOULD OFFER IS I THINK?
WE OWE YOU PROBABLY A MORE
FORMALIZED PLAN AROUND WHAT
WE'RE DOING AND THE TIME ONCE
AROUND THOSE THINGS. FOR EACH OF
THE THINGS THAT YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED I HAVE INDIVIDUAL
PLANS THAT WE'RE WORKING THROUGH --
I THINK IT'S KIND OF BRINGING
THEM INTO PROBABLY A THE DMV
REPORT THAT KINDA HOLISTICALLY
BRINGS THOSE THINGS TOGETHER I'M
NOT I'M FINE WITH THAT AGAIN
CHARTING I LIKE AGAIN CHART
RIGHT.
YEAH I AGREE I CAN SPEAK AT
LEAST TO THE THE ONE OF THE
AREAS AS AN EXAMPLE THE KIOSKS
I'VE MET WITH THE VENDOR THE I.
T. I. -- AND ASKED THEM NOT ONLY
FOR A COMMUNICATIONS PLAN WHICH
THEY HAVE PUT TOGETHER BUT FOR A
REVIEW OF THEIR METHODOLOGY WHAT
HOW DO THEY DECIDE WHERE KIOSKS
GO.
AND REVIEW OF THEIR MEDIA AT
METHODOLOGIES AND A PLAN AS TO
WHERE THEY WOULD PUT THE HUNDRED
THAT WE'VE ASKED FOR AS WELL AS
A PLUS.
ONE HUNDRED THAT WE HOPE TO HAVE
OUT IN THE FIELD -- BY THE END
IS THE END OF THE YEAR AND I
UNDERSTAND COLEEN THAT THEY ARE
PUTTING THAT TOGETHER.
SO -- THAT IS AT AT A PLAN FOR
THE KIOSKS BOTH A RECHECK OF
THEIR METHODOLOGY WHERE BEST TO
WE PLACES CARIASO A REVIEW OF
WHETHERTHEY'RE APPROPRIATE
STILL THAT.
HAVE MORE IN THE IN THE DMV
OFFICES WHICH DRIVE TRAFFIC INTO
THE FIELD OFFICE WHICH IS AGAIN
NOT ONE OF OUR GOALS.
SO THAT IS ONE OF THE PLANS
AROUND ON AROUND THE KIOSKS ERA.
AS AN EXAMPLE.
AND I WON'T SPEAK I'M YEAH I
WANT TO FOR THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
OR THE CHAIR BUT I THINK THAT.
YES I VIçT LIKE VERY CLEAR
PLANS WITH CLEAR.
DELIVERABLES FOR EACH OF THOSE
FIVE I THINK WOULD GO A LONG WAY
TO GETTING PEOPLE COMFORTABLE
WITH.
YOU'RE MAKING ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT OR AT LEAST BEING
ABLE TO TO MAKE AN ASSESSMENT IF
THAT'S APPROPRIATE [inaudible]
THIS FALL.
BUT I JUST.
SOME QUICK QUESTIONS AND SEE
THAT THERE ARE -- THE STATES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE ARE AT
LIVING WITH ID WHAT.
WHAT STATES ARE DOING IT WELL?
CALLING YOU JUST CAME FROM THE
NATIONAL.
YOU KNOW THAT'S A FASCINATING
QUESTION TO ASK -- I THINK I AM
CALLING JUST CAME FROM A
NATIONAL -- ASSOCIATION MEETING
WHERE THIS WAS MUCH TALKED MOTOR
VEHICLE ADMINISTRATORS AROUND
THE COUNTRY.
SO I I'M I'M I'M THEN I'M ALL
YEARS TO TRY TO UNDERSTAND ME
WITH FIFTY DIFFERENT.
STATE FOR THE DIFFERENT DMV'S.
WHO'S DOING IT WELL.
THAT'S A TOUGH QUESTION -- I
I'VE HAD I TRIED AT S. TWO TWO
EASY QUESTIONS YEAH YOU KNOW I
LOVE I LOVE IT AND HAVE A LOT OF
CONTACT WITH THE STATE OF
INDIANA I THINK THAT THEY REALLY
KIND OF WELL.
THEY HAVE AN AS SECRETARY
FACTORS AND ACTING DIRECTOR WHAT.
THEIR PRIMARY GOAL HAS AGAIN.
TO REALLY GET FOLKS OUT DO NOT
COME IF YOU DON'T HAVE TO
THEY'VE DEVELOPED SOME.
A WONDERFUL CONNECTS CENTERS
VERY SIMILAR TO AND I CAPITOL
ONE CAFE.
VERY HIGH TECH SILICON VALLEY
WHERE YOU CAN GO IN THERE IT'S
THIS MAN BY ONE PERSON AND IT'S
GOT KIOSK IN THE WALL AND YOU
COULD YOU KNOW ALL DIFFERENT
TYPES OF TRANSACTIONS SO?
I THINK THEY DO THAT WHILE THEIR
WEBSITE IS FANTASTIC.
I AM I ATTENDED ONE OF THEIR
CONFERENCES ON CALL CENTER IT
SAT CALL CENTER CENTER CITY.
OF WE SHARE THAT WITH OUR
COMMUNICATION PROGRAMS DIVISION
I THINK THAT THEY'VE ALL DONE I
THINK INDIANA HAS DONE A
FANTASTIC JOB.
BUT I ALSO THINK THAT WE LEARN
FROM THE OTHER STATES AS WELL SO
WE'VE GOT OUR FRIENDS IN TEXAS
ARE MANDATORY REAL ID LEARNING
FROM BAD ABOUT.
YOUR VENDORS YOU'RE KIDDING YOU
KNOW YOU'RE QUEUING SYSTEM HAVE
YOU TRIAGE PEOPLE SO I THINK
THAT.
YOU KNOW WE LEARN FROM ALL
DIFFERENT SOURCES BUT FROM MY
PARTICULARLY I THINK INDIANA
DOESN'T VERY WELL.
I I'D ECHO THE THE REVIEW THAT
WE'VE MADE OF DIFFERENT STATES --
AS A STRIKE TEAM INDIANA HAS
DONE SOME SUPERB THINGS YEARS
AGO THEY OFFLOADED IF YOU WILL
THEIR VEHICLE REGISTRATION
OUTSIDE OF FIELD OFFICES SO
THEY'VE MADE SOME STATUTORY
CHANGES TO WHAT IS -- WHAT IS
UTILIZED WHATEVER FIELD OFFICES
UTILIZED FOR THEIR THE OPPOSITE
COOLEY WAS JUST REFERRING TO IS
VERY MUCH A DMB OF THE FUTURE
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE HOPE
TO LOOK AT?
IN AND ARE WITH THE ARE IF TO
THAT WE HAVE ARE PUTTING
TOGETHER AND IT'S A IT'S A
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN D. M. V. THAT
AS SHE DESCRIBED.
YOU HAVE KIOSKS AND IN THE WALL
SERVICES LIKE AN ATM AND EIGHT
ONE PERSON CAN STAFF THIS IT'S
IT IT IT.
IT TODD AND IT LOOKS LIKE
FRANKLY AN APPLE STORE IT'S A
VERY INVITING ENVIRONMENT AND
PEOPLE CAN -- USE IT AT ONE AM
IN THE MORNING A ONE PM IN THE
AFTERNOON SO ARE WE LOOKING.
I GUESS TO MOVE IN THAT
DIRECTION AS WELL ABSOLUTELY SO
AND AND SO THAT IS PART OF THE
DISCUSSION I GUESS AND IN THIS
PLAN THAT WE'RE GONNA GET IS IS
THAT LONG TERM VISION OF OF
THESE KIOSKS AND AND A LOT OF
THEM GUESSING THAT WE DON'T
WOULD.
INDEED ALL THE STE THE EDITION
ALL TEMPORARY STAFF.
AND WE UTILIZING TECHNOLOGY IS
IT MY CORRECT.
WELL AND DOESN'T HAPPEN
OVERNIGHT BUT YES ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THIS STRIKE TEAM IS
LOOKING AT IS NOT ONLY A IN THE
AND I'D LIKE -- TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN SERVICE AND DMV BUT A
WHOLE A WHOLE NEW DESIGN DMV
WHERE -- PEOPLE ARE SERVICED OR
PEOPLE ARE SERVED AND PEOPLE
FLOW THROUGH AN OFFICE IN -- A
MATCH NEW MODERN WAY AND OUR
SERVICE IN TERMS OF HOW HOW HOW
THEY ARE AND EITHER UTILIZING
THE TECHNICIAN HOW THEY'RE
UTILIZING.
THINGS LIKE SELF SERVICE SURE SO
WE HAVE ONE OF THE PROPOSALS IS
INDEED A FOR A R. F. Q. TO HAVE
A VENDOR.
PUT INDEED THAT PLAN TOGETHER --
FOUR EIGHT FUTURE DMV SO SO
WHAT'S YOUR TIME LINE I MEAN I
MEAN THERE THERE ARE VENDORS I'M
SURE THAT COULD GET COULD DO
WHAT THE REGISTRATIONS THAT
COULD DO RENEWAL AS THEY COULD --
YOU COULD WE COULD DO TO YEAR --
LICENSE RENEWALS SO WHERE THE
FOLKS ON THE COME IN EVERY YEAR --
MAIL WHAT IS YOUR TIMELINE AND
MEET THEIR INTEREST RATE
SPECIFICALLY BUT WHAT WE'RE
TALKING FOREVER IN THE FOR THE
GOP I'M AND I THINK YOU HIT THE
STREET NEXT WEEK WELL FOR
EVERYTHING SO THE A MAN GUESSING
YOU'RE GONNA TRIAGE WHAT YOU GOT.
WE ATTEMPTING TO AND THEN YOU'RE
GONNA DO A TIER ONE TIER TWO
TIER TWO PRIORITIES TRYING TO
GET AT SOME POINT.
YOU KNOW I WOULD I THINK THAT
FOR US IN THE LEGISLATURE WE
THINK TO SHORT TERM SO LET'S GO
OUT. TWENTY YEARS AND GO AND
WORK BACKWARDS SO HOW FAST CAN
WE GET THERE AS WE ARE WHAT ARE
THE MILESTONES YOU THAT YOU HAVE
I MEAN I'M I'M JUST TRYING TO
KINDA.
PULL SOME INFORMATION FROM YOU
IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW HOW DO YOU
ENVISION.
AND CHANGING THE DMV MODERNIZING
THE DMV AND HOW FAST CAN WE GET
THERE.
WELL ON WITHTHE PROPOSAL THAT
WE HAVE IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
AND THE APPROPRIATION THAT WERE
ASKING FOR SOME OF THE THINGS IN
TERMS OF THE MODERNIZATION AND
THINGS THAT WE CAN DO.
DEPEND ON OF COURSE THE
RESOURCES WE HAVE -- IN TERMS OF
OF DMB OF THE FUTURE THAT'S
SOMETHING HOPEFULLY THAT WE HAVE
ABSOLUTELY OPPORTUNITIES -- TO
WITH NEW RELEASES COMING DO WITH --
SOME LEGISLATION THAT WAS PASSED
SEVERAL YEARS AGO THAT ALLOWS --
DMV'S TO ACTUALLY CONSIDER I'M
TRANSFERRING AND EXCHANGING LAND
I THINK SAN FRANCISCO IS IS ONE
IN THE LEGISLATION RANCHO
CUCAMONGA.
AND SAN DIEGO AND THAT'S THAT'S
AGAIN -- IN A PLAN THAT WOULD
COULD BE IMPLEMENTED LITERALLY
IN THE IN THE NEXT YEAR.
THERE ARE MANY MORE TIME FRAMES
THAT WEEK WEEK THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING THAT I THINK WE
NOT THE MOST IMPORTANT THAT A
VERY IMPORTANT.
ROAD MAP.
IS WHAT WILL BE DUE AT THE END
OF MAY AND THAT IS A ROADMAP TO
IMPLEMENT THE AUDIT.
AND THAT WILL HAVE MATRIX THAT
WILL HAVE -- TIME FRAMES
BENCHMARKS -- AND THAT WILL BE
DUE AND THE ACTING DIRECTOR WILL
MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S DONE IN A
TIMELY WAY.
IT WOULDN'T AND THAT PLAN THOUGH
IS IS PHASED OVERLAID WITH A
LONG TERM VISION RIGHT I MEAN
IT'S LIKE I'M SURE I'M I'M SURE
MISTER FRAZIER GOOD.
APPRECIATE THIS EXAMPLE WHERE
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE NOTHING
FRUSTRATES MIKE INCISIONS MORE
WHEN THEY WHEN SOMEONE'S TRYING
TO BUILD A ROAD AND AND SO.
THEY THEY BUILD A SIDEWALK.
AND THEY SPENT HUNDREDS OF
THOUSAND DOLLARS A BILL THE
SIDEWALK AND ALL OF A SUDDEN
THEY FIX THE ROADS THE TERROR OF
THE ROAD EDITOR OF THE SIDEWALK
IT IS BUILT IN AND THEN REBUILD
THE WHOLE THING ALL OVER AGAIN.
SO ARE WE YOU KNOW WE GONNA.
PUT OTHERS -- INVESTMENT INTO
THESE INTO THESE ALL THESE
STRUCTURE AND AND IN THESE
BROKEN MORTAR STUFF AND ALL OF A
SUDDEN IN FIVE YEARS YOUR VISION
IS NOT TO HAVE BROKEN WATER
ANYMORE.
IT'S HAT IS AND THEN WE'RE
GONNA MOVE OUT OF THESE
BUILDINGS AND WE'RE GOING TO AND
THEN AND WE'RE TO CREATE THESE
BRAND NEW COOL CHAOS AT THAT
APPLE STORE RELATED AND IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE IN THE BUILDINGS
THAT WE USE AND THEN ALL OF A
SUDDEN.
IT'S NOT YET YOU IS A MAKES AS
WE'RE NOT IT'S NOT LAYERED AND
AND WE ARE IN INDIA THERE'S
SYNERGY.
WE'RE THEY THESE ARE EXAMPLES
CERTAINLY WE'RE NOT GOING. TO TO
REINVENT EVERY DMV OFFICE IN THE
NEXT YEAR OR TWO AND AND AND TEN
YEARS FROM NOW WHEN WE HAVE A
THOMAS VEHICLES AND WE HAVE
FEWER.
PEOPLE DRIVING -- AND AND MAYBE
WE ARE REALLY TURNING THE DMV IN
TWENTY YEARS INTO AN IDEA
AUTHENTICATION -- SHOP AND NOT
NOT SOMETHING THAT DEALS WITH
THE VEHICLES I MEAN THAT THOSE
ARE THINGS WORK.
WE'RE NOT DEALING WITH HERE AND
AND CERTAINLY NOT CONTEMPLATING
IN TERMS OF THE IMMEDIATE PLANS
BUT WE WOULD NEVER WANT.
TO YOUR EXAMPLE OF TEARING UP
THE SPENDING MONEY AND TEARING
SOMETHING UP ONLY -- TO WASTE
THE TAXPAYERS' DOLLARS OBVIOUSLY
NINE APPRECIATE THAT AND I I
THINK THAT MY VERGE OF
QUESTIONING AYE I THINK IT'S A
MEMBER SMITH IS IS CORRECT MAYBE.
THERE IS NEW WHAT THE NEWTON
LOCALIZED -- APPROACHES AND THEN
AND THEN T<c.cyan> GET INTO WHAT</c>
OTHER STATES ARE DOING -- I
THINK IT IT MAKES SENSE TO ME
THAT WE LOOK AT OTHER STATES ARE
DOING IT VERY WELL LEARN FROM
THE STATE'S SAID A FAILED.
BOB WE WOULD I WOULD I WOULD
PROBABLY SAY THAT OUR STATE HAS
STRUGGLED CLEARLY OVER THE
UNDERSTATEMENT OF THE DAY -- IN
TERMS OF A AMPLE NAY WILL ID AND
SELL LET'S NOT RECREATE THE
WHEEL BUT I THINK I SHARE AS AS
YOU SAID EARLIER I I SHARE SOME
NUMBER ESTIMATES FRUSTRATION --
IN THIS BECAUSE IT DOESN'T HAVE
TO BE THIS WAY.
THANK YOU.
GREAT QUICKNESS FRAZIER.
SO I APPRECIATE US SECRETARY AND
IN THE INTERIM.
RECTOR COMING IN TALKING TO ME
YESTERDAY ABOUT THE VISION OF
GOING FORWARD.
AND AGAIN I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS IT IS.
TROUBLING TO ME IS. FOR LOCAL
SEVEN YEARS THAT I'VE.
NOWBEEN HERE -- IN FOUR YEARS
IS THE CHAIR OF TRANSPORTATION --
I'VE HAD THIS EXPECTATION THAT
WE'D HAVE RESULTS.
AND I'VE BEEN TOLD OVER OVER
OVER WE THROWING MONEY AT IT --
PROMISES MADE WERE NEVER
PROMISES KEPT [inaudible]
AND SO [inaudible]
I'M [inaudible]
APPREHENSIVE ABOUT.
THIS AGENCY BECAUSE OF THE
REPUTATION IN THE PAST.
NOW I DO.
HAVE SOME RENEWED -- EXCITEMENT
BECAUSE OF WHAT YOU'VE SHARED
WITH ME YESTERDAY AND WHAT
YOU'VE OBVIOUSLY SHARED WITH
THIS COMMITTEE TODAY -- I'D
APPRECIATE THE THE GOVERNOR
PUTTING.
YOU IN THIS PLACE -- LONG
OVERDUE -- BUT UNITE.
WE TALKED ABOUT CULTURE
YESTERDAY ALSO.
BROWN ALL CULTURE -- AND THE
EXPECTATION OF THE PUBLIC.
AND I THINK MISTER PATTERSON WAS
KIND OF SPOT ON WE TALKED ABOUT
THE THE ABILITY TO SAY YOU KNOW
WHAT.
WHEN I MAKE AN APPOINTMENT WITH
A TNT?
THEY TELL ME BETWEEN EIGHT AND
TWELVE AND THEY USUALLY SHOW UP
AT TWELVE OKAY SO.
MAKING.
A GOOD FAITH EFFORT I THINK IS
IS AN HONORABLE THING.
REASONABLE EXPECTATIONS HAVE TO
BE IMPLEMENTED -- BUT WE ALSO
TALKED ABOUT CROSS TRAINING OF
STAFF I DON'T WANT AN EMPTY WHEN.
IF SOMEBODY CALLS IN SICK I WANT
SOMEBODY TO BE ABLE TO MAN THAT.
OR WOMAN THAT THAT WINDOW SO
THAT WE CAN HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO PROVIDE EVERY TRANSACTION YOU
TALKED ABOUT MOBILE POP UPS --
RIGHT NOW WE DON'T HAVE CAPACITY
FOR TRANSACTIONS PEOPLE WAITING
LINE WE CLOSED IF YOU ARE I
DON'T REMEMBER THE NUMBER BUT WE
CLOSE SOME DMV'S.
A IN THE PAST.
I DON'T THINK IT WAS A LOT BUT
THERE WERE THERE WERE.
WINDOWS THAT.
WOULD HAVE BEEN CAPACITY.
I WANT TO SEE A BIGGER MOVE
TOWARDS.
ACCOMMODATING IN SOME KIND OF
MODULAR FASHION -- THE RURAL
AREAS -- WHERE YOU HAVE TARGETED --
HABITUAL.
EAST AND YOU KNOW PROBLEMS OF
GETTING PEOPLE SERVICE -- BUT I
THINK ACCOUNTABILITY TO ME IS IS
THE BIGGEST FACTOR IS I DON'T
THINK WE'RE GETTING ENOUGH REAL
TIME INFORMATION BACK -- ON A
REGULAR BASIS NOW THE MONTH
EVERY MONTH NOW HAS BEEN.
YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN A REFRESHING
THING AND I READ THAT REPORT --
AND AGAIN I'M TRYING TO HOLD
BACK BILLS AS YOU ASKED --
BECAUSE OF THE ONEROUS OF
FASHION IT WOULD TAKE TO THE
AGENCY RIGHT NOW -- SO THAT
YOU'RE NOT IMPOUNDED WITH A
BUNCH OF OTHER EXPECTATIONS.
THAT BEING SAID I MEAN.
YOU KNOW I KNOW YOU YOU'RE
ASKING FOR A LOT OF MONEY TO BE
ABLE TO FIX THIS.
AND WE TALKED ABOUT MY
RESPONSIBILITY NOT ONLY IS THE
DMV IS THAT AS THE POLICY CHAIR
BUT I OVERSEE.
THE HOT HIGHWAY PATROL -- T. S.
AND CALTRANS IN MY FASHION.
AND I ASKED FOR A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS LAST YEAR.
FROM THE HIGHWAY PATROL BECAUSE
WE'RE VERY SHORT IN OFFICERS.
WERE THOUSAND OFFICERS DOWN.
WHEN I WAS DENIED IT WAS VETOED?
AND WORD UP 27% AND DEATHS.
SO AT SOME POINT IN TIME WE'VE
GOT TO MAKE.
A DECISION ABOUT PRIORITIES.
I APPRECIATE THAT WE CAN GET AN
ECONOMY OF SCALE WITH A LOT OF
EFFICIENCIES ARE PUT IN PLACE.
BUT I CAN'T SUPPORT ADDITIONAL
MONEY BECAUSE PROMISE AS HAVE
NOT BEEN KEPT UP TO DATE.
MY EXPECTATION IS TO SAVE LIVES.
AT THIS POINT IN TIME AND IF I
CAN DO THAT I SAID OFFICER
KILLED IN RIVERSIDE.
HEY I DON'T HAVE ENOUGH HOW IT
FROZE OFFICERS ON THE ROAD.
IT'S HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
DO THAT SO.
I THINK WE HAVE AN EXPECTATION.
OF OF BALANCE.
BUT YOU KNOW.
AGAIN.
SHOW ME THAT YOU'RE GONNA BE
ABLE TO DO IT AND KEEP IT IN
BECAUSE THIS IS BEEN A REVOLVING
DOOR.
BUT YOU CAN KEEP IT ROLLING.
AND THEN I'M MORE APT TO BE.
LOOKING AT OTHER RESOURCES FOR
REVENUE FOR YOU.
OUTSIDE OF THE NBA OR IN YOUR A
PAST CITY LIKE WE TALKED ABOUT
YESTERDAY YOUR CAPACITY TO RAISE
REVENUE AND OTHER AREAS.
BUT I HAVE SO MANY OTHER NEEDS.
IN THE MBA.
THAT I JUST I CAN'T SEE THIS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IT'S NOT FOR
ME.
AND AND I APPRECIATE.
THE WILLINGNESS TO BRING THIS
BACK IN THIS DISCUSSION.
YOU'VE OF ALL.
YOU OF THE VAULT AND YOU'VE
TAKEN THIS AGENCY TO ANOTHER
PLACE IT.
I THINK IT CAN BE SUCCESSFUL.
BUT I'M ALWAYS AFRAID OF THAT
AGGRESSION -- DIGRESS IS.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER.
PETRIE-NORRIS IS IT ONE QUICK
QUESTION I'M I THINK.
THAT MR FONG BRIEFLY TOUCHED ON
IT BUT THERE WAS AN ARTICLE
TODAY IN THE LA TIMES ONLINE THE
MOTOR VOTER.
ROLLOUT.
I HAVEN'T WHEN DID YOU SEE IT IF
YOU HAD ANY REACTIONS TO THAT
ARTICLE IF YOU'D LIKE TO COMMENT
ON AND SOME OF THOSE FINDINGS
[inaudible]
WELL.
FIRST I WILL ASSURE YOU THAT A
DV WE TAKE THE MOTOR VOTER
RESPONSIBLE IN GETTING IT RIGHT
VERY SERIOUSLY WE ARE COMMITTED
TO IT.
I WILL ALSO TELL YOU THAT WE
HAVE -- BEEN IN CONSTANT
CONVERSATION THE SECRETARY OF
STATE TO IMPROVE THE PROCESS WE
MEET ON A WEEKLY BASIS.
WITH A SEPARATE STATE TO LOOK AT
HIM PROCESS IMPROVEMENTS TO MAKE
SURE WE'RE GETTING RECORDS OVER
TO THEM THAT THEY CAN ACTUALLY
HANDLE.
I THINK THE OTHER THING THAT'S
GOING TO BE HAPPY -- HELPFUL IS --
ERNST AND YOUNG AUDIT THAT WAS
COMMISSIONED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE -- AND SO I'M LOOKING
FORWARD RECEIVING THAT AUDIT
THERE ARE STILL IN OUR OFFICE
RIGHT NOW DOING SOME ASSESSMENTS.
BUT I THINK ALL OF THAT COMING
TOGETHER.
WILL BE VERY HELPFUL MAKE SOME
DECISIONS GOING FORWARD I I
ANTICIPATE SOME OF THE FINDINGS
MAY NOT BE DIFFERENT THAN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AUDIT
EITHER.
I DO FIRMLY BELIEVE GOVERNANCE
IS A REALLY IMPORTANT PIECE I
KNOW WE'VE REPEATED THAT ON
NUMEROUS OCCASIONS.
BUT I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT ANY
HEALTHY ORGANIZATION AND ANY
PRIVATE SECTOR ORGANIZATION NON
PROFIT OR EVEN IN THE STATE.
IT USUALLY STARTS WITH A REALLY
COOL IT'S STRONG ENTERPRISE
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE AT THE TOP.
AND IT'S IT DEALS WITH THE
BREAKING DOWN OF SILENCE DMV IS
A RICH IN SILOS.
AND WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO IS
BREAK DOWN THOSE SILOS SO THERE
THAT ACTIVITY IN EFFORTS THAT
ARE.
BEING ADDRESSED -- AND THAT'S A
CULTURAL CHANGE -- BY THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRESHER AND
ADDRESS THE CULTURE PEAS AND AND
THE MORALE AND AND AND FOLKS ARE
FULLY LITTLE BEATEN DOWN AND
TRYING TO DO BUT THE BEST THEY
CAN WITH THE RESOURCES THEY HAVE --
AND AND WHAT I NEED TO DO AND
AND MY KIND OF MY MESSAGE TO
PEOPLE IS I WANT TO MOVE.
FROM MAINTAINING OUR
GRANDPARENTS DMV TO CREATING OUR
CHILDREN STAMPING AND I BECAUSE
THEY ALL KNOW THEIR CHILDREN
WOULD NOT LIKE GOING INTO THE
DMV THAT EXISTS TODAY.
BUT WE ALL COLLECTIVELY
COLLECTIVELY HAVE TO BE ON THAT
ROAD TOGETHER AND I REALLY LIKE
THE IDEA OF KIND OF A VISIONING
SESSION THAT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
JUST US BY OURSELVES.
BUT WHAT DOES THE FUTURE DMV
LOOK LIKE IN INDIANA CERTAINLY
IS A MODEL FOR US TO TAKE A LOOK
AT ON THE MOTOR VOTER AND
GETTING BACK TO THAT PIECE -- I
WOULD TELL YOU THERE'S BEEN
GREAT PROGRESS -- SINCE THE THE
RESEARCH ASSOCIATE WITH THAT
ARTICLE -- WE DO HAVE A
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE IN PLACE --
ONE THINGS I AM PUTTING TOGETHER
IS A MOTOR VOTER PROGRAM IT'S
NOT A PROJECT THE TV IT'S A
PROGRAM.
AND WE NEED A STAFF AND AS A
PROGRAMMER APPROPRIATELY IT
TOUCHES MANY OF OUR PROGRAM
AREAS AND SO I'M WORKING THROUGH
ESTABLISHING REALLY THAT
PERMANENT PROGRAM UNDERSTAND THE
F. T. EASE THE AND THE P. WISE
THAT WOULD BE NECESSARY TO GO
HEAD SUPPORT THAT PROGRAMMING ON
A GO FORWARD.
BASIS IT HAS BEEN A RESOURCE
DEMAND.
BUT I ALSO SAY THAT WE HAVEN'T
BEEN AS EFFICIENT AS WE COULD BE
AND HOW HE MANAGE IT SO WE'RE
ALSO.
DOING A LOT OF PROCESS
IMPROVEMENT AND NUMBER THE AREAS
AROUND A MOTOR VOTER.
SO DO YOU THINK ANY FURTHER
INQUIRY.
WOULD BE WARRANTED KIND OF BASED
ON SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT THAT
ARTICLE POINTED TO OR DO YOU
FEEL LIKE THAT IS ALREADY UNDER
WAY.
I THINK THE ERNST AND YOUNG --
ASSESSMENT WILL BE REVEALING TO
WHAT THEY FOUND AND THEN I THINK
THIS BODY CERTAINLY HAS ABILITY
TO MAKE A DETERMINATION GOING
FORWARD OKAY SO PRINCETON YOUNG.
DVD BUT IT [inaudible]
THIS PAST.
I DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS BENEFIT
DRESSED -- HAS ANYBODY ASKED.
WHAT IS YOUR VISION FOR THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY DMB?
IF YOU COULD DO THE ETCH A
SKETCH TURN THE MISTAKES UPSIDE
DOWN.
AND DESIGN THE DMV OF THE FUTURE.
DO YOU HAVE A SENSE OF WHAT IT
WOULD LOOK LIKE.
WELL AND AS YOU AND I THINK
DISCUSSED YESTERDAY WE TALKED A
LITTLE BIT EARLIER ABOUT -- SOME
OF THE IDEAS AROUND -- THE IDEA
AND AND SKIS WITH THE DMV OF THE
FUTURE ONE BEING A TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN SELF SERVICE DMV.
BUT NO LINES AND PEOPLE MOVING
FREELY WITH THROUGH AN OFFICE IN
A STREAMLINED MANNER -- WITH
WITH.
UNDERSTANDING OF WHERE -- THEIR
SERVICE WHERE THEY CAN GO TO GET
THE SERVICE THEY NEED IN A VERY.
EASY AND THOUGHTFUL WAY LIKE AN
APPLE STORE -- FOR INSTANCE A
PLEASANT ENVIRONMENT AND
ENVIRONMENT THAT IT'S CLEAN
EFFICIENT -- ONE THAT SERVES
EVERYONE THAT IS THERE TO BE
SERVED IN AN EFFECTIVE WAY AGAIN
YOU MENTIONED AMAZON TYPE OF
SERVICES AND WE TALKED ABOUT AN
APPLE STORE.
WE'VE TALKEDTO I'VE TALKED TO
THE ARCHITECTS ACTUALLY THEY
HAVE DESIGNED THE ORIGINAL
DESIGNERS OF THE APPLE STORE.
I'M HOPING THAT THEY CAN BE
ENGAGED IS AS AS ONE THAT
PERHAPS ANSWERS THEY ARE IF Q..
AND SO THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
SOME OF THE IDEAS THAT WE HAVE
HAD I WISH WE COULD HAVE AN
ACTION AT TO SKETCH AND START
OVER BUT I THINK YOU NOTED --
SIR EARLIER WELL THAT AND THERE
ARE THOUSANDS MILLIONS OF
TRANSACTIONS THAT THE DMV IN ITS
CURRENT STATE HAVE TO CONTINUE
TO DO EVERY DAY WHILE WE ARE
LOOKING.
AND MAKING -- IN REAL TIME
CHANGES NOW BUT STILL LOOKING
FORWARD TO MAKING MORE CHANGES
WE'RE STILL DEALING WITH A VERY
AGED AN UNSTABLE INFRASTRUCTURE
IN THEIR I. T. WE'RE DEALING
WITH.
AND UNDER RESOURCE AND AND
RESOURCE TECHNICIANS IN THE CALL
CENTERS AND INDEED EVEN AT THE
WINDOWS.
AND SO.
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT WE HAVE TO
CONTEND WITH AND DEAL WITH NOW
WELL WE'RE LOOKING AT MAKING
THAT DMV OF THE FUTURE MUCH MORE
EFFECTIVE.
DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS AFTER NOT
BUT IT WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT
WE'RE DOING -- WITH RESPECT TO
THIS BUILDING.
RIGHT WE HAVE TO OPERATE IN IT
AND SO WE'RE BUILDING SOMETHING
OVER THERE.
WE'RE GOING TO BE SERIOUSLY
WE'RE GONNA GO OVER THERE.
YEAH AND THEN.
THIS GETS FIXED I MEAN THE BIG
CHALLENGER TO ME IN THE AND
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT.
IS YOU GOTTA KEEP THE THING
GOING FOR THIS EVEN IF IT IS
HERKY JERKY AND JUST.
AND THEN.
BRING IT DOWN.
AND THEN TURN AROUND AND BRING
UP THE NEW.
ONE WE WERE DOING THAT WITH THIS
BUILDING  CAN YOU DO IT WITH
THE DMV.
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S I LOVE THE
ASPIRATIONAL APPROACH THAT
YOU'VE TAKEN ON AND I THINK I
MENTIONED THAT TO A COUPLE TIMES
I APPRECIATE I DO.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU SO JUST THE ARMY GET
BACK -- TO ISSUES -- BUDGET
REQUEST SO JANUARY OF TWENTY
NINETEEN AS WELL OF MARCH OF
TWENTY NINETEEN YEAH. FORTY
POINT FOUR MILLION REQUEST --
SIX MILLION DOLLAR REQUEST THOSE
REQUESTS WERE NOT APPROVED.
BY JAIL BC A BECAUSE WE WERE
WAITING FOR THIS HEARING.
HAS THAT MONEY BEEN SPENT.
AND THE INITIAL FORTY POINT FOUR
MILLION THAT WHEN THAT REQUEST
WENT OVER AND IN REGARDS TO
WORKING WITH -- THE WAIT TIMES
AND EVERYTHING ALONG THOSE LINES
WHEN THAT REQUEST WENT OVER IN
IN JANUARY WE HAD NOTATED THAT
THERE WAS AT THAT POINT TIME
SEVENTEEN MILLION.
THAT HAVE BEEN SPENT TO DATE AND
THAT THE PROJECTION WAS FROM
JANUARY THROUGH -- JUNE THAT
ANOTHER -- TWENTY TWO MILLION
WAS GOING TO BE SPENT AND SO
WE'RE NOW AT A POINT SINCE WE'RE
IN APRIL YEAH THAT THE MONEY IS
CONTINUING TO GET SPENT.
OKAY SO YOU'RE YOU'RE.
THE MONEY HAS BEEN APPROVED THE
SPENDING AND DEFICIT.
UNFORTUNATELY YES.
SO SO THE THE THE REASON THE
MONEY WAS NOT APPROVED BECAUSE
WE'RE WAITING. FOR THIS HEARING
IN HOPES THAT WE WOULD HEAR --
ONE THE WORK THAT HAD BEEN DONE.
AS WELL AS THE PLAN. FOR THE
FUTURE.
THAT'S WHAT WE GOT IN THIS
HEARING WAS.
THE WAR THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
DONE WHICH DIDN'T GET DONE.
WE DID GET A PLAN FOR THE FUTURE.
I ALWAYS HAVE IS JUST NUMBERS
AND BODIES -- WHERE THESE --
WORK WERE YOU KNOW NUMBERS AND
BODIES AND THAT'S IT.
SO AT THIS POINT I STILL CAN'T.
AUTHORIZE AT LEAST FOR FOR OUR
HOUSE TO APPROVE [inaudible]
THIS MONEY.
SUCH AS THE TECH INTO THE ON THE
JOB IS THE REQUEST AND I'LL --
DEFERRED FINANCE AS WELL IS
OBVIOUSLY THE THE POINT THE
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE WAS TO
ASSIST WITH WAIT TIMES.
AND SO WITH THE JAIL BC THAT WAS
TO BRING THE WAIT TIMES -- BACK
DOWN TO TO AT LEAST WITHIN OUR
GOALS.
RIGHT BUT WE WE JUST DISCUSSED.
THE WAIT TIME INFORMATION YOU
HAVE.
WADE IS NOT ACCURATE.
I SAID ALRIGHT EARLIER YOU PRO
IN THE BACK OF THE ROOM WHEN I
SAID THIS BUT AGAIN I HAVE
PEOPLE THEY GET IN LINE AT FIVE
AM.
AT SIX AM.
THERE ARE THREE HOUR OR FOUR
HOUR WAIT TIME.
IS NOT TAKING INTO ACCOUNT.
CORRECT IN AND I'M FOURTEEN
THERE'S REALLY GONNA BE NO WAY
FOR US TO TO TRACK THAT UNTIL
SOMEONE IN THE OFFICE RIGHT.
YOU YOU YOU HAVE THE DIRECTOR
START OFF BY SAYING WHEN YOU
TALK TO PEOPLE PEOPLE PREFER TO
COME IN FIRST IN THE MORNING
RATHER THAN.
LATER.
SO.
IN ESSENCE MORE PEOPLE COULD BE
COMING IN EARLIER INSTEAD OF
LATER.
THEY COULD JUST BE DECIDING HEY
WE'RE JUST PANEL WAS GONNA GET
THE FIVE AM AGO WAIT INDIA
BECAUSE JUST JUST TO GET IT OVER
WITH -- BUT WE HAVE NO SO WE A
WE DON'T KNOW THE LEVEL OF THE
ACCURACY OF YOUR DATA.
YOUR DATA IS NOT RIPE.
SO THE THE WAIT TIME DATA THAT'S
IN THE MONTH REPORTS THAT WE
SHARE WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
IS DOES TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
QUEUE WAIT TIME WHICH IS WHAT
WE'RE ALL AWARE OF IN REGARDS TO
WIN THE Q. TICKET IS GIVEN.
AND THEN THEY ALSO TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THE THE PRICKLY WAIT
TIME AND SO THAT'S INCORPORATED
ABOUT BUT IT DOES NOT TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS IF
SOMEONE IS WAITING AT THE OFFICE
BEFORE THE OFFICE EVEN OPENS AND
THERE'S NOBODY THERE -- DOES
WAIT TIMES ARE NOT TRACKED.
SO AGAIN -- YOU YOU HAVE DATA
THAT'S NOT ACCURATE.
SO WE ARE.
THAT THE BUDGET WAS CONDITIONAL
UPON.
APPROVAL WE WE CAN'T APPROVE IT.
AT THIS POINT AGAIN -- WE'VE
BEEN ASKING FOR THIS INFORMATION
WE WAITED FOR THE STRIKE TEAM WE
WAITED FOR THE AUTO SO I THINK
WHAT WE DO HAVE IS.
WE HAVE A CLEAR EVALUATION OF
WHAT THE PROBLEMS ARE.
WHAT WE DON'T HAVE IS?
WHAT DO WE DO ABOUT?
SO IF I MAY SO ON A NUMBER OF
ITEMS IN THE IN THE FINANCE
LETTER.
INTO THE FINANCE LETTERS BROKEN
UP INTO SECTIONS AS WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER RIGHT TO THE
TOP SECTION AT THE SOCHI WITH
REAL ID.
THAT'S PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD
OTHER LIKE THAT THE WE JUST
CAN'T WE TALK ABOUT THAT BEFORE
TRANSACTIONS MINUTES.
THE WISE.
BUT THEN ALSO IN THE IN THE
REQUEST IS A LOT OF THE ITEMS
THAT ARE IDENTIFIED PER THE SAY
AUDIT OR PER THE STRIKE TEAM AND
IN THE NARRATIVE OF THE FUNDING
REQUEST ACTUALLY BREAKS OUT ITS
RELATED WHICH I'D RIVER WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE APRIL FINANCE.
NUMBER LETTER YEAH YEAH YEAH I'M
TALKING ABOUT THE JANUARY IN THE
MARCH FINANCE MATTERS.
THE DEAL WITH THE NOTICES.
THE THE WHOLE POINT OF THE JAIL
BC NOTICES WHERE -- PRIMARILY TO
MAINTAIN THE WAIT TIMES AT IT
EXCEPT WHEN I UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEY WERE I'M JUST SAYING THAT.
I DON'T THINK YOU UNDERSTAND
WHAT I'M SAYING.
THOSE LETTERS WERE NOT APPROVED.
THAT APPROPRIATION.
WAS NOT APPROVED.
BECAUSE THERE WAS A LACK OF
FAITH.
IN THE DEPARTMENT TO EXECUTE.
WHAT THEY SAID THEY WERE GOING
TO DO?
NOW WE HAVE AN AUDIT AUDIT THAT
PROVES NOT ONLY.
DID THEY NOT EXECUTED THEY HAVE
A PROBLEM -- THEY THEY THEY SAID
THEY WERE DISAPPOINTED IT DIDN'T
DO.
THE THOUGHT IS VERY CLEAR ON WE
CAN GO BACK AND WE CAN LOOK AT
THE AUGUST TESTIMONY YOU WERE
THERE YOU'RE DOING A FEW PEOPLE
WHO ARE.
SO WE CAN GO BACK AND WE PLAYED
OUT BUT IT'S CLEAR WHAT WAS SAID
WAS NOT.
TO SO AGAIN YOU'RE YOU'RE
RUNNING A DEFICIT NOW BECAUSE
JANUARY AND MARCH THE FORTY SIX
POINT FOUR MILLION NOT PROVE SO
YOU'RE SPENDING THE MONEY IS NOT
APPROVED ON A WE CAN GET FROM --
AND THEN YOU GOT APRIL FINANCE
MATTER AT THIS POINT I'M SAYING
HOUSE OF THIS.
THIS MOMENT BASED ON THE
INFORMATION.
WE HAVE TODAY I CAN'T RECOMMEND
APPROVAL OF THIS PROPOSAL.
I CAN'T I MEAN.
THE AGAIN.
THERE'S NO PLAN.
THERE WAS NO WHERE THIS MONEY IS
GOING TO GO WHAT IT'S GOING TO
BE USED FOR ALL I HAVE IS A
NUMBER OF BODIES.
THERE WAS NO HOW IS THIS GOING
TO IMPACT THE WORK OF THE FUTURE.
IF IF YOU HAVE PLANS AND ALL THE
DIFFERENT AREAS WHERE THERE'S
KIOSKS OR WHETHER IT IS A STAFF
IN THE FIELD OFFICES OR THE I.
T. GREAT WE WOULD LOVE TO SEE IT.
WHERE I DON'T I DON'T THINK
WE'VE EVER SAID HEY?
DON'T GIVE US INFORMATION DON'T
GIVE US YOUR PLANTS.
IN FACT THAT'S BEEN THE ON GOING
REQUEST FROM THE COMMITTEE WHICH
WE HAVEN'T RECEIVED THE
INFORMATION.
THE OTHER POINT JUST TO GO BACK
I MEAN JUST TO TAKE A FIVE POINT
ON CHAOS.
AGAIN AS OF FEBRUARY TWENTY
EIGHTH BASED ON YOUR ROUGH
NUMBERS YOU KNOW.
EVERY KIOSKS WAS SEEING ABOUT --
THIRTEEN THIRTEEN HUNDRED FIFTY
TRANSACTIONS AND THEN AS OF
FEBRUARY TWENTY NINETEEN YOU'RE
SEEING ONLY ABOUT ELEVEN HUNDRED
TRANSACTIONS.
SO AS YOU'RE DEPLOYING MORE
KIOSK TO GETTING LESS USAGE PER
CHAOS IS NOT SO IT'S NOT EVEN
CLEAR.
YOUR THE DATA DOESN'T
NECESSARILY SUPPORT -- HEY WHAT
WE SHOULD BE DOING MORE CHAOS.
NO I DID MY TIME THAT IS CORRECT
AS IT RELATES TO AS YOU ROLL OUT
A NEW KIOSK IT'S REALLY THE
ADOPTION RATE IN FOR THE NEW
CHAOS WHEN THEY FIRST GO OUT.
THEY DON'T HAVE A HUGE UPTAKE
IT'S A MATTER MAKING SURE THE
COMMUNITY IS AWARE AND SO THAT'S
ONE OF THE BIG BIG POINTS AS IT
RELATES TO I KNOW THAT.
STRIKE COMMITMENT IN WORKING
WITH MARKETING THE DATE ON THAT.
AGAIN LIKE I THINK WE CAN ALWAYS
BE PERSUADED BY INFORMATION.
BY FAX.
WE CAN GET YOUR OTHER LIVE
THROUGH IT SO SOUTHERN.
THERE IS A SINGLE OPTIC RATE
THAT'S WHY WHAT'S THE WHAT'S THE
SLAUGHTER CREEK HOW HOW LONG
DOES IT TAKE FOR TO PICK UP YEAH
WE CAN GET YOU THAT THAT'S NO
PROBLEM.
HELLO THE TICKET TAKER I DON'T
HAVE THAT INFORMATION DIRECTLY
WITH ME. THREE MONTHS SIX MONTHS
I WOULD SAY PROBABLY DEPENDS ON
THE LOCATION FOR INSTANCE AS YOU
MAY KNOW ROUGH WE HAVE ONE IN
THE LIBRARY.
APPROACHING THERE'S I WOULD
PROBABLY SAY IT'S PROBABLY A
GOOD SIX MONTHS TO A YEAR.
AND FOR THE MOST OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE GONNA USE IT THE
VEHICLE REGISTRATION ARE GONNA
USE IT ONCE A YEAR.
BUT IT IS SIR ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY I ASKED THE VENDOR.
TO REVIEW THEIR METHODOLOGIES
AND AND ALSO PUT TOGETHER A
COMPREHENSIVE COMMUNICATIONS
PLAN BECAUSE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT -- THEY ARE INDEED --
ADVERTISE MARKETED AND ARE IN
VISIBLE PLACES AND IN HIGH
TRAFFIC PLACES AND IN USEFUL
PLACES THEY HAVE -- CONTRACTS
WITH MANY OTHER STATES AND THEY
PROVIDE THE SAME SERVICE AND
MANY OTHER STATES HAD AND AND
INDEED EVEN GREATER GREATER
TRANSACTION SERVICES.
WHAT WE WHICH IS GREAT I THINK
WE FORGET STRESS?
I JUST WANT TO RESPOND TO YOUR
PLACE COMMENTS AND PLEASE ON THE
FRONT OF DALE B. C. NOTIFICATION --
AS NOTED IT IF IF PRESS WILL BE
MISTER TO HAVE NOT YET RECEIVED
A LETTER BACK FROM JAIL BC
SAYING IT'S NOT APPROVED RIGHT
THIS IS THIS WAS A POTS SO THAT
WE CAN HAVE THIS HEARING.
IF WE WERE TO RECEIVE THAT AS
NOTED IN OUR JANUARY THIRD
LETTER.
YOU ASKED WHETHER GOING TO GET
THE MONEY THERE.
ARE LETTER INDICATED THAT
WITHOUT THIS AUGMENTATION DMB IS
GONNA HAVE TO ELIMINATE STAFFING --
TO THE OVERTIME SOME OF THE
SATURDAY SERVICES -- AND THEY'RE
GONNA HAVE TO REDUCE OUR BASE
BUDGET AND SO THAT IS ALL THAT
WOULD HAVE AN IMPACT IF IF THIS
FUNDING IS NOT APPROVED AND I
CAN ONLY IMAGINE THE PHONE CALLS
WE WILL ALL BE GETTING I'M.
IF THAT HAPPENS WITH REGARDS TO
YOU SAID YOU'D BE PERSUADED BY
DATA WERE HAPPY TO PROVIDE THE
DATA AND THAT WE CAN -- WE HAVE
BEEN PROVIDING THE MONTHLY WAIT
WAIT TIME REPORTS AND AS YOU
KNOW WE CAN TRACK FROM THE
TICKET BUT NOT NECESSARILY.
PRIOR TO THAT AND WE WE WOULD WE
WOULD APPRECIATE ANY.
QUESTIONS AS TO HOW WE CAN
IMPROVE WE'RE APART WE'RE WE'RE
GETTING IF YOU'RE NOT GETTING
PHONE CALLS RAPID WRECKED OUR
PHONE CALLS TO BECAUSE WE'RE
GETTING PLAN SO I DON'T THINK
WE'RE GONNA GET ANYMORE PHONE
CALLS.
FOR OUR AND IN FACT IF YOU
HAVEN'T VISITED A DMB REALLY
REALLY I I THINK IT'S SOMETHING
YOU SHOULD ALL DO A SIX IN THE
MORNING.
BECAUSE THAT'S SOMETHING THAT I
DO.
SO ARE.
IF IF THAT IS A THREAT THAT'S
FINE I AM.
YOU KNOW AGAIN.
THAT THAT'S WHERE WE'RE AT I
THINK I THINK.
THEM JUST FINISH SO I THINK.
I SAY THIS TO REITERATE THE LACK
OF SERIOUSNESS THE DEPARTMENT
TOOK.
UPON THIS YEAR.
IT WAS CLEAR WE WERE WAITING FOR
THIS HEARING TO APPROVE.
THIS YEAR'S MONEY AND TO GET A
SENSE OF WHERE WE WOULD BE FOR
THE TWO HUNDRED FORTY NINE
DEPARTMENT DID NOT COME FORWARD.
WITH A PLAN.
THEY DID NOT COME FORWARD WITH
ANY SPECIFIC INFORMATION OUTSIDE
OF A BUDGET RIGHT.
BY A SPECIFIC DEPLOYMENT PLAN
HOW THEY WERE GOING TO ADDRESS.
THE DEFICIENCIES THAT WE KNOW
EXISTED THE AGAIN THE AUDITOR'S
CODIFIED WHAT WE KNEW WAS
ALREADY GOING ON SO I I
APPRECIATE THAT THE AUDITORS --
WERE ABLE TO CODIFY IN A
SINGULAR DOCUMENT THE PROBLEMS.
I DON'T THINK ANY OF US WERE
SURPRISED.
ANYBODY WHO'S BEEN IN A DMV IS
NOT SURPRISED BY ANY OF THIS
INFORMATION.
SO KNOWING THAT THIS INFORMATION
EXISTS NOW YOU HAVE A DOCUMENT
SO YOU COULD YOU HAVE ROAD MAP.
BUT AGAIN.
CLEARLY THE DEPARTMENT THE
AGENCY DID NOT PREPARE. FOR THIS
HERE THIS HAS BEEN ON THE RECORD
THEY THAT YOU KNEW THIS IS
COMING UP FOR MONTHS
[inaudible]
SO AGAIN.
WE NEED A PLAN.
WE NEED A CLEAR DELINEATION
WHERE THE MONEY'S GOING WHAT
IT'S GOING TO BE SPENT ON ARE
YOU CAN GIVE IT DOWN TO THE
FIELD OFFICE I DON'T CARE IF YOU
GIVE IT DOWN TO THE COMPUTER.
THERE'S NEVER BEEN A TIME.
DURING DURING WHICH I'VE BEEN
CHAIRMAN BY SAYING -- YOU'VE
GIVEN ME TOO MUCH INFORMATION
THIS IS WAY TOO MUCH DATA.
GIVE IT TO ME A FAIR DOESN'T
HAVE TIME TO REVIEW IT I HAVE
NOTHING BUT FREE TIME.
I'D BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO DO IT
RIGHT I I SPEND MY WEEKEND
READING THIS AUDIT COVER TO
COVER I FOUND A GREAT.
SITE JUST AGAIN JUST TO COMMEND
AUDITING.
BUT THE FACT THAT.
THE DEPARTMENT DID NOT SHOW THE
COMMITTEE THE RESPECT TOGETHER.
A WELL THOUGHT OUT PLAN.
IT WILL FOR PROPOSAL KNOWING
THAT THE TWO LETTERS HAVE NOT
BEEN APPROVED.
AND WE'RE BEING HELD FOR THIS
HEARING.
IS VERY TROUBLING HIGHLY
PROBLEMATIC.
AND THE FACT THAT THE MONEY THAT
WAS APPROVED.
WAS SPENT AND WHAT'S NOT SPENT
APPROPRIATELY AGAIN PER THE
AUDIT STAFF.
MONEY WAS SPENT PEOPLE WERE
TRYING.
AGAIN TABLETS.
TABLETS WERE BOUGHT NOT USE.
THE TEXT MESSAGING.
PROBABLY GONNA GET.
THIS IS JUST THESE ARE JUST THE
HIGHLIGHTS WE COULD GO ON I
COULD BE HERE TILL MISTER
FRAZIER DINNER IS OVER AND WE
COULD KEEP WE CAN JUST GO DOWN
THE LIST.
BUT AGAIN I THINK YOU GET THE
PICTURE BUT AGAIN.
I JUST WANT TO REITERATE THAT IF
THE DEPARTMENT DOES NOT BRING
FORWARD.
HI.
AND LEFT WITH NO CHOICE BUT TO
INFORM OUR DEAL BC CHAIR.
THAT WE ARE REJECTING.
THE LETTER.
CAN WE WILL END AT THIS POINT
RIGHT NOW THE ASSEMBLY CANNOT
INCLUDE THIS APPROPRIATION
REQUEST OR THE FORTY SIX MILLION
THAT YOU ASK FOR FOR THIS YEAR.
IN THE OUR VERSION OF THE BUDGET.
TYLER HOW HOW ANY CLEAR I COULD
BE.
SO WHEN CAN WE GET THE
INFORMATION WE WOULD LIKE.
WE CAN WORK WITH AMERICA THERE
IS -- THAT SOUNDS LIKE YOU NEED
A LITTLE MORE DETAIL THAN WHAT'S
IN THE FINANCE LETTER AS AT
LEAST ON PAGE TWENTY THREE THAT
BREAKS OUT ALL THE MONEY --
HELLO HELLO WHERE WHERE THESE
PEOPLE GO ON FIELD OFFICES I
WANT TO KNOW -- WHAT HOW HOW
THIS IS GONNA -- HOW THIS IS
GONNA ACCOMPLISH EACH OF THE
GOALS THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT?
YEAH I WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE
PLAN IS.
LIKE LIKE I LOVE THE SPREAD SHE
DON'T GET ME WRONG THAT THE
SPREADSHEETS GREAT.
RIGHT WITHOUT A PLAN.
AND UNDER NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE.
YOU DON'T HAVE.
THE ENTIRE STATE INTO UPROAR
ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT'S
PERFORMANCE WE CAN HAVE A
DISCUSSION JUST BASED ON THE
SPREADSHEET.
THESE ARE NOT NORMAL SYMBOL AND
FORTY THESE ARE NORMAL
CIRCUMSTANCES BUT THEY'VE BEEN
GOING ON FOR TOO LONG.
SO THAT NEEDS TO CHANGE.
THIS IS THIS IS NOT ANY
DIFFERENT.
I MEAN WE'RE HAVING THE SAME
THIS IS LIKE GROUNDHOG DAY WE'RE
HAVING THE SAME HERE WE HAD IN
AUGUST.
IT'S EXTRAORDINARILY INCREDIBLY
DISAPPOINTING.
I CAN'T EVEN TELL YOU HOW HOW
DISAPPOINTED I AM.
BECAUSE WE DISCUSS THIS IN
AUGUST.
AND WE SAID HEY WE'RE GONNA
WE'RE GONNA GREEN LIGHT THIS
LETTER AND WE TOOK GRIEF IN THE
PRESS. FOR GREEN LIGHTING THIS
LATTER END SO NOT ONLY DID YOU
NOT REWARD OUR FAITH.
YOU DEMONSTRATED THAT WE
SHOULDN'T TRUST THE DEPARTMENT.
TO DO WHAT IT SAYS.
SO WHAT MAKING THE SAME MISTAKE
TWICE.
SO YOU SEE YOU BETTER COME WITH
AN INCREDIBLE DETAIL WHERE THIS
IS GOING HOW'S IT GOING TO BE
SPENT WHO'S GOING TO BE
RESPONSIBLE.
AND THEN I WANT TO KNOW WHAT
PEOPLE ARE RESPONSIBLE.
FOR BECAUSE THE DIRECTORS G
AT BEAT BEAT YOUR YOUR THE
YOUR THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR IN
CHARGE OF THE MONEY.
SO -- SO LET ME ASK YOU HOW COME
TABLETS WERE BOUGHT THE NOT USED.
YOU'RE THE ONLY ONE WHO WAS HERE
AUGUST.
YEAH AND I WOULD SAY THAT THAT
TABLETS WERE WERE UTILIZED
TABLETS WERE DEPLOYED OUT TO A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TO THE OFFICES
THEN WENT ALL OUT TO ALL
HUNDREDS OF ME WHAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN USED.
I THINK OF THAT RELATE TO IT THE
CONSISTENCY CHALLENGE AND SOME
OF THE TABLETS MAY HAVE BEEN
USED IN THE ARMY KNOWLEDGE TEST
AREA AND NOT AT THE FRONT FRONT
AREA ANSWER LIKE THAT THE PEOPLE
TAKE THE ARMY KNOWLEDGE TEST.
WILL CHECK THEM AND GET THEM
APPOINTMENTS THERE SO SHE WAS A
DIFFERENT YOU HAVE NO WAY.
OF KNOWING WHICH TABLETS GUY USE
WENT.
TELLING YOU DO.
NOT.
WE DO HAVE A WAY AND SO WE HAVE
A MECHANISM OR WE CAN TRACK THE
LAST TIME THAT THE TABLET WAS.
LONG GONE AND WE'RE WORKING WITH
OUR IT INFRASTRUCTURE TO FIND
OUT NOT USUALLY WHAT WAS LYING
ON THE TIME THE OFFICE FOR AND
THEN.
MEET UP WITH A FEW YEARS HAVE
YOU DEPLOY.
THERE ARE HOW MANY IN TOTAL --
FIVE HUNDRED YEAH I THOUGHT
WHAT'S PROPER PUT PERCENT OF
BEING USED.
LAST THE LAST TIME I GOT A
REPORT IT WAS A HUNDRED AND
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND TWENTY EIGHT
TABLETS OVER.
ABOUT SEVENTY OFFICES I I THINK
OF ONE IMPORTANT THING TO NOTE
AND A TABLET MAY JUST BE AN
OFFICE MAYBE YOU SEE ONE TABLET
WAITING FOR THE OTHER TO CHARGE
SO I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT TO
KNOW IN A SMALLER OFFICE.
AND A LARGER OFFICE YOU.
I DON'T KNOW TOTALLY I CHARGE MY
TABLET OVERNIGHT.
SO -- AGAIN -- SO ALL THE FIVE
HUNDRED YOU AT A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY TWO TABLETS OF BEING
USUALLY.
YEAH SO SO WHAT'S WHAT'S THE
WHAT ARE THE OTHER.
THREE HUNDRED TOM WAS DOING
BEING CHARGED.
THAT'S OUR TRAINER IMMEDIATE
RIGHT NOW TWENTY IS THE ROOT
CAUSE WHY ARE THEY NOT BEING
USED AS A TRAINING.
IN WHERE WE'RE ON THAT PATH AND
I DO WANT TO TALK ABOUT TEXT
MESSAGES AS WELL.
SO YES WE SHARE YOUR CONCERN
THERE ON TEXT MESSAGES ARMY
UNDER UTILIZED.
YOU KNOW AND WE ARE WORKING TO
KEEP MATIC ASPECT OF SPEAKING
YES SECRETARY ABOUT HER SAID OUR
VENDOR WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
FIND OUT HOW MANY TEXT MESSAGES
ARE SENT HAPPENING DAY OR TO
SPECIFIC PART OF TIME.
BUT WE CAN'T TIE IT BACK TO THE
OFFICE AND THAT IS THE PATH THAT
WERE GOING DOWN THE CAN MANAGE.
TO TIE IT BACK TO THE OFFICE FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY.
WHO'S DOING IT WHEN THE THINGS
THAT I'M USING GIVE SEVEN
THOUSAND CUSTOMERS TODAY.
HOW MANY I'M SORRY YES SEVEN
THOUSAND CUSTOMERS TODAY RIGHT
WE WENT WE WENT BACK KNOW HOW
MANY CUSTOMERS THE OTHER DAY?
HOUSE A WEEK I'M SORRY ALL.
CUSTOMER TODAY ANYWHERE BETWEEN
SEVENTY AND EIGHTY TO EIGHTY
FIVE THOUSAND RIGHT PERFECT
SERVICE SEVENTY EIGHTY FIVE YEAH
RIGHT.
I APOLOGIZE HOW ME TEXT MESSAGES
HELLO.
LAST THE DAY I J. YESTERDAY WHEN
I LOOKED WE HAD.
BUT TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND OR SENT
OUT.
BUT I DO WANT TO BUT HAVE YET
NOT YOU HAVE TO HIT A THRESHOLD
IN ORDER FOR THE TEXT MESSAGE TO
BE SENT OUT.
SO EVEN THOUGH I MAY FIND OUT
FROM ONE OF MY WAIT TIME DOESN'T
TAKES THE THE TIME THE MESSAGE
WOULD BE SENT OUT SO I THINK
IT'S FAIR THAT WE WE HAVE A
BUFFER IN THAT FORMULA AS WELL.
AND AND THAT'S AND THAT'S FINE
BUT AGAIN BUT LIKE I THINK MY
CONCERN IS.
THESE QUESTIONS ARE GETTING.
ANSWERED AND BUDGET COMMITTEE
WITH NOT NOT AS MUCH DETAIL AS
ONE I WOULD LIKE BUT WHAT IT
DEMONSTRATES IS THAT THERE'S NOT
AS MUCH ATTENTION.
AS WE WOULD LIKE ON THESE FRIES
VICIOUS BECAUSE WHEN YOU AS A
DEPARTMENT CAME FORWARD IN FRONT
OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
LAST TIME HE SAID THESE ARE THE
THINGS THAT WE ARE TO POINT THIS
IS WERE SPENDING THE MONEY RIGHT.
SO THEN YOU HAVE YOU HIRED -- F.
R. FORGOT HOW MANY STAFF.
BE HIRED. NINE HUNDRED STAFF
THANK YOU NEITHER STAFF DID
RECEIVE TRAINING.
THAT THEY WERE THE PRIMARY HOW
MANY HOW MAY RECEIVE.
I BELIEVE THE I DID INDICATE
THAT 20% OF THE FOLKS THAT THEY
HAD TAUGHT YOU HAD NOT.
AND YOU'RE RIGHT LOOKING BACK IN
PERSPECTIVE WE ARE HIRING
QUICKLY.
WE HAD A LARGE NUMBER OF ON
FORTY WE DIDN'T HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE NUMBER OF TRAINING
SESSIONS THAT WE NEEDED FOR
ACTON ROBIN ARE WORKING TOGETHER
TO YOU.
PART OF THAT ASK IS FOR MORE
TRAINER SO THAT WE CAN HAVE THAT.
BUT I THINK LONG TERM WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT DIFFERENT MODALITIES
IT CAN'T JUST BE THIS THIS
CLASSROOM DIDACTIC INSTRUCTION
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT LEARNING
MANAGEMENT ALL OF THAT IS IS
IT'S PART OF OUR ASKING.
I KNOW IT'S A IT'S A TOUGH TASK
I I UNDERSTAND THAT BUT LOOK AT
WHEN WE'RE WE'RE HAPPY TO
ENTERTAIN THE THE VARIETIES OF
THINGS BY.
THE THE CHALLENGES IS THERE'S A
COMPLETE LACK OF CONFIDENCE THAT
IT WILL ACTUALLY BE IMPLEMENTED
AGAIN.
YOUR I CAN DIRECTOR GAVE ALMOST
THE IDENTICAL SPEECH THAT WAS
GIVEN IN AUGUST [inaudible]
ALMOST VERBATIM [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
AGAIN.
ALL I CAN DO IS THIS IS WHAT I
HEARD LAST LAST TIME WE HAD THIS
HEARING.
IF WE GET THE SAME RESULT THAT'S
COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE.
SO HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT WE'RE
GONNA GET A DIFFERENCE ALL.
ABSOLUTELY WITH MY NEW SHERRY
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A PLAN WILL
HAVE THE STATISTICS IN THE
MATRIX AND THE BENCH MARKING.
ON MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT YOU'VE
ASKED FOR AND WE WILL HAVE -- A
MUCH MORE ROBUST AND MORE
THOROUGH AND REPLY.
I'M I'M A TECH I MIGHT STRIKE
FORCE PERSON I AM I'M SAYING
THAT ON BEHALF OF THE OKAY BUT
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT RATHER
SECRETARY AND I WANT TO HEAR
FROM THE THREE OF THEM AND
BECAUSE CAN YOU CHECK AGAIN.
THE ONLY PERSON WHO SAID THEY
WERE DOING STUFF GUESS WHAT
SHE'S NOT HERE RIGHT NOW.
FROM LOOKING AT THE THREE
DEPARTMENT PEOPLE FROM
DEPARTMENT HOW DO WE INSURE THIS
GETS DONE.
I MEAN YOU HEARD THE AUDITOR
OKAY THIS ABOUT LEADERSHIP THIS
IS ABOUT YOUR TEAM.
DOING THIS.
THAT'S WHY I'M LOOKING AT THE
THREE OF YOU OW DID THE THREE
OF YOU GET THIS DONE.
PRESSURE TEAM.
I'M I'M I'M STILL WAITING FOR AN
ANSWER SO.
FIRST WERE WORKING ON THE
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLAN WHICH
WILL HAVE SOME MILESTONES AND I
THINK YOU'LL SEE SOME SPECIFIC
DATES.
COMING OUT WITH THE CARS THE
TARGETED ACTIVITY THAT WE'RE
GONNA DRESS AND WHETHER THEY'LL
BE DONE BY THE BY WHAT THEY DO
MAY -- SIXTY DAYS WERE LOOKING
AT AND THE MAIN THIS THAT'S
GOING TO BE COMING OUT SO SO I I
I WOULD I WOULD.
WRECK RECOMMEND YOU GET IT DONE
BEFORE WE CLOSE DOWN OUR VERSION
OF THE BUDGET BECAUSE IF IT'S
NOT DONE BEFORE THEN IF IT'S NOT
THEN TO OUR SATISFACTION.
YOUR APPROPRIATION WELL I I WILL
GUARANTEE IT WILL NOT BE IN OUR
PERSONAL BUDGET.
I WOULD SAY -- SECONDARILY -- WE
HAVE DOCUMENTS THAT SUPPORTED
THIS BUDGET REQUEST AND WE JUST
NEED TO GO BACK AND PROVIDE YOU
THE MORE DETAILED INFORMATION.
WITH OURS THE BUDGET REQUEST AND
SO WE WILL WORK WITH OUR
PARTNERS AT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND WITH THE STAFF THERE
WERE SO MANY INFORMATION AND
PULL THE DETAILED INFORMATION
FOR YOU.
SUCH A RIGHT NOW THIS IS FAIR AS
BUSIEST TIME OF THE YEAR SO SHE
MAY NOT HAVE TIME. TO GO THROUGH
THAT LEVEL OF DETAIL SO I'LL BE
REVIEWING THAT [inaudible]
AND I DON'T REALLY LIKE TO BE
GOING BACK AND FORTH FOR MORE
INFORMATION.
SO MY REQUEST TO YOU IS.
GIVE ME EVERYTHING YOU GOT.
LET'S TRY TO DO IT ONE TIME.
DOES THAT SOUND FAIR SOUNDS FAIR
AND HAPPY TO MEET AND HAVE
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS.
AND HOW SOON CAN WE HAVE THE
WHEN YOU WANT.
I WANTED TO TODAY.
I WANTED IT LIKE A WEEK AGO SO I
CAN GET READY FOR THIS HEARING
SO WE COULD APPROVE THE FORTY
SIX MILLION YOU ASKED.
FOR WE CAN'T DO THAT I'M GONNA
SEND A LETTER TO JAIL B. C.
TONIGHT.
SO WHEN YES THAT'S WHAT I WANTED.
SO IT'S A GREAT. SEVEN MILLION A
QUICK.
THIS FRAZIER THANK YOU MISTER.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS WHEN WE
WERE DOING SB ONE WITH THE
CALTRANS THE AGENCY WHEN THEY
WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
PERFORMANCE METRICS AND WHAT NOT.
WE REQUIRE THEM ALSO BECAUSE
THEY WERE GOING TO GET LARGE
SUMS OF MONEY TO BE [inaudible]
EFFECTIVE.
WAS THAT THEY HAD TO PROVIDE US
WITH A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
IN SAVINGS.
I THINK IN YOUR PLAN YOU ALSO
NEED TO SHOW WE'RE GONNA.
CAPTURE EFFICIENCIES AND NOT
JUST BE SPENDING LARGE AMOUNT OF
MONIES TO BE CATCHING SO IT HAS
TO BE BOTH WAYS -- AND AGAIN.
AS I MENTIONED BEFORE.
WE'VE BEEN DOWN THIS ROAD BEFORE
WE'VE BEEN TOLD THAT THINGS ARE
GOING TO BE ACCOMPLISHED.
I AM DISHEARTENED AT THE
INFORMATION HAS AMBER BEEN
PROVIDED AS EXPECTED -- BUT I
THINK THAT. ONE OF THE THINGS
I'VE YOU KNOW MY MY POSITION AS
THE POLICY CHAIR IS.
IS THE LEVEL OF SERVICE THAT MY
CONSTITUENTS DESERVE FOR THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT WE'RE
SPENDING.
AND IF I WAS TO DO A CASH
BENEFIT ANALYSIS -- I WOULD LOOK
AT ANOTHER WAITED FUND THIS.
I WOULD LOOK AWAY ANOTHER WAY TO
MAN THIS PROJECT -- COME FROM
THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
I'M NOT GETTING A VALUE RIGHT
NOW.
AND SO IN THAT [inaudible]
VEIN -- WE'VE ALSO IGNORE SOME
LEGISLATION THAT.
VENDORS WERE GAMING THE SYSTEM
ON APPOINTMENTS.
WERE HANDLING THAT -- MAKING
SURE THAT.
THAT LAWS CODIFIED CONCERNING
LAW THE WHICH IS MAKING SURE WE
CAN TRY TO MAKE SURE THIS AN
EFFECTIVE USE OF YOUR
APPOINTMENT SCHEDULE FOR THE
CONSTITUENTS -- YOU GO TO BE
MORE FORTHCOMING TO US -- WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY IN AND AS
I SHARED WITH YOU I FULLY INTEND
TO GO TO YOUR STAND DOWN.
WITH YOUR EMPLOYEES.
SHARE WITH THEM MY FAX NUMBER
ONE BUT ALSO.
HOPING THAT THEY RETURN THE
FAVOR AND WORK WITH US.
THAT THE CONSTITUENTS TO COME IN.
HAVE AN EXPECTATION THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO BE TAKEN CARE OF AND SO.
AGAIN.
IN SOLITARY LIMIT MY CHAIR I AM
THERE I MEAN JUST I HAVE TO BE
THERE AS I MENTIONED EARLIER --
YOUR OF YOUR THAT HERE THE FACE
OF GOVERNMENT.
I'VE SAID THAT BEFORE.
AND RIGHT NOW WE'RE NOT GETTING --
THE VALUE.
AND I I JUST NEED REASSURANCES.
BECAUSE AND OTHER AGENCIES IF
THE REPORTS ARE LATE THERE'S NO
ACCOUNTABILITY THEY JUST BLOW US
OFTEN.
YOU KNOW I THINK CARP HAS ONE
THAT WAS DOING DECEMBER AND NOW
THEY'RE TELLING ME IT'S GONNA
COME IN.
AUGUST.
I NEEDED THAT REPORT SO I COULD
DO.
OF A PROPER JOB AS THE CHAIRMAN
OF OF JUDGING LEGISLATION GOING
THROUGH.
THEY'VE HAD THEY'VE TIED MY
HANDS [inaudible]
SO.
WHAT HAPPENS IS IS?
YOU'RE GONNA LEAVE PROBABLY.
AND GOING TO BIGGER AND BETTER
THINGS AND WE'VE ACKNOWLEDGED
THIS JOB DOESN'T PAY.
I KNOW IF MONEY.
THE WERE LEFT HOLDING THE BAG
I'VE GOT SIX MORE YEARS HERE
[inaudible]
SB TURNOVERS.
I SAID THREE ONE IS IN A FINAL
THOUGHT I'M.
I THINK A NUMBER OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE SHARED WITH YOU
THAT DMV ISSUES AN DMP
COMPLAINTS ARE YOU KNOW BECAUSE
THE TOP OF THE LIST IN TERMS AS
DISTRICT ISSUES NOT TRY MENTION
THIS YESTERDAY BUT I'M THE
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMITTEE WE DID
A SURVEY OF DISTRICT OFFICES
ACROSS THE STATE.
YOU PROBABLY WON'T SURPRISE YOU
TO LEARN THAT -- EIGHTY ONE IN
81% OF OFFICES DMV AS EITHER THE
NUMBER ONE OR NUMBER.
TWO COMPLAINT ITSELF.
WELL NOW WE'VE GOT A BIG ISSUE
AND I ALSO KNOW WHEN I WHEN I
KNOWLEDGE THAT.
THE BOTH OF YOU WERE WERE
BROUGHT IN TO TRY TO WRITE A
FOUNDERING SHIP.
AND YOU KNOW.
CALL THE PARKING AT A TIME WHEN
PERHAPS THE SHIP WAS SINKING SO
I DO APPRECIATE YOU STEPPING
INTO THAT BREACH I'M.
I THINK I'VE GOT.
CAN OF THESE THREE REQUESTS LIKE
FOR MY PERSPECTIVE I'M NUMBER
ONE IS LIKE I SAID YOU A PROJECT
PLAN FOR THE TOP FIVE PROJECTS
WE DISCUSSED AND IN MY MIND AND
GOD.
GENTLEMAN FROM DMV IT'S IT'S NOT
A MATTER OF MORE DETAIL THAN
THIS IT'S SOMETHING DIFFERENT
THAN THAT IT'S SOMETHING THAT
LETS US GO ARE WE ACTUALLY ON
TRACK TO DELIVER THESE IN LARGE
SCALE.
BIG PROJECTS THAT HISTORICALLY
HAVE AN ACTUAL ABLE TO DELIVER
SO THAT'S ONE NUMBER TWO ON THE
TECHNOLOGY INFRASTRUCTURE SIDE I
THINK WE TALKED A LITTLE BIT AND
YOU SAID YOU HAD THAT THE FIVE
YEAR.
TECHNOLOGY PLAN.
ISN'T SOMETHING YOU CAN DO IN
THE SHORT TERM BUT I PERSONALLY
THINK WE HAVE TO BE A LOT MORE
AMBITIOUS THAN IT IT SOUNDS LIKE.
WE DON'T HAVE FIVE YEARS TO
REBUILD THIS PLATFORM IS WHAT IT
SOUNDS LIKE TO ME AND THE NUMBER
THREE I WOULD LIKE.
I AM TO SUGGEST A REQUEST A
REVIEW OF THE MOTOR VOTER.
PROGRAM AND THAT PERHAPS IS JUST
THE INSTEON AUDIT THAT'S THAT'S
ALREADY UNDERWAY BUT I WOULD
LOVE TO RECEIVE A COPY OF THAT
SO WE CAN.
JUST MAKE SURE THAT THERE ARE NO
UNDERLYING ISSUES THERE THAT
ALSO NEED TO BE ADDRESSED I SAID.
THAT WOULD BE MY PARTING THREE
REQUESTS ISING BEFORE IT THANKS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO I THINK JUST TO SUMMARIZE.
WE HAVE A BUDGET REQUEST AT THIS
POINT IS LACKING [inaudible]
HOME.
THIS IS THE COMPLETE DEFINITION
OF INSANITY AND WANT TO QUOTE
OUR GOVERNOR BECAUSE HE USED
THIS QUOTE QUITE OFTEN WHEN HE
WAS MAYOR.
THE DEFINITION OF INSANITY AS WE
ALL KNOW IS DOING THE SAME THING
OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND
EXPECTING A DIFFERENT RESULT.
SO WE'RE NOT GONNA MAKE THAT
MISTAKE.
SO AGAIN WE'RE ASKING THE DMV.
TO TAKE THAT FEEDBACK TO TAKE
THE CUSTOMER'S FEEDBACK TO KEEP
ALL THESE THINGS AND I THINK
WHAT'S WHAT'S SAD IS.
IN THE TOUGHEST PART FOR ME IS I
DON'T I JUST DON'T KNOW IF YOU
IN THE CENTRAL OFFICE REALLY
UNDERSTAND.
WHAT IS GOING ON AT THE
DIFFERENT FIELD OFFICE?
BECAUSE WHEN I'M THERE AND I'LL
TELL YOU MY COLLEAGUES WILL
REITERATE I I SEE A LOT OF HARD
WORKING PEOPLE.
THEY ARE WORKING REALLY HARD
THEY GOT LINES.
OUT THE DOOR THEY'RE JUST TRYING.
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
THERE.
MANY OF WHOM ARE VERY UPSET
BECAUSE OF OF HOW LONG THE LINES
ARE AND THINGS THAT ARE
COMPLETELY OUT OF THE CONTROL OF
OF THE STAFF.
AND AND THEY DO THAT EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
IN A WE CAN'T SIT HERE FROM OUR
COMFORTABLE PLACE AND SACRAMENTO
STATE THAT'S OKAY. TO CONTINUE
THAT.
WHAT YOU'VE PUT TOGETHER AS A
PLAN?
HAS DEMONSTRATED TO ME.
YOU'RE NOT LISTENING. TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
FROM OUR CONSTITUENTS YOU'RE NOT
LISTENING TO WHAT'S HAPPENING.
IN THE FIELD OFFICE.
SO WHEN YOU PUT TOGETHER A PLAN
THAT SAYS IN DEMONSTRATE THAT
YOU'VE HEARD US.
BECAUSE WE'VE HEARD OUR
CONSTITUENTS.
WE HEAR THE I GO TO THE GROCERY
STORE I GET THIS.
I GO ON PUBLIC I GET THIS I MEAN
YOU PROBABLY NONE OF YOU I DON'T
KNOW LAST ME THAT ANY OF YOU
WERE STOPPED AT A GROCERY STORE
TO TALK ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
SO SO FAR AS A FINANCE TO SAY
YES.
THANK THAT'S GOOD.
THAT DEMONSTRATES THE
THOUGHTFULNESS. TO REALLY GO AND
ATTACK THIS ISSUE.
THESE FIELD OFFICES ARE UNDER
SIEGE THEY'RE JUST IS LESS LIKE
THEY'RE LIKE AN EMERGENCY ROOM
THEY'RE JUST TRIAGE EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL.
JUST CONTINUES THAT [inaudible]
ATTITUDE.
JUST CONTINUES THAT BUSINESS AS
USUAL TRIAGE AND IS THE SAME OLD
SAME.
IT DOESN'T GET US TO WHERE WE
NEED TO GO.
IT DOESN'T DEMONSTRATE THAT YOU
YOU HEARD US DEPLOYING.
THE VARIETIES OF THINGS THAT
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT.
SO I THINK THAT'S WHAT WE NEED.
ANOTHER NEW DIRECTORS ONLY THAT
CONVERTS ONLY BEEN THERE FOR A
FEW MONTHS AND YOU KNOW THAT'S
THAT'S SO I THINK YOU YOU KNOW
YOU HAVE EXCUSE BUT THE REST THE
TO YOUR TEAM HASN'T.
ONLY BEEN FOR TWO MONTHS.
AND THE OTHER THREE THOUSAND
PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING IN
SACRAMENTO HAVE BEEN THERE FOR
JUST [inaudible] TWO MONTHS
[inaudible]
SO THIS.
HOUSE TO CHANGE.
HAS TO CHANGE -- KIND OF WE HAVE
TO TAKE MORE DRASTIC MEASURES
THAT WE HAVE TO DO THAT.
YOU HEARD MISS SMITH.
IT OUT OF THE BOX IDEA
[inaudible]
LET'S [inaudible]
DECENTRALIZED.
MAYBE THAT'S WHAT WE DO.
BUT WE NEED TO DECENTRALIZE
BECAUSE WHAT.
I THINK WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
NEW THINGS THE WORKERS WHATEVER
DON'T GUESS WHAT IT'S NOT
WORKING.
THE WORKING FOR US IS NOT
WORKING FOR YOU I DON'T THINK I
DON'T THINK ANYBODY IS SITTING
HERE THE SYSTEM THAT WE ARE
PROUD OF SO.
IN THE END UNTIL WE GET
SOMETHING THAT IS BACKED UP.
BY SOME SERIOUS THINK IN IN
LISTENING AND DEMONSTRATES THAT
YOU'VE HEARD OUR FEEDBACK YOU
PER CONSTITUENTS FEEDBACK.
WE'RE WE'RE NOT TO DO THAT WE'RE
NOT TO MAKE THE SAME MISTAKE
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT. TO HAVE TO
COME IN CALL YOU BACK IN THREE
MONTHS AND BE LIKE OKAY SO.
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT'S WHAT'S BEEN
DONE WHO'S BEEN TRAINED HOW MANY
KIDS LIKE WHAT YOUR DOG WE HAVE
TO DO THIS EVERY THREE MONTHS
[inaudible]
IN COMMITTEE.
SO AGAIN -- YOU KNOW LOOK FOR TO
NEXT WEEK.
GET YOUR PROPOSAL READING.
AND WE WE WILL DISCUSS BUT I
THINK THAT WILL BE IT IF IT'S
NOT UP TO SNUFF WE'RE NOT
APPROVED.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE WE ARE JOINING.
BUDGET COMMITTEE SUBSETS.
IT WOULD BE FREE -- BUT YEAH